hey guys welcome to this front-end full
course video
now front-end development is one of the
most commonly heard phrases today now
front-end development is basically the
part of web development that involves
coding and creating the front-end
elements of a website
now the front end is typically what the
end user or the client interacts with
so in this video we're going to be
learning all about front-end languages
and libraries
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what we'll be learning today
first we look at a complete tutorial on
version control systems that is git and
github
once you're familiar with that we'll
move on to understanding the basic
front-end language that is html
we'll also look at how to implement html
registration forms
moving ahead we'll look at a detailed
tutorial on css after that we look at
javascript and how to add interactivity
to our web applications
now javascript offers some really cool
libraries and frameworks for front-end
development
so first we learn react.js which is a
javascript library and moving ahead
we'll understand how angular is used to
build apps
so now that you know what's in store for
you let's go ahead and jump right in
hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to delve into git
and what it actually is and how it fits
within your devops stack so a little
scenario before using get one of the
challenges that a lot of developers and
development teams would have had is
developers would be working on different
types of code whether it was database
code whether it was python or whether
it's java or net and they would have a
central server that they'd be pushing
all of their source code in but there
was little or no communication that was
actually going on in between all the
developers you know the challenge you
had with that scenario is that when
people would be checking in code you
could be like you know there'd be
conflicts and you'd have to roll back
different code versions and this is
really kind of the challenge that git
addresses git is a tool that allows all
of the developers no matter what stack
they're working in to have access to all
of the code and it makes it much more
effective at being able to have
development teams work on small medium
or even massive applications and some of
the biggest applications out there are
managed through a get distributed server
environment so let's jump into what
we'll be covering so you have a clear
understanding of the value that you're
going to get out of watching this
presentation so we're going to go
through devops and the tools have
available for devops we'll talk about
what version control means within a
devops environment and cover the two
different types of version control
centralized and distributed and then
we're going to zero in on git which is a
really fantastic distributed version
control system and we're gonna go
through understand the features workflow
branches and commands in git we're gonna
give you a demo and then summarize all
the activities at the end of the the
presentation so what is devops well this
is one of my favorite questions i love
the idea of what devops is so devops
really is a culture of being able to
deliver solutions faster where your
development teams and your operation
teams work effectively together the idea
is to be able to continuously build out
solutions and have testing codes that's
built into your solutions so that no
matter where they are in the stage of
the integration and deployment life
cycle they're always being tested and
you can always have code being ready to
be released out the idea is that instead
of having big releases that you'd have
maybe once every two weeks or once a
month that you would actually have a
continuous stream of releases because
you always have code that is being
tested you have your network that's been
tested you have your environment being
tested and you'll be able to provide
feedback directly to the appropriate
person whether they're in devs or
whether they're in ops to be able to be
successful at being able to deliver
solutions faster the bottom line your
dev team things like operations and your
operations team begin to feel like think
like developers it's really a fantastic
way of being able to speed up delivery
and have your team just think and feel
and act in a different cultural
environment so let's have a look at some
of the tools that are available to you
in devops environments if we look at
devops it's really kind of split into
two areas the dev side you have building
code planning and testing and then on
your upside you have release deployment
operating and monitoring but the tools
really all interact with each other and
what's really great is that the tools
are either open source or very very low
in cost in fact most of the tools you're
seeing in front of you right now are
open source tools which means there's no
licensing to you and you can actually
effectively manage them and implement
them within your team right now so let's
have a look at some of the dev tools
that you have for doing code versioning
and so some of the tools that you may
have used in the past uh include
subversion team foundation service and
git these are all different types of
version control software that you have
out there one of the oldest ones is
subversion it's a centralized version
control system it's one of the tools i
used years ago it really is good at
doing what it's supposed to do which is
just a very simple version controlled
solution it's open source so it's free
and there's no licensing there are
challenges with working with it because
it is a centralized tool rather than a
distributed tool we'll get into that in
a little bit but for a very basic
version control system you know it does
what you wanted to do team foundation
service solutions something that many of
you in microsoft world may have been
using for a long time and the thing
that's great about tfs is it's built
right into the microsoft environment
it's the server side the services side
of building out your solutions with
microsoft um just recently in the last
couple of weeks at the beginning of
september 2018 microsoft actually just
re-branded tfs as azure devops and so
you have azure pipelines and there are
five now azure tools that you replace
tfs but these are all tools that are
very similar in concept the old tfs
tools are very similar to the
centralized svn tools whereas the new
tools that are part of azure are
actually much more aligned with git so
what you're seeing is microsoft moving
from the centralized server to a
distributed server with their new azure
devops tools which is fantastic news for
every developer listening to this and
then we have get and get is a
distributed version control system it is
again open source which means that you
can start using it right now without
fear of having to have any costs or any
penalties and the thing that's really
good about it is that it's really you
can use it for almost any kind of
digital project and what it's good at is
being able to create that historical
record and versioning of your source
code whether you're doing a web
application a mobile application or
you're actually building a python script
for a machine learning solution so let's
dig into what version control systems
are and how they can be of value to you
so the role of the version control
system is to allow developers to be able
to check in their files into a
repository and here you can actually see
how we can check in three files into a
repository and that repository then
becomes a snapshot or a historical
record of the files that we're working
on and you want to be able to have it so
that the repository is flexible enough
so that as you want to be able to scale
and add in new files or new versions of
a file that you can actually do that
easily within your vcs environment and
the goal is to be able to constantly
have each of these versions available so
that anybody wants to be able to check
out the file can actually have the
latest version or see a history of how
that file became what it is today let's
look at centralized version control
systems and then we'll compare it
against distributed version control
systems so a centralized version control
system has a central server where all
the files are stored and everybody has
to check in and check out from that
centralized server and all of the
versions are managed within that server
environment the problem is is that if
that central server crashes which
doesn't happen but very often but it can
happen you end up losing all of your
files and i was actually on a project
where that actually happened to us and
we lost six months of history of how the
application was created fortunately for
us we actually had a backup but it
didn't have all the historical data so
we were able to at least continue
working but we just lost a lot of files
and it took a while to get back into
place so let's now look at and compare
this to a distributed version control
system with a distributed version
control system you still have a
centralized server that manages the
files but the difference is is that as a
developer you check out all of the files
for a project so you can actually manage
the whole project locally on your
develop machine and make your changes
and then you can just check in and out
the changes that you've made to the
centralized server the opportunity you
have here is that the server itself if
it goes down you're not going to be in a
situation where you lose all the history
because everybody that's working on the
actual application has all of the
versions of the code locally on their
machine
now one of the more popular distributed
version control systems that out there
is git i mean it really is probably the
most popular buyer margin compared to a
system out there so you know let's dig
into you know what actually is git so
get is a version control system for
managing files and as a developer you
have a git client on your machine and
you're able to make changes and create
local repositories of a program on your
computer and then you can sync up with a
remote service such as github or git lab
or the new azure
labs environment where you can actually
store files remotely and then allow
remote teams to have access to
those changes in the actual application
you made so you can track your changes
easily you have it's the the tool is
inherently distributed so it makes it
very easy to manage the code for large
teams and you can bring people in very
quickly and you can have people come in
as specialists and spin them up quickly
and have them work on a piece of the
code and then drop them out of the
project if you want to have a check on
how this works go and start contributing
to um any of the the many thousands of
open source projects at github where you
can go in with your get tools and just
contribute to those projects and then
finally one of the things that i really
like with git is that it's not a linear
development approach it's not starting
from a and going to z it's a non-linear
approach which allows you to have
branches that people are working on in
parallel to your master branch where
people are actually doing the delivery
of the production code so let's step
through some of these features
so get as you can imagine the first
thing it does is track history that's
probably the most important part of
having a version control system it's a
free open source you can actually go and
use it right now there are no costs of
actually using it it is a non-linear
environment that allows people to be
able to build out new features in
parallel to the master branch so that
you can be constantly having the master
code out there without and adding in new
features without breaking the code and
you can automatically create backups by
because each developer has a version of
the code remotely it's incredibly
scalable some of the biggest projects
out there now are being managed through
git and because of this scale the
collaboration becomes a byproduct of
teams working together and branching
just is so much easier within git so as
you can see this whole thing leads to a
very effective distributed environment
so let's step through some of the the
workflow that we have available for git
so the way that git works is that
you as an operator as a developer you
have the get client on your local
development machine whether it's a linux
machine a mac or a pc and you connect to
a remote server and you pull down the
latest working copy and then you're able
to make all of your changes uh locally
and you can modify the codes you can
review changes and you can commit those
code to your git repository that you
have locally and then you can push those
changes back up to the remote server and
as soon as you push them into the remote
server those changes then become
available to everybody else working on
the project so they can be constantly
keeping everybody updated on all the
work that is happening so you know
typically the way that it would work is
you know you would start off with having
the working file working directory that
you have locally then you would stage
those files into a staging area and then
you get those files ready to be
committed to your git repository and
these are all actions that you would do
locally and then connect to a remote
server and then later when you go back
into work on your project the first
thing you should always do is check out
that code so you always have the latest
version of the code and everybody is
kept in sync so let's talk about
branching in git so the way that
branches work is that if you imagine
you're working on a project and projects
always have a tendency of getting bigger
than you imagine and what you want to be
able to do is keep that main product
working and keeping it working
effectively but if you want to be able
to add a feature to that product you may
have two or three different groups that
are working on multiple features
simultaneously
and what you want to be able to do is
give them the freedom to work on those
individual features and the way you do
it in git is that you can create
branches off the master and while you're
off the the main branch which is called
the master and so each person could be
working on their own separate branch and
then when they want to they can then
later merge those branches back into the
main master and all this time the main
master still works and still able to
produce the right code for the customer
but at the same time it allows the
developers the freedom to be able to
write in their new features and so we
can look at this in a little bit more
visually with the master branch and we
can put in small features and large
features so we can then merge them back
as we need to so this kind of covers
some of the commands that we have in git
so the first command you'd want to use
is called git init and that's allow you
to go into a folder on your local pc and
or your local mac and convert that file
that folder into a local git repository
and that creates that repository then
you want to be able to make changes to
that repository and the commands you'd
be using in this instance would be add
commit or status and you want to be able
to sync your repositories with the
remote server so be able to put the code
that you have on your computer on the
remote server you just push you know get
the code from the remote server you'd
use pull and then add origin and then if
you want to do parallel development from
the master branch the main branch you
would use branch merge or rebase as ways
to be able to do parallel development a
very warm welcome to all our viewers i'm
anjali from simply learn and today i'll
be showing you the installation for git
on windows so we'll start by downloading
and installing git on our system we'll
then have a look at the git bash
interface we'll type in some basic git
commands next we'll create a local
repository that is we'll create a
repository on a local machine we'll then
connect to a remote repository and
finally we'll push the file onto github
first things first we need to download
and install git so download git for
windows and i'll select the second link
so 2.19.1 which is the most latest
version of kit that's the one we want
for windows system choose your version
so mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while
so git is finally downloaded now we need
to install this on our system
click here
run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path
uh just so just click on in quick launch
and on desktop
next
next again next nothing to change here
either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash
so let's just tick that and then click
on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version
and as you can see version 2.19
on our windows system which is exactly
what we just downloaded we'll now
explore the help command so let's just
type git help config so config is
another command and as i hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it
so in case you have any doubts regarding
how a command is used what a command is
used for or the various syntax of the
command you can always use the help
command now there's another syntax for
using the help command itself which is
git config dash dash help enter this
does the exact same thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir
test
now test is my new directory i'll move
into this directory so cd test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so git
init is the command for initializing the
directory and as you can see as you can
see the path here this is the local path
where a directory is created so i'll
just show you the directory test and
it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and i'll
just name this demo
i'll open this and just put in some
dummy content
so hello simply done
save this file and go back to your bash
interface
let's just check the status now so git
status and as you can see
our file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to our
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is we
will be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we will
be applying is the commit command and
when you add certain files to the
current directory the comment command is
applied on all the above directories so
git commit minus m and a message that
will appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion
just clear the screen next thing we need
to do is we need to link our git to our
github account so the command for doing
that is git config
global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
github account
so this is my github profile and my
username is
simplylearn.github so guys before you
begin this procedure just make a github
account type in my username here simply
learn github and enter and there you go
a git is successfully linked with github
next thing we do is we'll just open our
github and we'll create a new repository
give a repository name so i'll name it
test underscore demo and create
repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and our
local repository
so get remote origin and then paste
the http link and now that our local
repository and our remote repository are
linked we can push our local file onto
our remote repository so the command for
doing that is git
push origin master as we are on the
master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to github i'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo if you have any queries
regarding this please post them in the
comment section below and we'll get back
to you as soon as possible and now we're
going to go through and do a demo on get
so we're going to do a demo on get so
you can feel comfortable running the
commands in the interface and you're
able to get get running correctly in
your environment so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to set
up which version of git that you have
and then we're going to see if we can
establish some global configurations
within your git environment and we're
going to do sandeep.dash as the name
email address is sandeep.simplyline and
then we're going to do a list of the
different configuration settings we have
so to check the version of git that we
have we do get dash dash version in our
terminal or command line window you can
also use powershell that'll actually get
you running in the same environment as
well all of these tools are going to be
command line tools and then the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to assign some global usernames and a
global email address and so that we can
actually access the git account itself
locally on the device and so we're going
to dash and we're going to put in config
dash dash global user dot name sandeep
and then a git config
global user.email and sandeep.d
at simplylearn.net and now we're going
to check the list of usernames and email
ids in our configuration environment
with dash list and you'll see that we
have everything in there correctly here
is our username right here and our name
and our email id
so if you need any help when you're
actually doing any of your work in get
all you have to do is to get help config
or get config
help and this will allow you to actually
get access to the help screens so let's
just go and type that in git help config
return and this takes us to the help
page that's running locally on your
device and here we have a breakdown of
all the different commands and what
those commands actually do within a git
configuration
and we can go ahead and we can do git
config dash dash help and that will
actually take us to the same page so two
ways of doing the same thing so we're
gonna go ahead and we're gonna create a
test repository on our local system and
we're gonna do that with make directory
called test and we're going to move our
cursor within command window terminal
window to the test folder and then we're
going to initialize that folder to
become a get repository so let's go
ahead and do that so we're going to make
a new directory i'm going to call it
test and we're going to move the cursor
so it's actually in the test folder we
do cd change directory to test and you
see now we're actually in the test
folder and now what you have to do is
initialize this folder as a get
repository and so we're going to do this
as git init and it's now a new git
instance that we can actually now use
for managing our git environment so
we're going to create a new file and
we're going to call it info.txt and
we're going to put some content in it
and we're actually going to put it in
the folder that we've just created so
you can actually see what it's like to
test out the get environment with a file
that hasn't been checked into it yet so
let's go ahead and do that so we open up
our folder directory and here you can
see we have the test folder and we're
just going to go ahead and create a
default test file so right click text
new document info.txt open that and
we'll just you can put really whatever
you want in here we're just going to put
in this information right now name
equals sam registration number uh one
two
four seven nine and save that file close
it out now if we actually go ahead and
run a git status command you'll see that
the info.txt file is in red that's
because that file has not actually been
checked into the project it's a new file
that we've added but it hasn't been
committed yet into the git repository so
let's go ahead and see what it takes to
actually add the file to the git
repository that we just created so we're
going to do that by doing git add
info.txt and then we're going to commit
that into the history of that git
repository so we can do so it now has a
version control and we can start doing
uh forking and other kind of similar
activities when we connect later to our
github git environment so we do get add
info.txt and remember we're actually
still in the test folder so it's going
to look for that file in that folder and
just add it in and now if we go ahead
and do git status we'll actually be able
to see that the info.txt file is in an
active color first of all we have to
commit it so we go get commit dash m and
then we're going to commit and we add in
some quick text you can write whatever
you want committing the text file is now
actually committed into the git
repository and it's all running locally
on your pc so we're going to go make
some changes to the file and we're going
to save it and we want to be able to see
how we can use git to compare the
differences between the two files so
let's go over and we're going to make
some changes to the info.txt file here
we are here's info.txt which is going to
add in a new line we're going to add in
the line address and we'll save that
file and now when we go over to git
we're going to
be able to review the difference so
we're going to do git diff and here you
actually see that we've added in a new
address file so now you can actually see
this is the difference and the
difference between the two documents now
as you can imagine when you have code
this could become more elaborate where
actually it will show you code that's
been pulled out if you've reduced any of
eliminating code or if you added a new
code really useful so we're going to go
ahead and add our get username to a
remote location so we can actually start
testing out the
file that we've created into a remote
repository in this case we're going to
use github and you'll be able to see how
we can actually then save that file into
a git repository that somebody else
could then access and be able to make
edits to so let's just go ahead and make
those changes so get config dash global
user dot username and we do simply learn
and that will associate it with this uh
git repository that we've just created
locally so simply down dash github so
simply learn github is the username that
we use on github so we're going to go
over to github here we are in github and
then correct new repository
and then
as you can see with simp so we're in
simply learn dash github and we're going
to call the new proprietary test we're
going to make it public so anybody can
access it and you'll see that it
automatically adds a readme file and we
have our test environment set up
correctly so we'll go ahead and copy the
url link which is github.com simply
learn dash github forward slash test.get
copy that and we'll go back over to our
command line window and so now we're
going to add the username to the github
configuration so what we're doing is
we're connecting the local repository to
the remote repository so we type get
remote add origin and then we'll paste
in the address and this then allows us
to connect the local repository that we
created in the test folder with the
remote repository and now we're
connected so now that we've connected we
can actually push the file that you have
in the local repository on your pc or
mac to the remote repository in the
github server environment so let's go
ahead and do that so we do get push and
push is the command to push the
documents from the origin which is the
local file to master and master the
remote file hey and there we are success
so what we have now is the file that we
just created in our local get repository
is actually now in the remote repository
as well so anybody can access it so
let's go have a look at that so we're
going to refresh the github page and hey
there we are there's info.txt has been
uploaded and we're ready to go that's
great that's uh that's what you should
be seeing so refreshing your web page on
the remote github folder and it could be
any get service but just happen to be
using github because it's free to use
you'll be able to see that the local
file has been installed and is now part
of the get repository in the remote
server so what we're going to do now is
we're going to create three more files
and we're just going to call them
info.txt info 2 and info 3 and then
we're going to push them out to the
remote server and we're going to merge
everything together into a single
environment so let's go ahead and create
those three files and we're just going
to add those into the folder so let's go
ahead create new text document info one
and then we're gonna create info two and
then info
three look at my typing right here okay
here we go there we are
okay i'm opening info three and i'm just
going to enter some text in here and
what we're going to do is illustrate how
we can do branching and each of these
files i'm going to save and then close
out and now i can go over and so let's
create a new branch and we're going to
call this one first underscore branch
and we go get branch first underscore
branch and this will be a new branch of
the code environment that we're creating
and so hit return and that allows us to
create a new branch and so what we do is
we're going to move to the new branch so
we're going to do git check out first
underscore branch and that allows us to
move into that branch and you'll see
that info.txt is already there which is
good that's what we want to see now what
we need to do is um add in the new
documents so here we have the different
steps we've taken we created a branch we
moved to the new branch and now we're
going to go ahead and add the info 3 txt
to that branch so you can actually see
everything coming together and we're
going to go at git add info 3.txt so
we're just adding a file like we were
previously with our initialization our
first initial git folder and that file
has now been added to the first branch
so we're going to go ahead and commit
the file to the first branch and then
we're going to merge the documents into
the master branch so we have everything
together so let's go ahead and do those
steps we're going to do the commit first
and then we're going to merge everything
together all right so we do get
commit dash m and we just put in we're
just gonna say uh made changes to
first branch and that's just uh
documentation so that we know what we've
done and there we are we've committed
the file so we had
that file info three txt committed and
now we're going to go ahead and merge
the files into the main master and
so we can actually have everything
together as one consistent environment
and we do that by typing in so this list
out what we have in our master file so
we just do ls and that shows everything
in the folder and we have info.txt
info 1 txt info 2 txt and info 3 txt i'm
now all in the first branch so let's go
ahead and we're going to merge okay so
actually before we merge we have to
check out the master branch so we do get
checkout master so it gets us into the
master branch and you'll see that we
have just one file on there info.txt so
we're going to list out the files in the
master branch and so so what you'll see
is info.txt info one text and info2 text
are there but
info.info3d text isn't there because
that was created in a separate branch so
let's go ahead and merge the first
branch into the master branch so we do
git merge and we do first underscore
branch and there we are we've merged it
in and
accidentally looks good so let's go
ahead and list out the files that we
have in the master branch and we do ls
and then you'll see that we have four
files including the info three dot text
that we had in a separate branch now all
in the master branch in this session we
will have a look at the basics of github
before diving deep into the subject
let's first have a look at a use case
the used case we will consider today is
of the world's largest sporting goods
retail brand decathlon
decathlon has 1600 stores spread in 52
countries with around 100 000 employees
the iit team of github consists of 1000
members that helps decathlon to bring
its shoppers journey to their devices so
here we will first see the problems that
they faced and then we shall see how did
they sort out that problem
in the beginning decathlon worked on the
data center with the help of a vpn
and using a vpn was a huge challenge in
terms of workflow visibility and
avoiding redundancies so the first
problem is
how to maintain workflow visibility and
avoid redundancies
then since there are so many stores
located at so many different places
hiring of developers seemed to be a
difficult task as a physical workplace
was always needed
so the second problem is
how would they hire developers
now let's see how did decathlon solve
these two problems one after the other
in the first case the entire decathlon
shifted from any other remote repository
to github
github turned out to be an amazing open
source community as the code became more
visible across the organization and now
anybody could contribute to it
then
let's talk about the second case for
hiring the developers
as we know github is an open source
community so it helped in collaboration
with any developer all over the world
the potential developers could now
contribute to benefit the global
community
now the question arises what made this
contribution possible
so the major contribution role was
played by the version control system
this was just a single case amongst many
others
there are many organizations that have
benefited from github
now
when we have realized how github has
revolutionized the market let's start
learning more and more about github it
is time for us to jump on the topic what
is github
github is a service hosted on the web
where all the projects are stored
every project on github has its own
repository and its unique url
git provides a graphical interface to
store the files and helps team members
to coordinate on the project from
anywhere
github provides several access control
and collaboration features like wikis
and basic task management tools for
every project
let's now have a look at the features of
github
the first feature we will see is easy
project management
github helps project managers and
developers to coordinate better on the
project
the work can be easily tracked and
updated which makes sure that the
project is on schedule and as entitled
second feature is increased safety with
packages
the packages on github can be published
as desired
they can be published privately or
within a community or can also be
published publicly
the packages can be easily downloaded
from the github to use and reuse them
next feature is the effective team
management
now as all the team members can stay
updated with all that's happening on the
project so this helps them in staying
organized and well coordinated the pull
request and other modification tools
make sure that the team focuses on the
code
moving on the next feature is improved
code writing
with the help of github the quality of
code has significantly increased
now with the help of gitpull command one
can review improve and propose new codes
along with that suggestions or
modifications may be discussed before
changing the original code
the next feature is increased code
safety
github uses codeql which is the
industry's leading semantic code
analysis engine
this tends to find risks in the code
which other tools tend to miss
the last feature we shall see
is easy code hosting
as the name suggests the codes and
documentations are hosted in one place
we also know that there are thousands of
repositories on github so each
repository has their own set of tools to
release and host the code
finally let's have a look at the
competitors of github
there are several competitors in the
market
here we have just put the most common
ones
first is atlassian bitbucket
then comes fugbugs
followed by surround scm and gitlab
then we have buddy and finally followed
by beanstalk let's see the differences
between git and github
git is a software that can be installed
directly onto our systems whereas github
as we saw in the demo is hosted on the
cloud then git can be used offline we
don't typically need an internet
connection unless we need to access the
github whereas github can only be
operated when we have an internet
connection next difference is git is
something independent and can be used
without github whereas github has
nothing to do unless we make
repositories in git which means it
cannot be used without git
then git is a version control system
that helps in source code management
whereas github provides centralized
hosting of the code on the cloud next
difference is git does not work
according to a graphical user interface
while github is a simple graphical
interface
next difference is git is a command line
so it operates on several commands like
commit merge push pull etc whereas
github is a web-based service so it has
nothing to do with command line then
git is released under the gnu general
public license which is an open source
license it ensures that the software is
free for all its users whereas in the
case of github there are two tires a
free tire and a paid tire
in the end let's have a look at the
competitors of the two as a competition
git has mercurial supervision ibm
relational team concert and clearcase
while for github the competition is
bitbucket and gitlab hello and welcome
to git commands my name is chidanand and
i am with the simply learn team today i
am going to cover few essential git
commands and walk you through a
demonstration for most of it i begin by
installing a git bash on the git client
and configuring it for its first time
usage once i'm done with configuring the
git client i'm going to spin up few
repositories locally and work on these
repositories using git commands once i'm
happy with my local changes i'm going to
commit few of them and then push these
changes to a git server of my choice for
today's demonstration i plan to use
github.com which is a cloud-hosted free
service and it provides free account
registrations for anyone eventually i
will cover few topics regarding git
branching and merging because these two
in my opinion are the killer features of
the git distributed version control tool
kit is one of the most popular
distributed version control tools of
recent times and like any other
distributed version control tool it
allows us to perform various version
control tasks without really needing a
network connection before i jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with kit is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like windows
all flavors of windows
linux mac os and other operating systems
so once you install git bash you get a
command line utility using which you can
fire up your git commands and ensure
that you can bring up repositories you
can work with these repositories by
adding files to it committing changes to
it and all those git commands would work
perfectly well so you can bring up a
small repository and you can work with
your repository using this git bash but
what does it take for you to share this
repository with another user who has
also got git bash installed on his
system this is where you would need
something called as a gig server
so for user one or one user to share his
repository with another user he would
need to collaborate using something
called as a git server so in the present
market there are a bunch of git servers
which are popularly available some of
them are free some of them come with
cost because they are licensed a bunch
of these servers that i can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this github enterprise
servers wherein they buy these servers
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is bitbucket this is from
the famous atlassian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and git lab also
provides you with a community edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what i'm
going to do is i've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and i'm going
to use a free account so whatever
repositories that i'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
i want to register myself by using my
username or my email id and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user 2 the first
thing that i got to do was have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once i have
that i can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user 2 or the other developer
who wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as he's registered properly on
the git server he can use his
credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as ssh authentication as many
of you would know ssh means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while i
create a keys i will be asked for a
passphrase i need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it onto my account within my git
server so that whenever i'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as i remember my phrase correctly i can
authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and ssh are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that i can go ahead
and install it so i just type in get
client for
windows open up a browser and type in
for this the first one that i find as a
gui tool i don't need this gui client i
need this one
so this is the git client or the git
bash that i was referring to it's about
40 megs and let me just download this
pause this video for some time so that
the download happens and come back to
you once i have the download the
download seems to be complete when i'm
recording this video the version that i
have the latest version that is there is
2.19.0 and this is a 64-bit version for
windows so i've got that downloaded let
me go ahead and find it and install this
exe
all right i go ahead choosing all the
default options i want it to be
installed in c colon program files under
the git folder
everything looks good for me i'm not
going to make any changes here
get bash from windows yes i may want to
use git from windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open ssh that's fine
looks good looks good
now i don't want any of these new
features
so what i'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that i can
start using my git commands
the version that i'm using is 2.19.0
which as i record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good i don't want to
see the release notes i'll say launch
git bash
so what i get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good say get to
version it sounds good say get
help all right a lot of git help
commands everything looks good so i
ended up installing the git bash i can
go ahead with all other commands
now that i have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before i do
anything i just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
user name and the email id with which i
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is git config
hyphen iphone global which means that
this setting that i'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double quote in my
case i am using the simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen f1 global this is also
a global setting
and this would be the email id
the email id need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email id that
i would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email id has been picked up the
way i wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you are placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where i'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so i will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo
so this would be a folder so i would use
this folder as a base folder for
creating all other repositories as a
part of this demo so let me create my
first repository a repository is nothing
but a folder so let me create my first
folder called first
repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all i navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty
there's nothing much in this folder at
all at this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do i create a repository of
this it's pretty simple i just run and
get init command
when i say git init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing on it was
an empty repository so it initialize an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all i look at my content
you'd see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since i've
configured my explorer to view all
hidden folders i see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command git init
if i get into this folder i see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and there's info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing
now if you notice here when i was in the
folder the repository did not have
anything after this now when i say git
init there is something called as a
master that shows up so typically what
happens is whenever a git repository is
created for the first time it creates a
default branch the name of the branch is
called master and that is why you would
see master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a branch called master and we are
currently on that branch if at all i
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever i navigate to different
branches the branch name within these
brackets would change
all right so far so good so we created a
folder we made it a git repository by
initializing that with the git init and
then i have not put anything yet in the
repository so let me try to do that let
me create a few files within this
particular repository so i use a touch
command
touch is a linux command it kind of
creates this particular folder if not
you're not comfortable with the file
creation by this way you can always use
a file explorer and create some files in
this so i create a file called
touchmaster.txt i'll open up in the
notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what i'm going to write inside this
i save this and i come out of this all
right now let me do a git status
command so what does this
tell you there's no commit set you're on
the master branch there is an untracked
file and this shows up in red it also
gives you all the commands that is
supposed to be run so if at all you want
to add this file you would say git add
and the name of the file and then you're
going to commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git add i
can specify either the name of the file
or i can give a while character saying
git add dot now if i run the git status
command again
it says there's no commit yet
added a file and the file which was
earlier in red now shows up in green and
it says it's a new file master dot
all right it also gives you something
called git remove command if at all you
want to unstage or undo your changes so
what has happened is the file which was
earlier untracked has been added into
the git index or it is ready for staging
or it's in a staged state
now i can go ahead and commit this file
if at all that's what i want to do so
let me do that
i'll do a kit commit minus m and i give
a message that i want i would say this
is my
first get
commit
all right i run the git status command
again
and see it says on the branch master
nothing to commit it's all nice and
clean so typically what happened was i
created an empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git init i put a
file into it i made some changes to the
file i added that file into the
repository and i committed to the
repository if it error i run the git log
command
it says this was the commit
id or the commit
number or the commit hashtag and this is
the author if you notice this is the
email id and the username that we set
earlier this was done on this date and
this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so i will touch
master one dot text i'll put in another
file
i'll open up this particular file
write something into this
alright i save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what i did i modified the
older file that existed i also added a
new file to my repository now if i run
the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
i want to
incorporate i would say git add dot i
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if i do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice
i'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server i
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things i can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way i want to
without really having any connections to
the git server
now that i have my changes the way i
wanted and i've checked in all the code
changes into my local repository i may
want to share my repository with
somebody else
and work in a collaborative way so the
way to do that is as i mentioned earlier
to host this repository or to push this
repository onto a kit server i already
have a github account wherein i've
registered myself using my username and
password so i log into my github account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what i essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that i can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is this first repo
so let me copy this i would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name
so that
when i pushed my repository from my
local box it will go ahead and get
created in the server
so the repository name should be the
same as what i created on my local box
description i would say this is my first
git
hub repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up
and if you notice
i can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that i'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so i choose public and i don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because i already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that i need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server
so with this option with just the name
and with an optional description and the
repository being public i go and click
on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that i would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server
and also important point it shows me two
urls one is the https url and the other
one is the ssh url as of now we do not
have any ssh keys that is set up so let
me use this https url to connect my
local repository with the repository on
the server
so i've done all these things i already
have the repositories set up all that i
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server url
so this would be the command that i need
to copy
which essentially links or adds an
origin with the url of the git server i
just copy this command
and run it here
git remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
url which is nothing but the placeholder
that i've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the url looks good i'm all set i've
got two comments in my repository i'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen u this is for
linking the upstream
origin
master
so get push hyphen u upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to an origin
and the origin points to this url
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an url asking
me the credentials with which i need to
log into my github server so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which i've
registered
i would say login
okay success
so i'm able to create a repository on
the server and the content seems to be
pushed and it created a new branch
called master it has linked the master
branch from the local repository with
the master branch on the server so let
me go back to my server and refresh this
page
and see if all my commits have come in
master
master1.txt if at all i see the commits
there seem to be two comments this is my
first comment this is my second comment
and if at all you notice each of this
commit comes with a hash key or a hash
id which contains the details of my
comments in this commit the files were
added this was a line that was added if
you look at the second commit
i added these lines
i made this you know one line chain that
was there i also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the commit
this is the commit which was committed
for 15 minutes ago so what does this
mean is that the commit is the timestamp
when we actually commented the code in
the client the pushing is just after we
committed the change we pushed it so
there's no timestamp of the push that
happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein i create a repository
on the client and then i pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the ssh
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of ssh keys and ensuring
that i connect to the github server
using the ssh mechanism so for doing
that i need to first create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is ssh keygen
hyphen t i will use the rsa mechanism
for creating my keys capital c and i
need to specify the email id using which
i'm going to connect to or i need to
create the keys for all right so
generating a private and public key pair
it says let me know what folder should i
create the keys in so by default the
keys are created in the user home
directory under a dot ssh folder so this
is pretty good for me so let me go ahead
and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase
so let me enter some passphrase
keep in mind that i would need to
remember my passphrase because when i'm
going to authenticate myself using ssh
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase i need to enter
the right passphrase so that i get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with
a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now i would need to stick it in
on the server so that i can get myself
authenticated using ssh keys so i've
logged in to github using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you will see an ssh and gpg keys let
me click on that as of now there are no
ssh key or gpg keys so i will click on
new ssh key and let me paste my
public key that i have copied
and i would say add ssh key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
i've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my ssh keys are working well
so i do ssh hyphen capital t
i would say get
at
github.com
this is just to double check if my ssh
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase
i hope i remember it correctly
all right
pretty good i have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my ssh
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase i can connect to my github
server using ssh all right so for the
second use case what i would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository
linking the origin so that i create an
exact replica of the repository which is
there on the server on my local drive so
let me first create a repository on the
server i will create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file i would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the github server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time i'm
going to choose this option
the reason being that i don't want to
create just a skeleton as of now i want
to create a repository with some readme
file in it a random readme file with no
content in it but then i want a
repository to be created on the server
all right i say create a repository
so a random readme file with some
content in it gets created and i can see
there are two urls to this repository
https and ssh so this time let me copy
the ssh url so that i will use this url
to clone this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that i created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that i
created on the server the command to do
that is get clone the url of the
repository that i want to clone
oops looks like i didn't copy the url
correctly let me copy that again
copy this url
all right so if you notice there's no
https to it i'm just cloning the url
that is ssh url of the repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so i just had first repository earlier
now i have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if i get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here i would say
notepad
second.txt
some text file i'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
i will push onto the server
i'm going to put in some content out
there
i'm going to save this
and if i do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository you want to track this
file yes i definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file with the message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
i'm giving some particular message
and this time around since i cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me i don't really need
to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that i was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why i had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case i have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when i clone i get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
i don't need to do anything more other
than push the content i'll just say get
push to be on the safer side i would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it pushed the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here
okay wonderful i had only one comment
now i see my second comment so what was
added as a part of the second comment it
says a new file was added all this line
that never existed got added this is the
second file the content exactly what i
pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when i
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using ssh
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now git init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kit gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file ten files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen m with a
meaningful message
this will commit all the work items that
you have done in terms of the files that
got changed the files that got added all
this with one particular message gate
status will give you the status of all
the files and folders any file that got
added any file that got created any file
that was deleted all status of the files
will be obtained using the git status
command git log will show you all the
commit history with the latest history
or the latest commit showing up on top
git add remote origin this command is
used whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen u origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server git clone and the url of the
server this is the command that you will
run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or gate
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify
or change some of the files that they
recently committed or checked into the
repository now from a perspective of get
this is a very very simple activity
however from a perspective version
control tool you will have to be really
cautious about the change that you're
gonna do in case the changes are pretty
local none of the developers or none of
the other users who are collaborating
with you would be affected by this
change you're good to go ahead and make
this change however if your repository
has been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users who will
be using it you need to be really
cautious while running these commands in
case your repository contents are local
you have not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you missed few things you can go ahead
and modify this with some of these
commands let's say i have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all i look at the logs of these i
have the commit histories which are like
this
i have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1 i've added a
file in c2 i've added another file in c3
i've also added some file in c4 i made
some changes to m1 and m3 and in c5 i
have added another file called m4 now
this is my commit history now let's say
i made these two comments but possibly i
want to club them together along with
some other changes because whatever
changes i did did not really fix things
the way i expected it to fix so there is
a git command called git reset this
would allow me to go back in history to
go back to any of the snapshot get rid
of all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all i need to go back in history
and go back to this particular commit
and however i just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but i want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist i would do
command called get reset
hyphen iphone soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
commits but a soft would ensure that the
file changes that were done as a part of
these two commits would still exist a
full remain so the command for that is
git reset hyphen fn soft which is the
snapshot that i want to get back to if
this is the commit that i want to get
back to i just copy this
and i paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all i do a good log pretty one
line
what it says is c1 c2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to c5 it's gone back
to c3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of c4 and c5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of c4 were
some changes to m1 and m2 and c5 a new
file got m4 got added if what i do a git
status
you'll see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history c3 is the topmost commit
that exists as of now c4 and c5 have
been gotten rid of but the changes that
were there still exist
all right now i can make some more
changes that i want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe i'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.txt
and say
one
new file
that was missed out
i make this change
i go to a get status
all these files are still there i would
say git add dot
i'll say git
commit hyphen m
c4
rewriting history
and i do a get
log
pretty
there you go
so c1 c2 c3 still existed and whatever
was a part of c4 and c5 the older ones
i've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes i also added a new file i
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what i talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and is not
been pushed to the repository take this
scenario wherein let's say i have a git
server
and i have the changes
which are c1
c2
c3
and possibly c4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer one is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history
i'm going to jump all this c2 and c3 and
get into c4 and he's pushed all these
contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer
one then figures out that by mistake he
put in the c3 which was the wrong thing
to do and possibly you know he could
have done a better job of fixing this in
a different way so he wants to get rid
of the c3 or c4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from c4
all of them would be affected in adverse
way so
in short never go back in history if at
all you need to undo something go ahead
and put in a new commit to undo
something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of c3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead
say let's say c5 and what does this
commit do
this commit possibly gets rid of c3
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your git history
ahead but as a part of this commit
you're undoing some part of the work
that was done as a part of c3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are
you're using this repository
collaboratively and what planning to get
ahead in terms of history they cannot
afford to go back in history and modify
something in history all right the
command to do this is called the git
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all i do a git log
pretty one line
have these bunch of comments
and c1 i've added a file in c2 hour
another file in c3 i've added one more
file and in c4 i made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest commit so if at all i see the
contents of the git
folder it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4
and
let's say looking at the previous use
case that i mentioned i may want to get
rid of this particular commit
i want to get rid of the c3 which is
nothing but i've added a file called
m3.txt but i added it by mistake
i need a better way of fixing it
possibly i look at it later on but for
now i don't want this particular commit
and the changes that were made as a part
of that commit to exist so the better
way to do that is using the git revert
command so git revert
and the commit id whatever i want to
revert so if i want to revert this
i copy this particular commit id
and bear in mind that considering reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
i can do
one commit revert at a time i can club a
bunch of them together and do one commit
but otherwise the revert always works on
one commit at a time so get revert
paste this
essentially what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while i'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit it unders
whatever changes that were done as a
part of this comment so if i say git
revert this
all right i forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me i say write and quit
all right and if i do a git log
all right if you see this c1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from c5 i see another commit
but what was that as a part of this
commit actually is getting rid of this
commit c3 so if at all i see my files
here there's only m1 m2 and m4
m3 was added as a part of c3 now i've
gotten rid of m3
by getting rid of the revert command for
c3 so this is a better way of undoing
things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding git which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because kit deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool
in most of the version control tools
whenever you create a new branch a
complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it is a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space
however in git you just create a very
very lightweight mobile pointer whenever
you create a branch there is no folder
or no copy of the repository that is
created in short the branches are very
very inexpensive and great so go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then i'm going to
create a new folder here
i'll create a folder called arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right i navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
i initialize a repository and dot git
folder is created without any files in
it so let me create a few files on it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
i create a name dot text within this
maybe i'll create one more file in this
notepad
employees.txt
simply learn
has
over
3k employees
i just put in some content in this
save this content
all right
so if i try to go get status i just
see two files in it so let me go ahead
and
add these two files and let me commit my
changes okay
commit iphone am or iphone m
first comment
so if i do a gig log
i see only one commit and there are two
files and you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get
branch name of the branch
so let me name my branch as bangalore
branch blr branch
and this created a branch
but i don't see any changes in the
folder structure or in the file that
exists here
i've just created this branch so if at
all i do a git
branch
i see these two branches
and whatever star means i'm currently in
this master branch so let me go ahead
and get into the blr branch at this
moment the number of files that exist in
this repository is same there's
absolutely no change in any of the
branches both master and blr branch
point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is gate checkout
plr branch now actually switched into
bangalore branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because i've
created a branch from my base branch
which is a master branch and when i
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a
file that is specific to panel branch
so i would just say notepad
maybe i want to put down the address of
this organization specific to bangalore
in this address dot text so i say
notepad address dot text
i'll say simply learn
angular office
say located in
some address
i would say bangalore
that is the content of this file
and i'm creating all this new file in
this blr branch so i would say git add
dot
and i would say git
commit hyphen m
bangalore
branch commit
all right if you see this now i have an
address.text which is there only in the
bangalore branch that i'm presently on
now let me switch back to my master
branch the command to do that is get
check out
master branch
if you remember when i forked out or
when i created a new branch from the
master branch i didn't have this address
dot text in it so let me go back to get
get check out master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address.txt
it kind of disappeared
how did that happen it's all because of
this magical git folder so what happened
is now git knows that when you were in
the master branch the file that was
there in the bangalore branch which was
called the
address dot text didn't exist
so
git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if i come back let's
say i come back to get check out
bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever i'm switching to bangalore
branch i see this address.txt when i go
back to my master branch i don't say
this bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that i created this branch
maybe i may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so
the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new repository
all right this
is the name of the repository
get
branch demo this is what i'm going to
put in as a description i would say
public i don't want any readme files in
it because i already have a repository i
will just say create a repository
all right
let me use
the ssh url yeah this is the ssh url
this is good for me so let me copy this
url
let me add it here
i'm linking my local repository with the
server
and i would let me come back to my
master branch
let me first push my master branch so i
would say get
push hyphen u origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
i pushed my master branch it looks good
it says new bunch master is created so
if i go back to my server and i do a
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name.txt
now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and i need to push this new branch onto
the server so the command would be
gate
push
hyphen u
origin
and the name of the branch that i want
to specifically push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of
this right it says two branches
if i get into this bankrupt branch i
would see the address dot text if at all
i go back into master branch i would not
see this address.txt
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that i
created back into the master branch that
is what i would mean by merging i would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangalore branch to come back
into my master branch so if i go to
click checkout
bankrupt branch i see this attach this
is there only as a part of bangalore
branch now assuming that i am done with
the changes from the banner branch i
want to get those changes back into my
master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merging the changes is
get merge
so what is that you want to merge i want
to merge the bangalore branch changes
and where will it merge it'll merge it
into the current branch that i'm on
presently i'm in the master branch so
this command would merge the changes
from the bangalore branch into your
master branch so with this if you'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address.txt this file should appear
as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened
quickly and you would see this address
dot text that is here so if you see
let's check the contents in terms of the
git log
all right so there was only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
bangalore branch commit which was there
as a part of the bangalore branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well
gate push
origin
master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all i do a refresh out here
okay i mean two branches
the francis master even if i'm in master
brands i should see this address dot
text that is there even if i'm in the
bangalore branch the content is all same
because we have merged these two
branches
now that i've merged this branch i don't
need this branch anymore so i would go
ahead and delete this locally as well as
push it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is get
branch
hyphen d and the name of the branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
i would say get branch
and i'm presently in the master branch
so i can go ahead and delete the other
branch so get branch hyphen d bangle
branch
all right this got rid of our bandwidth
branch locally
if at all i don't get branch hyphen way
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this branch would still
exist on the server because server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done
we need to specifically push our changes
onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen iphone delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch
from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as i said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive and good go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
branch please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the git branching commands
are as follows to create a new branch
you issue a command git branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command git branch new underscored
branch it creates a new underscore
branch from the master branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this branch you type in git check out
the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command get
push hyphen u origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new branch are pushed
onto the server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git branch hyphen av assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
branch into a master branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
branch on which you currently reside if
at all you're on the master branch and
if you issue a command git merge new
underscore branch this would merge the
contents of the new branch onto the
master branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get branch
hyphen capital d and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this branch from the server
the command to do that is get push
origin hyphen iphone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
branch that you created on the server
today's topic is learn html in 10
minutes let's begin
first we'll go through a quick
introduction to basic web architecture
to understand how the internet works
then we'll understand what exactly html
is
after that we'll have a look at what css
then we'll go through javascript
and in the end we'll create a simple web
page using html and css to gain a better
understanding of the html tags
so without further ado let's begin now
what exactly is the basic web
architecture
now web architecture is made up of three
essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user
then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data
and finally there's the ip address that
is the address assigned to a website in
order to be accessible on the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is
so your browser starts by loading the
main html file and then the css and
javascript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the back end of an
application now secondly we have
the server once you've developed your
website you'll have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's ip address which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an ip address
we put a domain name over that ip
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is html
html is the most widely used markup
language for developing and structuring
web pages on the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is css then
now css is a simple design language used
for making web pages look more beautiful
and presentable
it can be attached to any html element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is javascript
now javascript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development it
is used for making web pages interactive
and bringing the web pages to life
so now let's create your first website
now html short for hyper text markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs
div containers tables and more html tags
are nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags
so now let's write a simple html code
that will help you understand the basics
of the language so for this i am using
the text editor that is visual studio
code you can go ahead and download this
text editor from their official website
so here i've created a simple dot html
file in my vs code and i've added the
initial html files
now let me explain to you one by one
now doctype is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction
now this indicates the browser that the
document type to be served to the user
is in fact an html document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your html page
next up you have the html tag that is
used to contain all the web pages html
code
right so it contains an opening and
closing tag with contents in between
them
the html tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page
followed by the html tag there's the
head tag now this is the first section
of the code that contains all of the
information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
pages title description additional meta
tags and css code so here i've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
html
in 10 minutes
all right
you can also add css to the head tag by
using the style tag and change the
display styles of html elements that are
being used
the next section is the body tag now the
body tag contains all the displayable
contents of your web page including
headings paragraphs div containers
tables and more
now the html header tags are used to add
headings to a webpage
there are several types of headings
available for developers to add to a web
page right so first up let's have a look
at them i'm going to create a simple h1
heading tag
and the message i'm displaying is
this is
the first
heading all right
after this i'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so i'm gonna add a p tag
and save
this is the paragraph tag
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading tag and say this is the
second heading
now you can also add line breaks which
are helpful from time to time if you
want to provide a single line break in
your content you can do so by adding the
br tag
so here let me just add one for
better understanding
now the html div tag defines a division
or a section in an html document that is
used as a container for other html
elements
now these elements can include content
areas sidebars page bars page headers
footers etc
this tag is used to apply styles to html
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the html image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a webpage are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so let's say
img
within which i mentioned the source
[Music]
i'm adding the html logo so let me just
mention that here
and then i'm going to provide width for
it and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file
and when you look at the browser
you can see that
the first heading is displayed then your
paragraph tag is displayed followed by
the second heading and then the image
now let me show you how you can add
styles for some of these uh headings and
paragraph tags so here in back in my
first heading tag let me just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
and i'm going to change it to career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so i'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when i look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
html tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website so it's time for us
today to talk about something very
interesting feature of the html because
this particular session which we are
recording it for you it is designed
dedicated for html based hands-on
so in this html base hands-on we are
expecting that all of you are aware
about the basic concept of html as well
as the css so this
kind of learning is going to help you to
understand like how html and css can
connect together while offering you a
mini application the first application
on this track we're gonna offer you that
is related to your html registration
page okay so
as you know for this particular
registration development application i
would like to use the visual studio code
which is a very very popular tool
provided by microsoft so this tool will
be using it for our mini application
development so let's get started with
this
so step number one let me go back and
create a new folder now i'm going to
create a new folder name called
registration
and inside this i would require two
files number one it's called index dot
html
another one that is called
css we can say
app.css
so in index.html file
we want
some standard development so i want to
start with my html tag
so
i already have this html base auto fill
code provided by your visual studio code
so there are plugins are available
inside this so that you can
automatically create the basic
structure for this html which you can
have the html tag head tag
as well as the body tag and from this
point onwards we will start developing
our code now so
i want to develop a registration page so
in this registration page i will start
from my
form tag now so inside this form it is
saying like form action to something i
really do not have any backend so i just
leave it as a blank and here i will
start with my h1 tag where i want to say
register
after this register i want to offer the
paragraph tag
where i can say please
fill
in this
form
so hr
so
starting with my horizontal row
and pause this because see we would like
to organize our application and now
level
in this level for
i just wanted to give the name called fm
it's just the name
and after this fn stands for the first
name
and within this level i would like to
use the b tag which is a i would say the
bold
here i will pass first name
bold tag is close it's a label
inside this label i would like to use
input tag
here i will call input type equal to
text
and offer a few other details also like
i say a placeholder
placeholder will offer you what to be
filled i'm saying first name
that is
the
placeholder value after this name
equal to
fn that is a stand for first name
after that id
id is option
but if you want to pass we will use this
id fn
id equal to fn
and
required
because i want this field cannot be
blank
so this is my
first text box where i have this
first name with me
like that i will go ahead and talk about
my
next property or password and for
password also i would like to have the
similar details with me
so this level i'll copy
and paste it below
and this is for
your password so we're giving the name
called psw
here we are saying password
and uh input type into text so here i
will change input applicable to password
because password field
details would not be visible to you
please
here we say
placeholder i can say enter
password
name equal to
you can give psw
id equal to we can give same psw
so
we have a password in a similar line we
would like to offer the confirm password
fields too
i will copy this line
and paste it again
and here we can say confirm password you
can say
cpsw
again password enter
confirm password cpsw
and cpsw
now it's over
after this we want to make it as a
horizontal row
closed
and once it is run then we'd like to
have the button with this
so here is the button we can say
register
and here in my button
i would like to offer the type equal to
submit
are we going to submit
so that's it so this is
the simplest form i have it
now i would like to see how it really
looks like it
so from here i would like to open it
revealing finder
let's open this
well it looks like that
fine so this is what my formless form is
ready and now we would like to go back
and start developing my css in which i
would beautify my form to offer some
more details of this
well friends as we know the html page is
ready it's time to go back and start
developing a css to beautify my html so
inside the css i would like to start
with the tag which is a call body
and
inside this body tag i can offer some
basic setups but
i just want to give the basic background
color now which is called
background hyphen color
i can just give the name called d here
that's a background color let's
the rest of the things i can just leave
it as it is now for all the other
properties i can say box sizing
border iphone box
after that
dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits
now first thing you need to understand
which other places i will be using the
container so you see here in my
index.html file
uh
when we talk about form actions and all
okay we say h1 register we haven't used
any container right now so let's get
added the container
div
class equal to
container
okay and this particular div tag will
get closed only at the last
so
the step tag
will close at the last
here
so i want to make
the look and feel for this complete
container
in much more better way so here in my
container we want to say
margin auto
let's press enter here
margin
auto
now width
50 percent
then adding
16 pixel
followed by background color
which we want white
then box shadow
this box shadow we want to give some all
four origins 20 pixels
continuation to save 20 pixel
and 0 pixel
and which color we want so i just say
rgba
in this rgb just give the value called
zero
again
again 0
and
the value which you want to give to this
alpha because it
is always between
0 to 1 we are saying 0.7 that is an
opacity
well four properties is given
now let's see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a css
in my html so let's add the css so
inside my
browser html
now inside my head let me add link
link rl equal to style sheet href equal
to
laptop css
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now
so this is your container okay which you
can see it is having some shadow i would
like to organize this all set up text
boxes in much more better way
so
after this
we want to offer the other
properties to liken for my input
go back to my css
so after this container we want input
input again
time equal to
text
now
also
to
input
type
equal to
password
here we offer few things number one
width
which is hundred percent
after
sorry
then padding
once again 15 pixels
then margin
you're offering 5 pixels
22 pixel
followed by display
display i will say
inline block
followed by border do you want any
border
so i say null
border borderline and background
we can offer the color so we can say
white smoke
that's it let's see in my html
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized
so this is
your form but i want to make it even
more better now because i want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the
beautification needs to be added more
here
we want to offer the same input type
text input type password i copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
focus
this has to be on focus
focus and here also
on focus
now background color
we want to change
to anything but for typing we can just
give
same
and
outline
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button
so
here we say dot
i do not have that class for register
button so i have to clear this class
inside my
button
register btl
i would like to offer the properties for
those like background color
t
followed by color
which is
white
then padding
we offer 16 pixel
then border
then cursor
i think it is better to have pointer
only
then width
solve it by margin
this auto
then opacity
then i say 0.8
fine so this is for my registration
button
let's see
wow this looks better now
so this is a full size button
so this is for my button
and i want the moment i take my cursor
on button
the color should change or it should
look like it hover
copy this
over and here we say opacity
which is with the value for 1
that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this
you see how the conditions are working
when i press on register you see the
messages
please filter field blank and it is
changing
the
when we talk about the situation
called focus so in this it works like
that when i give the name
you see now how the background color is
changing now so it is little bit more
grayish color so friends this is what
your registration page with the basic
setup
having this html as well as the css
together cascading style sheet which is
also called css is an important aspect
of web designing
it has made our web page responsive and
user friendly
this video will help you understand all
the concepts of css and provide lots of
hands-on examples
we'll start with understanding selectors
box model grid layout flexbox
differences between grid layout and
flexbox and some more basic topics
then building on these basics will make
a navbar learn how to create animation
and transitions and finally we'll move
on to css advanced functions so let's
begin
in this video you will learn what are
css selectors and what are their
different types what are css selectors
css selectives allow you to select and
style html elements selectors are used
to find elements based on their id
classes types attributes value of
attributes and much more let's discuss
the most common selectors
there are several different types of css
selectors the most common of them are
css element selectors css id selector
css class selector css universal
selector and css group selectors
so what is the css element selector
the element selector selects element
based on the element name
this is a css selector it means it will
select all the p elements on the page it
will style all the p elements to the
central arrand having blue color
this is a css selector
it is set to p
this means it will select all the p
elements on the page it will style all
the p elements to be center aligned
having blue color let's look at what it
looks on a page
so as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned with the text color
blue
css id selector
the id selector uses the id attribute of
an html element to find a specific
element
an id should be unique within the page
so you should use the id selector to
find a single unique element
to find an element within a specific id
use a hash character followed by the id
of the element
so
here we have used the hash paragon so
all the rules will be applied to the
html element with id equal to para1 so
this is an id selector
it will be applied to all the html
element with id is equal to para1
as you can see it is applied to the
element having the id parameter and all
the other elements are defaultly styled
css class selector the class selector
finds the element with a specific class
set by the html class attribute
to select an html with a specific class
use the period character followed by the
name of the class so this style will be
applied to all the elements having the
class name class 1. this is a class
selector it is denoted by a period
symbol all the elements having a class
name class 1 will be styled with
centrally aligned and color blue
as you can see the element having the
class name class 1 is styled and all the
other elements are set to default
css universal selector
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a page the universal
selector is assigned by a star character
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a style sheet
as you can see it is generated by a star
mark all the elements inside our webpage
will be centrally aligned and the color
will be set to blue
as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned and the colors are set
to blue
css group selector
in style sheets there are often elements
using the same style to minimize the
code you can group selectors to group
the selectors separate each selectors
with a comma here we have group
selectors for h1 h2 and p
so style is applied to h1 h2 and p
elements only
it is better to group the selectors to
minimize the code
here we have group selectors p h2 and s3
so style will be applied to only
elements having ph2 and s3
as you can see so all the elements of
ph2 and s3 are centrally aligned and
colored to red in this video we will
discuss what is the box model and its
various properties
we will also do an example to understand
the box model better
so let's get started
every element that can be displayed on a
web page is comprised of one or more
rectangular boxes css box model
typically describes how these
rectangular boxes are laid out on a web
page
these boxes can have different
properties and can interact with each
other in different ways but every box
has a content area and optional
surrounding padding border and margin
areas
the following diagram demonstrates how
the content padding border and margin
css properties determine how much space
an element can take on a web page
the content area consists of content
like text images or other media
it is bounded by the content edge and
its dimensions are given by the content
box width and height
the border area is the area between the
box padding and margin
its dimensions are given by the width
and height of the border
the margin area consists of spaces
between the border and the margin
the dimensions of the margin area are
the margin box width and margin box
height
it is useful to separate the element
from its neighbors
the padding area is the area
that includes the elements padding this
area is actually the space around the
content area and within the border box
its dimensions are given by the width of
the padding box and the height of the
padding box
now let us jump to an example to
understand the box model better
so we are on the sublime texture to get
started i have created a box named
simply background color pink the font
size is 30 pixel and we have set the
border to zero solid green
let's see how it looks on our page
so as you can see we have a box named
simply learn with background going all
the way to the end
i have also removed all the padding and
margins from the page so that the boxes
are pushed just at the corner of the
page
as you can see
let's start by adding a padding of 20
pixel to the box
if you save the file you can see the box
increased by 20 pixels from all the
sides
padding occurs inside the background of
an element it goes around the content of
the element
most of the buttons inside the css are
designed using padding so that the
background of the button becomes wider
than the actual text the next thing we
can do is change the border of the
element if we change this border size to
15 pixel we will get a nice solid
background of color green
the border goes around the padding of
our element so we have the 20 pixel of
padding around our content and 15 pixels
of border around the padding which is
round the content
now we will see the working of the
margin
if you add 30 pixel of margin to our
element you can see the spacing on the
outside of our border
so let's add the 30 pixel margin and
refresh
you can see the spacing on outside of
the border margin is used to space two
elements apart from each other
now let's change these values to see the
difference
let's make the margin 40 pixels
we'll make the padding 30 pixels
and let's keep the border 20 pixels and
make it color
red
this is 40 pixels
let's observe the changes
so as you can see our border now has a
red background the padding is 30 pixel
the margin is 40 pixels let's inspect
the elements to understand it better
by clicking on inspect you can see the
different styles
here in the computer tab you can see the
box model
this is a content area this is the
padding area this is the border and this
is the margin area
we have the margin of 40 pixels around
the
border so you can when you click on this
area you can see the margin
get
highlighted the border area gets
highlighted of 20 pixels
this is the padding and this is the
content
you can change the size of the content
by adding the height and width
so let's try adding height and width it
will give the height 50 pixels and we'll
give the width also 50 pixels
just save the file
now when you refresh you can see the
content area of 15 to 50. in this
tutorial
we will discuss everything needed for
you to get started working with grid
layouts
we will start by discussing what is a
grid layout
then we will move on to the features of
the grid system and some basic
terminologies which will help you
understand the grid system better
in end we will work on an example to
understand a grid system
so let's get started
what is a grid
a grid is a set of intersecting
horizontal and vertical lines defining
the rows and columns
and what is the grid layout
so css gridloud is the most powerful
layout system available in css
it is a two-dimensional system
meaning it can handle both columns and
rows unlike flexbox which is largely a
one-dimensional system
you work with grid layout by applying
the css rules to both the parent element
which became the grid container and the
elements children which become the grid
items
the css grid allowed excels at dividing
a page into major regions or defining
the relationship in terms of size
position and layer between parts of a
control build html primitives
you can see this is the basic layout of
a grid system
like tables grid layout enables an
author to align elements into columns
and rows however many more regular
layouts are either possible or easier
with css grid than they were with tables
for example
a grid container's child element could
position themselves so they actually
overlap and layer similar to the css
positioned elements
so here are the features of the css grid
layout
they are fixed and have flexible track
sizes
you can create a grid with fixed track
sizes using pixels for example this sets
the grid to the specified pixel which
fits to the layout you desire
you can also create a grid using
flexible sizes with percentages with the
new fr unit designed for this purpose
you can place the items into a precise
location using the grid
line numbers names or by targeting an
area of the grid
the grid also contains an algorithm to
control the placement of items
not given an explicit position on the
grid
you can define an explicit grid with a
grid layout the grid layout
specification is flexible enough to add
additional rows and columns when needed
features such as adding as many columns
that will fit into a container are
included
it also gives you control of overlapping
content
more than one item can be placed into a
grid cell or area and they can partially
overlap each other
this layering may then be controlled
with the z-index property
so
here are the basic terminologies you
should know to work with the grid system
better
the grid line is the dividing line that
make up the structure of the grid
they can either be vertical or
horizontal and reside on either side of
rows and columns
a grid column is a space between two
adjacent vertical grid lines
the size of a grid column is determined
by the grid template column's property
on the other hand a grid row is a space
between
two adjacent horizontal grid lines
its size is determined by the grid
template rows property
the grid cell is the single unit of a
css grid
and in great design a gutter is
basically the width of the space between
columns a gutter margin is this white
space formed by the adjoining inside
margins of two
facing pages in a book or a space
between columns on a page
so
with this
let's now move on to the hands-on demo
and see how the grid system works in
actual world so we are in the sublime
text editor open with a project with
some basic background styles and nothing
inside the body
you can see this is a basic background
style we have pre-applied just to have a
good look of the
box model
we'll start by creating a container and
wrapping our grid items in it
so let's create a grid and give it a
class name grid container
and inside of it we'll put our different
grid items so we'll just create
different grid items and give them a
class grid item
followed by a class number they belong
to
so that we can easily distribute between
them
just copy paste this
five times
so we'll have the five elements on our
page
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so you can see we have the different
grid items on the screen so that are
easy for us to visualize
we have not applied any styles to them
other than the visual styles
so we'll go back to our code
let's go back to the css styling sheet
so to create the grid we'll open our
style sheet
we need to display grid on our grid
container so we'll select our grid
container and set the display to grid
it is save now
you will see nothing changes this is
because the grid itself doesn't define
any rows and columns for us to work with
it just they give the alignment properly
therefore by default it looks just
exactly the same
to make the grid look actually great
what you need to do is define columns
and rows for a grid
so to do this you will use a set grid
template and set the column if you want
to set the size of the column
we'll set the size to 100 pixel 150
pixels
now
if you refresh you have the 100 pixel
column on the left and a 150 pixel
column on the right
and then the grid captures our next row
but what if we want our box to flexible
size themselves according to the items
inside of them
here we'll use a fraction unit instead
of a 150 pixel column we want one
fraction of our size and instead of 100
pixels we want the two fractions of our
size
so we'll just replace with two fractions
and this with one fraction
if you save the file
and go back to the page
you will see that the items on our left
here in our first column are twice as
large as the item on the second column
and that's because of the fr units we
have defined
you can see the difference in the sizes
the item one is the twice of the size of
the item two
another thing you can do is with columns
is use repeat
suppose you want four columns of a size
100 pixel wide you can just write repeat
command and inside of it how many times
you want to repeat the size
so we'll just delete this
and use the repeat we'll set the number
of times we want to repeat and the size
of the
columns
now if you save the file you will see we
have a four columns of 100 pixel wide
we can do the same things for row just
set the grid template
rows and define the size you want
now you can see we have the symmetric
size all around our container
if you don't know how large your grid is
going to be you can use the grid auto
rules and this will determine the size
of all the rows that is added after the
template rows
suppose we want all our rows to be 100
pixel
so we'll just delete the grid template
rows
and set the grid auto rows to 100 pixels
now you can see all the rows are now 100
pixel tall
let's change our colon back to 100 pixel
and 150 pixels
so that it will be easier for us further
we'll just delete this grid auto rows
now we'll talk about the spacing of the
rows and columns apart from each other
we can do this with the help of the grid
grab property grilled row gap will give
some spaces between the rows similarly
the grid column will give you the spaces
between the columns
now you can see the gaps between the
rows and columns
now we want the same value for both the
columns you can use the grid grab
property and mention the space
we'll just delete this two
and instead of it we will use just the
grid gap
and set the
size to 20 pixels
now you can see the evenly spaces
between the rows and the columns
this is all you need to know about the
sizing of the different columns and rows
now let's talk about the positioning
items within its grid cells
so for horizontal positioning we could
use the justify items and we can set
that to center
so that centers each item within the
cell
by default it is set to stretch
we can also set it to start
or end
or space
around we will leave this to center
to vertically position the content we
could use the align items
the
items also accept the same values
we can set it to center
we can also set this one to start or end
just will keep this to center as well
you can also align the entire grid
within the container
so let's get rid of these to just
demonstrate them
in a proper manner
you can use the justify content and that
will align the content horizontally
within the container
we can also set this to start or to end
just set this back to center
to align the content vertically we could
use the align content and the align
content also accepts the same value you
can set it to center
or start
if you inspect the elements
you can see they are aligned centrally
between the container
we will just close this
okay so this is everything you need to
know to get started with the grid layout
grid works very similar to the flexbox
but it allows it too much in terms of
laying your elements because of its 2d
nature in this video we will learn
what is a flexbox and how it is useful
in designing the layout of the website
we will also try to understand the
different properties of flexbox with the
help of an example
so let's get started
what is a flexbox
flexbox
also called flexible box model is
basically a layout mode or model that
provides an easy and clean way to
arrange the items within a container
if you are using a css for a while you
must have used the old block model where
you assigned width in terms of
percentage or fixed width and then use
the float to arrange the items on the
page
suppose for example
you want to arrange three boxes in a row
then you have to enter everything
manually from width height and to
padding flexbox can do all these things
with ease
some of the concepts of flexible box
model is the ability to alter the item
width and height to best fit in the
containers available in the free space
flex model is the direction agnostic
which is different from the box model
which is vertically biased and the
inline which is horizontally biased
flexbox works for both
flexbox is more effective in small scale
layouts
so here are the main properties of the
flex
ok
so let's jump to some code and learn how
these flex properties work
okay
so we are in the sublime text editor
to get started let's add a div inside a
body here and we'll give a class of
flexbox container since this will be the
container where all our flexbox item
will reside
then inside this container we will add
another div and give it a class flexbox
item and one more class flexbox item 1
which will help us to understand which
items we are referring to when we style
our elements individually
let's just save the file and see how it
looks on a page
now if you save the file you can see we
have the box because i have already
applied some other styles to these
flexbox items
let's just see the styling
so you can see we have the items styled
just a basic styling so that we get the
box on our page
now let's just copy these and add two
more flexbox items and you will see we
have two more boxes on our page
just copy and paste them below
give them the class name flexbox item 2
and flexbox item 3.
just save the file
now you can see we have three boxes on
the page
now to create a flex container
we will add display flex to our flex
container and this is how we create a
flex
box container
so here we will just add
display
flex
just save the file
now you can see all the items are in the
same height and they are all in the same
row
you will also notice that if we shrink
our browser the items adjust themselves
accordingly to fit within the browser
now if you want to style the elements on
the main axis we will use the property
justify content inside of flexbox
container
let's
make it a center
save the file
now you can see that all the elements
are in the center of the page
another thing we can do is if we want
our layout to have a spaces between the
elements
we will set the justify content to space
between
you can see all the items are now evenly
spaced
if we want to lay out your items on the
cross axis we would use the align items
property
the default value for this is stretch
if we want to keep the size of our items
we will use the center and then all our
items will be centered vertically
before flexbox aligning the items
vertically inside the container was
nearly impossible
with flexbox you can do it easily
now you can see the items are aligned
vertically inside the container
now let's just delete everything and
we'll just keep the display flex
now if you want to have a column layout
instead we will use the flex direction
and change it to column flex direction
column now if you refresh the page you
will see all the items are shown up in a
column
now we can start talking about the
different properties that can be applied
to our different flexbox items as
opposed to flexbox container items the
textbox is only for laying out and
spacing between your items as well as
the positioning of your item inside the
container
the actual flexbox item properties are
used to override those item properties
or to apply different sizing to these
elements now if you want our first item
that it does not shrink when we shrink
our browser we'll set the flex shrink to
zero to our first item
so we'll set the flex
shrink to zero
now if you go back to the page
and try to shrink this
you will see the first item remains the
same it does not shrink
now
in the same way you can set the items to
grow in proportion with the web browser
suppose we want our flexbox item to grow
with the as the page grow and cover all
the empty spaces
so we'll set this flex grow to one
now
you will see the all these empty spaces
are taken by the second item
let's say we want our second box to be
the center of the container instead of
stretching to full height we can use the
align self property and set it to center
now you will see that the alignment
property overrides the align content
property of the container
you can see it is centrally aligned
so this is all you need to understand
and get started to work with the
flexboxes
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
learned something new about the flexbox
and how you can use the flexbox to
create the dynamic layout for your site
in this video we are going to discuss
one of the most important topics of the
web development which is css display so
without wasting any time let's get
started
so what is the display property
the css display property controls the
layout of the element on the page
the default value of the display
property is block or inline
let's jump back to our sublime text
later to see the various display
properties by using an example to get
started i have a really simple example
setup
as you can see inside my html i have the
two paragraph tags
and
i have a formatting
with the background player of stand
color and font size 30 pixels
as you can see this looks like something
like this on the page
the very first property we are going to
discuss is the display block property
the drug display values make an element
a block element
the block elements start a new line and
span the entire width of the viewport by
default like how p elements behave
there are also line breaks before and
after these elements
the default value of the
p element is a display block
so here
this looks something like this
what display blocks does is it means
that it is going to take the entire bit
given to it
this is going to force a new line above
and new line below it so you cannot have
something next to here now if we change
here this to
[Music]
the next property we are going to
discuss is inline
the inline display value turns any
element into an inline element
these elements will appear on the same
line without breaks
now if we change here this to display
inline now all the p tags will behave as
an inline element
now if we go back to our page and
refresh
you can see now this is an inline
element
the inline element takes the minimum
amount of space possible
as you can see here the cyan color takes
the minimum amount of space to fit all
the content inside of this
p
so this is what an inline element does
also all the inline elements are on the
same line
they share the space together because
they take the minimum amount of space
possible
there are no line breaks in these
elements and they try to fit as closely
as possible
now
one of the demerits here is we cannot
change the height and width of the
inline element
if you change here height
to 200 pixels
and width 200 pixels
and save
just go back and refresh
you'll see nothing happens
this is because in the inline display
property you cannot change the height
and width of the element
the next property we are going to
discuss is the inline block value the
inline block value is a hybrid of inline
and block element elements assigned
display inline block appears on the same
line with the other inline elements
a characteristics of inline elements
however inline block elements also like
block elements in that you can change
the width and height of the css
now if here we try to change the height
and width
of the element
just change this to inline block
now if you go back to the page and
refresh
you will see the height and width
property works this is one of the major
difference between the inline block and
the inline l inline display property
the last name type of display we are
going to discuss is the display none and
this is a really straightforward display
property
you just delete this
and change the display to display none
now if you save the file and go back and
refresh
you'll see both the element disappears
the display none removes the targeted
elements and all its child elements from
the page this causes accompanying
elements to behave as if this element
does not exist
in this video we will discuss everything
you need to know about css positioning
by the time this video is over you will
be able to position the elements in css
like a pro
so let's get started
first let's cover the theoretical part
here we will discuss what is the ss
position property and its different
types
after that we will jump to practical
example to learn how to work with these
properties
so let's get started
so what is css position property
the css position property allows you to
define the position of an element on a
web page
the top right bottom and the left css
position properties
are used to determine the final location
of the element
there are four values that you can use
to set the position of an element on a
web page
they are static fixed relative and
absolute
using one of the four values above you
can specify how an element should be
positioned
you can also use the top bottom left and
right properties to further define the
element position on a page so let's
discuss each of the properties
individually
css static position
this is a by default position for html
elements
it always positions an element according
to the normal flow of the page
it is not affected by the top bottom
left and right properties
it is important to note that having a
static position is the same as not
setting the position property at all
the next is css fixed position
the fixed positioning property helps to
put the text fixed on the browser
the fixed test is positioned relative to
the browser's window and does not move
even when you scroll the window
the next is css relative position
the relative position property is used
to set the element relative to its
normal position
the relatively positioned element
behaves the same way as a static element
except that it is now subject to the
values of the four other css properties
we will discuss each of them with more
detail in examples
now there is css absolute position
the absolute positioning is used to
position an element related to the first
parent element
that has a position other than static
if no such element is found the
containing block is html
with absolute positioning you can place
an element anywhere on the page
now let's move on to the example to
understand each of the properties better
to demonstrate the properties i have the
simple example set up
currently we have three elements with
just basic coloring style
we have not applied any position style
to them
now let's click on this
element too and inspect it
just go to the computed
and type here position to see the
position of this element
so you can see that currently the
position is static
static is the default value of all the
elements of the page in starting
the next position we'll see is the
relative position
it works almost in a similar manner to
static
if we go here and change our position to
relative
you can see nothing changes
relative act is the same as static with
the only difference is that the relative
allows you to change the top left right
and bottom of this element let me show
you an example
now if we change here to
left
20 pixel
and refresh
you will notice the elements move itself
to 20 pixels from the left
let's set the top to 10 pixel as well
you can see the element has moved 10
pixel from the top and even overflows
the element below
this is because relative position when
applied with the top right left and
bottom actually takes that element out
of the document flow
so let's just reset it
next property we are going to discuss is
absolute position and this property gets
well along with the top right left and
bottom
so let's make this position to absolute
and you can see the changes made due to
this by just
saving
the absolute value completely removes
the elements from the document flow
this is useful when you want a
particular element to be a specific
position but you don't want to disturb
the other elements positioning
accurate position positions the element
inside the some parent container that it
can reference
now just
let's shift the top to 10 pixels
you can see the movement of this element
[Music]
the absolute position always position
the element inside some parent container
that it can reference to
now if we change the here body position
to relative now the
this nav bar will position the element
according to this body so if you go here
and refresh this you can see that this 2
is in relation to with this container
and this is where relative is very
useful
next is fixed positioning which is very
similar to absolute positioning with
some differences
so let's change this to fixed
and just save this
now you can see it completely ignores
this relative positioning and goes
entirely at the top
this is because fixed position elements
are always fixed based on the entire
html element
it has nothing to do with the parent
elements
one unique feature of the fixed element
is they stay in the same place when you
scroll
let's make the height here
to 200 vertical height
now if you scroll down you will see that
the element two will stay on the same
position
see
the two elements stick to the same
position
but absolute does not work that way when
you change this here to absolute
you can see it does not stay
at the top now
this is one major difference between
absolute and fixed
so that's it you can see the working
with the css position super easy in this
video
we'll discuss the differences between
both the layouts and we'll discuss which
one you should use
i will also show you both the layout in
a practical example without diving too
deep
so let's first understand the theory
grid allows developers to construct
custom grids with more flexibility and
control than ever before
it is for two dimensional positioning we
got rows and columns here
whereas flexbox is for one dimensional
layout it is useful in allocating and
aligning the spaces among the items in a
grid container the flexbox layout
pattern makes it easier to design and
flexible and effective layouts
the grid is used for creating more
complex and organized layouts on your
pages
whereas the flex items is used to design
the responsive pages without using
too much of positioning or float in our
css code to work with the css grid
layout you have to add display grid
property to your element
whereas to create the flex container you
have to use the display flex property
so this is the main difference between
the layout of the
grid and the flex blocks
here in the grid layout you can see that
there are rows and columns with all the
header menu main right and the footer
included whereas the flexbox is only for
one dimensional positioning
now let's move on to the example to see
the working of the both the layouts so
here is an example of the web page that
does not have any function other than
some basic styling
here on the page we have a header which
is blue in color
this is a sidebar with a red background
and this is the main content and this
black color is the footer of the page
here you can see this all these items
are stacked on top of the each other
in the code you can see um this is the
footer part of the page uh this is the
main content of the page this is for the
sidebar and this is for the header area
of the page
for the styling part we have used some
basic styling just so as to understand
the example better
now
we can turn the body into a grid by
setting the display property to the grid
so here under the body we'll set the
display to grid
just save the file and refresh
you can see nothing changes because by
default the css grid starts creating
rows automatically and adds the content
in these rows that side didn't change
we can change it by adding the grid
template column property in our body
in our case we'll need two columns one
for sidebar and other for the main
content
let's set the side area to 30
and we'll keep the main area to auto to
cover the remaining spaces
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are broken into the
stills we created
we'll also define the rows for our
header and we'll use the grid template
rows
we'll set the grid template rows for the
header to 60 pixels
for the sidebar and for the main content
we'll set it to auto
and also for the footer we will keep it
60 pixels
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are adjusted in a
2d manner just as we wanted
this shows the power of the grid and the
flexibility it provides to the developer
however
we can see that items are not positioned
properly in the header
and the footer
this is where the flexbox comes into
play as discussed earlier flexbox is
about positioning elements in a
one-dimensional area
so what we'll do is we'll go back to our
navigation list class here
and we'll add display as flex
now if you save the file and reload
you can see these are sitting next to
each other by default the display sets
them into the rows
now we want the contents to be in the
center of the main axis
so we will use the justify content and
set it to center
you can see the items are now in the
center of the main axis
to center them vertically we will use
the align items and set it to center as
well
this will position them in the center
across the axis
for this to work we have to specify the
height arm so we'll set it to 100
percent
so now you can see the items are aligned
centrally both on the main axis and the
cross axis
let's now add some spacing between these
items
so to give some spacing between we add a
margin to navigation item class
we'll set the margin to zero for top and
bottom and 10 pixel to left and right
if we save the file and refresh
you can see we have the spaces between
the items
in this video you will learn how to set
a background image on a web page you
will also learn so the basic properties
of the background that are used to set
the image
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
in this tutorial we'll discuss what is
css background image after that we'll
discuss some of the basic properties of
the background image in the end we'll
add a background image to our web page
by adding the code to our text editor
so let's begin by discussing about the
background property of the css
the background image property specifies
an image to use as a background of an
element
the background is defined in the body
element of the html code
to add a background image on an html
element use the html style attribute and
the css background image property
and mention the path of the image inside
the url attribute
there are several properties of the
background that are used to define the
image on a page
some of the common ones are background
image background repeat and background
position by default the image is
repeated so it covers the entire element
let's switch to the text editor and see
how we can add the background image to
our page so we are on the sublime text
editor let's start by opening a style
tag
the background image is always set on
the body tag so type body and open the
curly braces
the background image is always set on
the body tag
so open the body type with curly braces
and start typing background image
use the url value of the background
image to set the path of the image
make sure the image is in the same
folder as of the html file here we have
our file nature 3.jpg
so
mention the path inside the double
quotes
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a web page
as you can see we have the image on the
web page let's format this image a
little bit we'll start by setting the
background size so type background size
and there are three values to the
background size first one is auto
it will set the image as it is
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page
as you can see the size of the image is
as same of the original size
the color value will set the image size
that will be fit to the web page
as you can see the image is set to the
whole web page
you can also set the image size to
manual let's say we want the image size
of bit 500 pixels
so
now as you can see the width of the
image is 500 pixels next we will set the
background repeat property
there are three values to background
repeat first is no repeat with the no
repeat value the images will not be
repeated on a page
now as you can see the images are not
repeated
second is repeat x it will set the
images to be repeated on the x-axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated on the x-axis
similarly repeat the images on the
y-axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated to the y-axis
and there is a default value repeat
which will repeat the images on the web
page so
let's keep it to cover
so let's keep the background size to
cover
and set the background repeat to no
repeat
let's save the file and look it on a
webpage
now as you can see the image is fully
put to the webpage
let's add a text above our image to see
how it looks like
so i'll add a paragraph tag
and type some random text here
let's set the text color to red and
align it to center
i'll type p and open the curly braces
i'll set the color to red
and i'll set the text align to center
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
as you can see we have a text above our
image which is centrally aligned and the
text color is red in this tutorial we
will learn how we can add colors to our
page using different methods we will
start with discussing colors and then
see the hex value and rgb format of the
colors
in the end we'll do an example to
understand how we can add colors to our
page
css uses the color values to specify the
colors on a page
they can be specified using predefined
color names hex or rgb format there are
nearly 140 standard color names
hexadecimal is a sixty representation of
a color the first two digits are
represents a red value the next two are
green value and the last is the blue
value
all the other colors can be created
using the combination of these three
colors there are several websites
available where you can know the hex
value of the different shades of color
as you can see the black color is
signified by hashtag and the six zeroes
the red is hashtag ff and the four zeros
followed by it
the rgb color value is specified using
the rgb property this property takes
three values one for red green and blue
the value can be the integer between
zero to 225 or a percentage
as you can see the black color is
signified by zero zero zero the red by
255 zero 0 the blue by 0 0 255 and the
green by 0 to 55 0.
now let's move to an example to
understand how we can add the colors to
our page
in this example we will see how we can
add colors in different ways to our html
so we are on the sublime text editor as
you can see we have the standard wallet
ready with an h2 and a paragraph on our
page open the style tag and make the
font size of the paragraph to 25 pixels
so it is clearly visible
let's start by adding colors to our text
just by color names html supports nearly
140 standard color names
we'll make the color of the paragraph
green for that just type color and set
the color to green
as you can see our paragraph is changed
to green
let's try one more
this time we will add the color red
just refresh
as you can see the color is now changed
to red
there are nearly 140 html standard
colors that are supported by the web
browser
you can also add colors using the rgb
format there are many websites available
to know the rgb or hex value of the
desired color one such is html codes.com
as you can see in the htmlpost.com we
have the hex value and rgb value of the
desired color
let's try one
we'll add this color with rgb value 171
229 and 27 to our paragraph so for that
just type rgb and the color code you
want
as you can see the color is not changed
to our rgb value
let's try one more
this time we'll use this rgb value to
our text
you can see the color is changed to our
desired value
in this way you can use the rgb format
to change the colors
the next way is using the hex values
hexadecimal is the sixth representation
of a color the first two digits are red
next one two are green and last at the
blue value
let's see how you can use the hex values
as you can see the hex value for this
color is hash 31787f
we'll use this value to our text
to add the hex value you have to use the
hashtag followed by the color code
you can see that color is changed to a
hex value let's try one more
you can see the hex value for this color
is hash f14a07
just copy the desired value to your file
you can see the color changes
you can also add color borders to our
heading
do that just mention the border style
along with the color code
we'll add the border color red to our h2
now you can see we have the border
around our h2
i hope you have understand how to use
the color values to your web page there
are mainly three ways by which you can
add the colors to your webpage they are
hacks rgb values and the color names
in this video we will discuss what are
keyframes and how you can use them to
add animations to your page
we are going to discuss what are
keyframes and we'll try to understand
the syntax of the keyframes so let's get
started
the keyframes are used to specify the
animation code in the page they are used
to change the animation from one pattern
to another keep in mind that the
keyframes do not have any selectors on
them
they are not tested inside anything
they are on the root of the css page you
write at the right keyframes and the
name you can name it anything you want
we are going to use that name later on
to call the selector in this case we are
looking at from and two from implies the
initial state and to the ending state
here in this example the element will
start from 0 pixel and will go all the
way 200 pixel so what we are going to do
right now is we are going to jump to the
keyframes and work out some examples to
understand the working of the keyframes
better so we are on the sublime text
later and this is a simple setup
we have created one html element named
box and we have a css body of padding 50
pixel and the box element has an inline
block
background red with heightened width 200
pixel
and also i have an animation stand
declared on the box
currently it's doing nothing because it
is calling keyframes called my frames
but we have not yet created any keyframe
we will discuss what this animation line
means at later stage but right now i
need those lines to be able to expose
you to the functioning of the keyframes
you can see we have a box on our page
with the color red
and padding 50 pixels around it
we are going to write add the keyframes
and i am going to use the name my frames
then we will write prompt condition to
have the starting state and let's just
keep the height 200 pixel
and then we want it to grow and we'll
set it to increase till 500 pixels so
let's just create our keyframes
this is a from condition
we will set it to 200 pixels
and we want it to grow till 500 pixels
just save the file
now as you can see our box is going all
the way to 500 pixel and when the
animation is done it resets back to 200
pixel and starts again because the
animation is looping you can also put
multiple style declaration for example i
am going to write background pink
in the two condition
just save the file
you can see that the animation is
starting at
red and ending at pink now instead of
saying prom and do we can also say from
zero percent to hundred percent
this is as same as doing from and two
but what it enables you to do is you can
add something in the middle of here say
30 and we will make the color any
different
so in the place of prompt we'll write
zero percent
and we'll replace true with hundred
percent
let's just add one more condition in
between say 40
so at 40 we want the color to change to
say something
greed
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so as you can see it starts with red it
turns to green in the middle and then
all the way converts to pink
as you can see there are lots of
interesting things you can do with the
keyframes
all of the things that i am showing you
today are just like how this works
to really get a great understanding of
how it works you just have to open an
editor and start experimenting on it
okay so now let's go back to our code
and learn about the animation property
so here we have the animation name my
frames
the animation name should be as same as
keyframes name to work it properly
the animation duration specifies for how
long we want our animation to last in
this case two seconds
let's just change this to say
10 seconds
just save the file
now as you can see the animation is
going at a slower speed just to cover
the 10 seconds update
let's just reset it to 2 seconds
the timing function used to mention the
transition there are some keywords such
as easy and linear easy now and some
more the animation delay is interesting
to understand it means how long we are
going to wait once the animation is
triggered before the visual starts
happening
let's change it to 3 seconds
as you can see the animation starts
after the 3 seconds
iteration count specifies how many times
the animation should happen here we have
set it to infinite
which means animation will keep on going
let's change it to something say 5.
as you can see after the count of five
the animation stops we'll set it back to
infinite
animation running state can be paused at
the running state
in this video we are going to break down
everything there is to know about the
css animation
css animations make it possible to
animate transitions from one css style
configuration to another
animations consist of two components a
style describing the css animation and a
set of keyframes that indicates the
start and end states of the animation
style as well as possible intermediate
now to understand this better i have an
example so let's get started now
so we are on our sublime text editor now
to get started i have a very basic
example with html and css
i have a parent element here
and inside this parent element i have a
div class child
so when you go back to the page it will
look something like this
this pink color is the parent element
and the small box with the red color is
a child element
whenever you hover over the element the
child elements move from left side to
the right side of the parent we want to
talk about animation
in case there are two different ways to
animate one is the css transition
property which works well with only
simple animation
if you want to learn about css
translation property you can refer to
the last video on css translation
there is a full-fledged animation
property which is used for more complex
animation
i am going to show you how you can make
this simple transition into animation
for this example we'll make this child
element move all around the box using
animation
so let's go back to our code
so just like the translation property we
have the several properties in the css
animation as well this consists of like
timing function fill-in mode and several
other functions in the css animation
so to convert the transition into
animation all we need to do is write the
word animation and you write the
animation where you want it to happen
in our case here is our hover so we
write the animation here and as you
write you will notice that you have more
properties in animation than transition
in general you will write everything in
this animation keyword because it is
easier
you can write it separately as well like
animation delay duration animation name
but
we will use the shorthand property of
the animation
so we'll select the animation
and the first thing the animation needs
is the animation name
so
we will give some name to this animation
say
example
this is just like transition we can
specify our duration
in our case we will use one second
so we have given the
name of the animation
we will give the duration we can define
our timing function which will be ease
out
this is all the code we need for our
animation
this line is same as writing this
individually
like animation name
[Music]
animation duration one second
and animation timing function
which will be ease out
now let's say ease zen
so for the better understanding let's
just remove this shorthand property and
use it individual properties
now just save the file
let's understand briefly what each of
these properties do
the animation duration property defines
how long time an animation should take
to complete the animation duration
property is not specified no animation
will occur because the default value is
0 second
the animation timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
animation
now comes the keyframes
chains are used to define the animation
name
we come down here and write at the right
keyframes
followed by the name of the animation
the keyframes has to be put outside any
selector
keyframes essentially determine what our
animation looks like between the values
0 and 100
so at our animation we want to have this
translate
so
we'll write 100
and we'll write
transform
translate x
hundred percent and save the file
now when you save and go back to the
page
you will notice the smooth transition of
the animation
when you hover over
one thing you will notice that as soon
as the animation is over the box goes
back to the original place
the reason for this is all the process
happens inside this keyframe
this one
as soon as the animation is done the
default state kicks in
if we want this to stop in the transform
state like box should be here
on the right side
we have to specify it in the animation
property we will set the animation fill
mode to forwards so here
we'll set the animation field mode to
forwards
just save
and then when you go back to the
page and refresh
you see the box stops on the right side
and doesn't go back to the original
state
now that you have a basic understanding
of the animation and its different
properties let's work around our main
aim to move this child element all over
the parent element from this to this
side to this side to the side so here at
the keyframes we just delete this
and we'll start with zero percent
so here at the zero percent
we'll set the transform and translate x
to
zero
after that added 33
we want
this box to move down so we'll work on
translate y so
we'll translate the y two hundred
percent
at sixty six percent
we want both the x axis and y axis too
to move
from here to this side
so
we'll set
translate x to hundred percent
and translate
y 200
and finally at hundred percent
we want to translate x
back to 100
on the upward side
so when you save and refresh
you'll see we have achieved our target
the child elements move all over inside
the parent element
to watch it little bit more slowly let's
change the time here to three seconds
when you go back and refresh
you can see the box move little bit
slower
so
with the animation property we can go a
step further we can tell our animation
how many times to repeat the order of
the animation
among other things
so the animation iteration count
property specifies the number of times
an animation should be played
let's set it to three
so here
we set the animation iteration count to
three
the animation direction property defines
whether an animation should be played
forwards backwards or in alternate
cycles
so
for the animation direction we set it to
alternate
now if you save and go back
that's one
two
and three after the three count the
animation will stop and you must have
noticed that the box were moving on the
alternate rounds
let's go back to see it again
this is the first cycle now it moves alt
on the other direction
and now on the other direction
so this is for animation you can see
animation property is as
same as a translation property with some
more
functions and sub properties you can add
more complex animations to the page with
the help of this animation property
the css translation property is the
simplest way to add the animation to our
website
and in this video we are going to see
how to use it
so animation is a good way to catch
attention on the page and if done
properly it increases the user
experience
the most basic way to animate something
is by transition
according to the mdn definition
transition animals to define the
transition between two states of an
element
basically when the state of an element
changes such as hover focus or anything
else we can change the css property
through a transition
there are handful of transition
properties let's discuss what they are
and how they work
so
we are on our port pen
i have a box that changes the color on
the hover
the first property that we are going to
start is with the transition duration
property
the transition division property
specifies how many seconds or
milliseconds a transition effect takes
to complete
so here i can write transition duration
and i can write here a number
take note that here we can enter time in
milliseconds or seconds i will suggest
you to use the millisecond since
javascript does not accept time in
second
so i will enter here 500 milliseconds
now
when you go here and hover over this box
you will see the color changes from pink
to green in about 500 milliseconds
let's
change this to say two seconds
and see the difference
now if you hover this box
you see it takes two seconds to change
the color from pink to green
[Music]
the next one we are going to look is a
transition property the transition
property sets the css properties to
which a transition effect should be
applied
suppose we want to rotate this box when
hovered over
so first we'll specify the transform
property here and will set it to rotate
45 degrees
now here we will specify the transition
property and set it to transform
now if you hover over this box you see
it takes about 500 milliseconds for the
box to return to 45 degrees while the
color changes instantly
suppose we set it here to two seconds
and save
now you'll notice the box will take to
about 2 seconds to rotate to 45 degrees
while the color will change instantly
you can see the difference here
now the next property is transition
timing function
the transition timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
transition effect
the default value is ease
ease means it specifies the transition
effect with a slow start and then fast
and then end slowly
suppose here
we'll set the transition
timing function
to eve
there are four major values for this
timing function they are ease linear
ease in and ease out
let's see one by one in detail
so
the linear functions specify the
transition effect with the same speed
from start to end
so if we change here to linear
you will see that it rotates with the
same speed from start to
end now if we change this to ease in
the ease it specifies the transition
effect with a slow start so now if you
hover over this
you see the box rotate the slow start
and then increases the speed at the end
the ease out specifies a transition
effect with a slow end
so if you set it to ease out
you'll see at the end the speed
decreases
the last property we are going to
discuss is a transition delay the
transition delay property specifies when
the transition effect will start
the transition delay value is defined in
milliseconds or in seconds
let's set the transition
delay to two seconds
and just remove this
now if you hover over this box you will
see it will take two seconds to rotate
the box to 45 degrees
so you can see after the two seconds the
transition property takes place
now if we change here
to background
you see the box will rotate instantly
while the color will changes from pink
to green after two seconds
so
this is a translation property is it as
simple as it can be
in this video you will learn how to add
interactive hover effects to your
element
we will do an example where we will
create hover effects to our buttons
so in this tutorial we will discuss what
is the css hover effects and then we
will do an example to understand it
better
so what is the css over effect
a css hover effect is a style technique
where the user interacts with an element
with a pointing device but it does not
necessarily activates it
it is triggered when the user hovers
over an element with a pointing device
now let's jump to an example
in this example we will create the hover
effect which will look something like
this we have different hover effects for
all the buttons
so let's get started and see how you can
make this all by yourself
so we are on the sublime text writer
create two new files index.html and
style.css where we will write our html
and css code respectively
start by linking the css file with the
html file
now we'll add four anchor tags we will
specify the class name for each of them
so that we can style them separately
later
put all the anchor tag inside the div
tag and name the class middle
we'll name the class btn btn1 btn btn2
btn btnc and btn btn4
just copy paste it four times
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page right now
as you can see we have the port text on
our page
with this we are done with our html part
now let's shift to css and design the
text and add the hover effects
so in css we will start by setting the
margin and padding to zero we will also
add the background body color
as you can see the margin and padding is
now zero and we have a good background
color
now we will design the buttons and give
them proper formatting we will start
with the class middle
set the position to absolute
the top property affects the vertical
position of a positioned element the
left property affects the horizontal
position of a coefficient element the
transform property applies a 2d or 3d
transformation to an element this
property allows you to rotate scale and
move the elements
as you can see the elements are now in
place
now let's format the buttons
set the position to relative
display block
we'll keep the color as white
font size 25 pixels
we will use the font family as
montefrett
keep the text decoration to none
we will set the border to 2 pixel and
solid
we keep the text transformation repeat
we'll keep the text transformation as
upper case
transition allows you to change the
property values smoothly over the given
duration
the before selector is used to insert
something before the content of each
selected element
keep the position to absolute
we'll keep the transition as all 0.6
second and eve
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
now as you can see all the elements are
in place with proper background and text
we have the padding and border properly
formatted and now we can add the hover
effect to this button
now we'll add the hover effects to the
first button
as you can see we have the hover effect
on our first button ready
in a similar manner we can add the
effects to the second and third button
as well
we'll just copy and paste this above
code below and make changes to this code
we'll set the width to 100 here
and height to zero
we'll change it to height hundred
percent
just save the file and
refresh the page
as you can see both the buttons have the
hover effects now
now it's time to add the hover effect to
our third button
i will add the hover effect to the
button third
just save the file and go to the page
as you can see all the three buttons are
ready
now it's time to add the hover effect to
the fourth button
we will set the color to hash ff
this will change the text color to red
when we hover over the fourth button
set the position to absolute
keep the weight as 200 percent
we'll set the background to hash dcd159
we'll keep the z index as -1
keep the transition to 0.8 seconds
set the height to 180
percent of the page
now to add the over effect
write the following code
just save the file
refresh now you can see we have all the
hover effects on our four button
as you know css animations is a powerful
concept that is used to make your web
page engaging and attracting visitors to
your website
they make the user experience smooth and
entertaining
so in this video
we are going to learn how to create some
cool css effects using just html and css
so without further wasting any time
let's jump to our sublime text editor so
we are on our sublime text editor
for our example purpose i have used one
image from an unsplash.com and we have
created a simple class div clock
container for it
now let's go and style these images to
get a 3d effect so first let's design
the body part
we'll set the margin and padding to 0
pixels
we set the width to 100 percent
and we'll set the height to 100 vertical
heights
we'll keep the display as flex
and will align the items in the center
and will justify the content in the
center as well
now we'll design our container class
so for the container class we'll set the
position to relative
we'll set the width to 360 pixels
and we'll keep the height to 640 pixels
will set the margin top
to 150 pixels
and will keep the
background to white
we'll use the rgba format
we'll use the transform property to
apply a 2d or 3d transformation to an
element
so
we'll use that transform and we'll
use it it's properties we'll keep this
to
degrees
we'll set this q
to say 25 degrees
and we'll scale it to 0.8
let's discuss more about these
properties
so
the translator defines a 2d or 3d
translation the scale defines the 2d or
3d scale transformation
and this q property is used to skew
transformation along the x or y axis
now let's design the images
we'll keep the position to absolute
we'll set the width to 100
and we'll keep the transition time
to 0.5 seconds
let's go back to our page and see how it
looks up to this point
so as you can see we have the images
aligned as we want
on a flat side
now we will create the 3d transformation
when we hover over it
so let's go back to our css file
so for the 3d effect we are going to use
the edge child property
the end style selector allows you to
take a single argument that describes
the pattern for the matching element
indices in a list of siblings
we design the each image separately so
for the fourth image
we'll use the transform property and
we'll translate it to 160 pixels and
minus 160 pixels
let's copy this code
four times
okay we have to set the opacity as well
so we'll set the opacity here
to 1.
the opacity property sets the
transparency of the element
just change the number of the nth child
elements so here we'll keep it to 120
pixels
minus 120 pixel will set the opacity
to 0.8
for the second element let's keep the
translate to 80 pixels
minus 80 pixels and we'll set the
opacity
to say 0.6
and for the last image
we'll translate it to 40 pixels
and minus 40 pixels and we'll keep the
opacity
to say 0.4
so now when you save the file and you
will go back to the page
let's see how it looks
so if you refresh and hover over it
now you can see the image has a 3d over
effect over it
there are four layers to the image and
we have
designed the opacity according to the
image layer
so this is a 3d image hover
the next property we are going to
discuss is a 3d perspective image
so for this let's use a new set of
images
so we'll go back to the unsplash.com
again
and let's select one image
this one looks beautiful
so let's copy the image address
and mention it
under the image tag
just save
[Music]
now when you go back to the page
you'll see you have your image here
now let's add the 3d perspective image
design over it
so under our css file let's first design
all the elements
let's keep the margin and padding to
zero
keep the
width of the container elements 200
pixels
or say 100
let's keep the minimum height to save
100 vertical heights
and we'll use a background color of hash
let's design the image as well before
going back to the page
so we'll set the perspective to save
4000 pixels
the perspective property is used to
determine the distance between the z
plane and the user in order to give a 3d
positioned element some perspective
let's keep the width of the image 70
percent
we'll keep the position to absolute
keep the left margin to 50 percent
and drop to 50 as well
we'll use the transform property
and use the translate value of it to
minus 50 10 plus 50 percent
we'll use the transform style property
and set the value to preserve 3d
the preset 3d indicates that the
children of the element should be
positioned in the 3d space
so just save the file and let's go back
to the page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see we have the required
background image and we have the image
in a required position
now it's time to style our image
so use the transform property
and will rotate
we'll use the rotate x property of it
we'll keep it to 70 degrees
let's discuss this property translate 3d
the translate 3d css function
repositions an element in the 3d splits
it results in the transform function
data type
the transformation is characterized by a
three dimensional vector it coordinates
how much the element moves in each
direction
let's set the box shadow
to minus 80 pixels
60 pixels
pixels an rgba value to
zero comma zero comma zero
point four let's say
let's set the transition to all point
four seconds
and we'll set the transform style to
preserve 3d
so just save the file and let's go back
to our page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see the image is flat for
and ready for 3d effect
now let's design this 3d hover effect on
it
so for the 3d over effect
we'll use the
cover property image
colon hoover
over the image
we will set the transform
rotate x
0 degrees
rotate that
to 0 degrees
and translate 3d to
0 pixels comma
0 pixel comma 0 pixels
let's check this once again
this is right
now we'll set the box shadow to
zero pixels zero pixels zero pixels
zero pixels and rgba
zero comma zero comma zero comma zero
just save the file
and refresh
now when you hover over it you will see
that the perspective of the image
changes
so this is a 3d perspective image
now
there are many css effects that you can
design using these properties
in this video you will learn what is
navigation bar and its importance on a
web page
you will also learn how to create a
basic navbar using html and css
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
we will start with what is navigation
bar and why navigation bar is required
in a web page
you will look at some of the
well-designed navigation bars on
websites
after that you will work on the code to
create the basic navigation bar using
html and css
so let us begin by discussing what is
navigation bar
a navigation bar is a graphical user
interface intended to aid the user in
accessing the information
it is usually placed at the top of the
page a navigation bar needs standard
html as the base
navigation bar can be created either
vertically or horizontally
so what makes a navigation bar so
important
a navigation bar is an important element
of website design since it allows users
to quickly visit any sections within the
website
if they have ever visited a website
without a navigation bar you may have
found it difficult to locate the page
you need
you may have also had to click back
several times in order to find a link to
the next section you wanted to visit
thankfully web design has become more
standardized in the recent years and
nearly every websites now include a
navigation bar keep in mind that you
want to keep people on your site to
explore further a well-designed
navigation bar is an important part of
the user experience now let us look at
an example of a navigation bar on our
website we are on the homepage of amazon
website as you can see this is the
navigation bar that has several elements
on it
as the user clicks on these elements
they will be directed to the different
sections of the website the navigation
bar allows the user to easily move
through any section of the website
by clicking on the best sellers button
you will be redirected to the best
sellers page on the amazon
now we are going to create a navigation
bar with html in css that's going to
look like this
we'll have the following sections with
sub menus and some of them
make sure you have a text editor to
write the code
i will be using a sublime text later for
this purpose we will create two new
files index.html and style.css where we
will be writing our html and css code
respectively
let's start by adding the standard
boilerplate
keep the title as css nav bar
link your
css file with the html file by using the
link tag and hrf attribute
this navigation bar is going to consist
of a bunch of ul tags which means and
another list and list items
let's create our first another list and
this will be our main menu of the
navigation bar
i have options such as home about
contact services and news so this is
going to be our main menu
save the file let's see what it looks
like right now by opening it inside our
browser
you can see it is just an unordered list
with no menu at this point let's go
ahead and add our sub menus home will
not have any submenus but the about list
item is going to have a sub menu
add another ui tag inside the ally tag
this will create a sub menu inside the
about item save the file
just copy paste it and paste it inside
the ul tag
name them as team
clients
careers and legacy
just make the indentation properly
if you see this in the browser you'll
see that we'll have
the sub menus inside the above let's do
the same thing for contacts just copy
paste this whole section and place them
inside the contacts list rename them
according to your wish and save the file
if you go back to the browser
you will see that we'll have the
submenus inside the contacts as well
as you can see this is our complete
submenus without the styling all the
html content is ready now we are going
to write the css for it in the css file
let's apply the background image first
because it will make the page look a
little bit nicer
i have my file on my computer make sure
the image file is in the same folder as
your html and css file i am using
attack.jpg
and for the background size i will set
it to the cover which is going to adjust
it to the image screen and it's going to
cover the whole background of our web
browser
keep the font family as aerial
let's see what it looked like at this
stage you can see we have a background
image and the font is changed to arial
now let's make sure our unordered list
does not have any margins or padding by
setting it to zero
also put the list style to them because
we don't want to have any kind of
bullets under our listing
now unordered list list items they are
the main items that are going to apply
the style to the list items of the main
ul tag
float that all the text to the left
and set the given formatting
we will set the background color with
the hash value 003542
you can choose your own value from our
website known as colorpicker.com
we will fix the line height to 40 pixels
this will center the text vertically
text align to center this will align the
text horizontally and font size to 20
pixel
font size 20 pixels
let's see what it looks like now you can
see the text is floated to the left
now let's tell the actual menu link so
the menu link will be uli a
uli a
keep the text decoration
to none and color white
keep the display as block
now it's time to set the hover effect of
our array the url hover will set the
formatting when the user hovers over the
menu
we will use the background color of the
hash value de1 fcb
save the file and let's see what our
plate looks like up to this point
you can see we have the hover effect
over our menus and we have the sub menus
under the main menu
we want our sub menu should be visible
only when we hover our menus so we'll
set the uli to display none and we'll
set the hover effect to the block
let's save the file and see what our
page looks like up to this point
now you can see
our navigation bar is ready
with all the sub menus and menus at
proper places we have this nice hover
effect over the menus
in this video we will discuss some cool
tricks that every web developer should
be familiar with and which will help you
during the time of the designing of a
web page so let's jump onto the sublime
text editor and see these tricks so
the first trick is called the css blend
mode the css background blend property
sets the blend mode for each background
layer and you can blend it with image or
with different colors with the help of
this property we can blend background
image or blend them with colors
so
here's an example of the css blend mode
here you can see the images are blended
with different colors
so let's see how we can achieve this
so for our example purpose i am going to
use this image
to our page
so in the body tag add the image url
and the location of a file
keep the margin left and margin right to
auto
now let's add some style to our body tag
in the blend mode there are several
modes such as normal multiply darker and
lighter or screen
let's blend that image with
one color
so you can select the color from the
html color codes
i'll use this color for my purpose
so just copy paste here
and in the background blend mode let's
keep it to lighten
now if you save
and then refresh here
can see we have blended our image with
color
let's go back and change here something
different
let's keep it to darken
let's try something different
let's keep it to screen
so as you can see there are several
properties for this blend mode and you
can use according to your needs
the next trick is called clipping the
css clipboard property creates a
clipping region that specifies the
region that should be shown on the page
so let's understand this with the help
of an example
here we'll create a div
and give this class any class say tr
the easiest way to generate the clip
value is to use a generator
there are several websites that give the
value of the clip
so we'll use this
website to generate a clip value
suppose we want a hexagon
shaped
image on our page so here you can
adjust it according to your needs
the any shape that you want
here you can see the clip value just
copy paste it from here
now here we will use that class that we
are specified
we'll just copy paste the clip value
here
we'll keep the height to
say fifty percent or let's say fifty
percent
set the width to sixty percent as well
select the color you want to give to a
clipped image
i'll use the same color from the
previous example
so just copy paste this color code
keep the position to absolute
and the z index to minus 1
just save and go back to the page and
refresh
now you can see we have the clipped
image on our page let's try something
different
um let's say i want
a left arrow
so just copy paste this
clip
value clip path value
[Music]
just save the file
and you can see we have the arrow on our
page another must-have for web
developers is animations
css allows us to animate almost every
property that we use in the css
let's look at one example so here an
html file will just add one div tag
first
and to start with animation we'll have
to mention a keyframe the keyframes
allows us to create different steps for
our animations
we'll keep the keyframes name to blink
so here in this example we'll create a
box and we'll add different colors at
different points of animations right so
we write zero percent and we'll set the
background
to indigo
we'll change the colors five times so
just copy paste this code five times
we want next change at thirty percent so
we'll set the background here
suppose say red
at 50 we want it yellow
at 70 we want it green
and finally we'll change it to say blue
so inside the div tag we'll mention the
height and width of the box first let's
say 400 pixels and width also 400 pixels
now i'll mention the
border of the box so just set it to say
one pixel
solid black
now for the animations part
we'll set the animation for 10 seconds
and for infinite number of times
write this webkit so as to support in a
google chrome
now just save the file and go back to
our page
and here you can see we have the
animation on our box
you can style each and every element in
html using animations
another thing you can do is add pss
gradient the css gradient property
allows you to add smooth transitions
between two or more colors
for this purpose you can get the
gradient value from a website called css
gradient dot io
here in this website
you can get the mix and match of the
different colors you want to use
let's look at an example to understand
better
so here in this html file first let's
set the height
so we'll set the height to hundred
percent
now inside the body tag
will keep the height as hundred percent
will mention background color
let's select different color this time
so we will use save this color
this time
just copy paste the value here
now for the gradient value just go back
here in this website and you can select
the color you want
let's say i want a mix of this color
and
you can change the shades from here
now when you're done with the colors
just go back below and copy this
code here to your page
now when you go back to the page you
will have a beautiful gradient here
let's try one more
this time a linear gradient
just copy this value to your code
just save the file and go back to the
page and you will have a linear gradient
here
in this tutorial we are going to discuss
what is concept design and how we can
achieve this using the css media query
so let's get started making a website
with an adaptable layout is called
responsive web design and css media quiz
are one of the most important part for
responsive design
in the past building a website was much
simpler today a website layout should
adapt itself not only to computers but
also to tablet mobile devices and even
tvs
so
let's see how we can create a responsive
web layout using css media keys with the
help of an example so here we are
sublime text writer we have us our
standard wallet ready so let's create
something so let's start by creating the
four days here
we give it a class name box
with an id box one
we'll name this windows
just copy it four times
let's rename this id to box 2 and here
we'll type mac os
for the box 3 will have
[Music]
let's add some styling over here
so just open the style tag
i will text align the text we'll send
the text align to center
we'll set the background color
let's select some color
so we'll go to this recta html color
code choose a good color
set the text color to white
and we'll set the font size to say
something different
and just save the file let's go back and
refresh the page
let's figure it out
okay so first this is not valid
so after you refresh you see we have our
lives with windows mac os linux and
android and with this background color
so
to design our responsive web pages use
the media queries
so what are media queries let's first
discuss this
so a media queries are used when you
want to customize the website's
presentation according to the user's
screen size with the help of the media
queries you can display different
markups based on the device's general
type mobile desktop sub tablet you name
it
a media code is a logical operation
whenever a media query becomes true then
the related css is applied to the target
element so
to start the media query just type at
the rate
and media
now here we'll mention the max weight
to save 400 pixels
and inside this media query we write the
css code that should
take an effect when this condition is
satisfied
so here
we'll set the box one
[Music]
to display block
now
if you go back to the page and you
refresh
you see nothing happens because we have
not made this display to none so first
go back to the css code
and set display to none
now you can see we don't have any
display here so let's inspect the page
first
so you'll see we have our contents here
now you can see this is the
layout we are currently using the
current width is 685 pixels into height
to
255 pixels
now we are setting the max width to 400
pixels this means if this bit decreases
to less than 400 pixels or this css code
will kick in so let's decrease the width
here
so as you decrease
this width
you see as soon as you get less than 400
pixels our css kicks in so we have our
windows displayed here which is
the box id1 so this is how the media
query works
let's add some more media queries to
understand it better so just copy this
code down
so now let's set this minimum width
to
401 pixels
and maximum to say 600 pixels
now when this condition is true let's
say we want our box to
to display block
with color
green
so let's set the background color here
to let's
say green
now
we will add one more media query
so just copy this code
paste it here
so when the bit is from 601 pixels to
say
800 pixels
so we'll set the box 3 display
to block and color
to
flipping
so
just save this and let's understand it
on the page
so
let's
change the width of the screen
so see as soon as the width goes less
than 400 pixels we have our windows on
display
now when we increase the width size and
it goes more than 401 pixels we have the
mac os display
keep on increasing it
now see the width is more than 600
pixels and we have linux on display so
this is how we create the responsive web
design for the different devices in this
session we bring to you all the
fundamental concepts of javascript so
what is javascript
javascript is a dynamic computer
programming language which is
lightweight and object oriented
now the best part about javascript is
the fact that it's open source and is
cross-platform compatible meaning one
piece of code written in any system
regardless of the operating system
functions the same in other operating
systems as well
lastly most commonly used is a part of
web pages it allows client-side script
to interact with the user and make
dynamic pages
now moving on to the next important
question why javascript
now being the most popular language in
the world javascript has a huge fan base
and benefits from a large community
support
javascript is now being used in many
industrial fields such as web
development mobile application
development and also game development it
is very diverse in nature
there are great career opportunities for
javascript developers as this technology
seems to be holding on its own when
compared to other languages
all right now moving on let's go ahead
and execute a simple program
to understand javascript better
so we'll go ahead and execute a simple
hello world program
all right for that first thing you need
is a text editor in this case we've used
the vf code editor
so now let's go to our
text editor that is vs code and here
let's open a file
you say
file
and now you can
type in your code here so we will have
to add the javascript to the html code
and then print out the words hello world
on the browser window right that's our
objective so let's add the html
boilerplate in this file
so let's type in
html
this is our tag
and then next we have the body tag so
within the body tag
we can add the script tag to insert the
javascript into html page right so we
say script
language
equals javascript
and type
equals
text
slash
javascript
all right
let's close the file
and then
in the script we call a javascript
function that is document.write which
writes the string to our html page
right so we say document
dot write
and then braces we say hello world
okay and now we close the tags
you also close the body
and finally
all right
now when we save the file
we're going to save it say on my desktop
and i'm going to call it index dot html
right so make sure the extension is html
and then save it
and that it already exists
i say replace it
and now once you save it as an html file
you can see that the colors have
appeared so any errors will be easily
indicated here
so now let me see this and now let's go
ahead and execute the file that is
stored
so let me go back
to my desktop
and here i have index.html
there you go
when you click on the file it opens in
your browser
and you can see the words hello world
in this we will be learning all about
javascript arrays and the popular
methods of the array
so what's in it for you we'll start by
understanding what a javascript array is
then we will get to know about the
operations that we are performing on the
array
after that we'll get familiar with some
of the most used array methods
and lastly we'll go through map reduce
and filter functions
so what exactly is an array
now an array object lets you store
multiple values in a single variable
it stores a fixed size sequential
collection of elements of the same type
now an array is used to store a
collection of data and it uses only
integers as element indices
however associative areas can also use
string indices
moving on let's understand what array
operations are
now we can perform various operations on
an array in javascript
but let's start by creating an area
so for that let's go ahead and create a
folder first which will consist of the
file that we're creating right so for
that
let me just
go ahead and create a folder
and i'll call it demo underscore adding
so once you're done with that open your
visual studio code editor
and here say open folder
and click on demo array
okay it's creating the workbench all
right and now here you can see
the new file icon so go ahead
and create
demo.html file
all right here you go now let's start
typing the code
the first thing we do is type in our
tag
and here i have the head tag
and let me say javascript
tutorial
all right and now let's create the body
tag
now within the body tag i create a
paragraph tag and create an id
and let me call it demo
and then close the tag now i'll explain
to you why we're doing this a little
later
so first let's go ahead and create the
script tag
so say script
and within the script let's create our
array so let me use the keyword let
and say we give the name of the array
cars
equals in square base braces
we say bmw
and
volvo
[Music]
and then say
honda
all right so now we create an array now
one more thing is that we use the
keyword let so that which indicates that
the array can be changed throughout the
program
all right so now we go ahead and display
it so
i say document
[Music]
dot get element by id
and here i say now the id
created was demo so i say demo here
and i use the dot
inner html property
which is equal to cars
okay let me change this to bmw first
all right so what exactly in our html
does is that it is responsible for what
is being displayed on the web page
okay now since we've taken id as demo
any changes made is reflected in this id
and then displayed onto the web browser
all right so let's save this and now
execute the file
so here i go back to my folder and then
to the file and go ahead and click on it
so there you go
the heading is displayed and the entire
array is displayed here
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
okay so i hope this was easy to
understand
now let's go ahead
the next operation is to access an array
element
so let's go back to our vs code
and here
let's create another variable say let
bmw bmw is a variable don't get confused
with the array element so bmw equals
cars
of the index 0.
so basically
cars of 0 is nothing but
bmw all right so that is being saved in
the
variable bmw
and now let's just go ahead and display
this
so we let's just copy this
and place it here and instead of cars
you use the variable name bmw that is
this one
all right
so now let's save this
and when we
execute it
you see bmw here
that's how you retrieve an element from
an array
next up we have the addy length property
which displays the length of the array
so again let me show you how to do that
let's go back to our code
and here let's create a variable and
let's call it length variable so i say
let l e n
equals
cars dot left
now you can use the length property
which will retrieve the length of the
array for us it's as simple as that
and now after this
again let's just
copy the same
code here and then
let's
pass length okay
now let's save this
and when you execute it again
it says three
so we've successfully retrieved the
length of the array
all right so the next operation is to
access the last array element right so
let's go back to our vs code
and now let's create another variable
and let's call it last
and we'll just say last equals cars
and within square braces
cars dot length
minus one
right
so basically
the length of the array is three and
three minus one is two so it should
retrieve
cars of two which is honda right
so let's just
execute this and we pass last here
save it and see if it
displays honda for us
there you go
it's as simple as that
all right so moving on
the next array operation is loop over an
array item
so for that let's go to our
code
and here
let's use the for loop so i say cars
dot
for each
and within this
we'll say
item
comma index
comma array
and now we use the arrow function
and display the content on the console
so i say console.log
of item
along with its index
so let's save this
and now let's go ahead and execute it
all right now as you can see nothing is
printed on your web page right because
whatever is being printed has to be
printed in your console so now click on
f12 which opens the developer options
and here you can see console so click on
that and now you can see the name of the
item in the array along with its index
so you see bmw 0 volvo 1 and honda 2.
all right
so moving on
now that we've learnt about the array
operations let's go ahead and learn
about the array methods
so the first method is tostring now as
the name suggests it is used to convert
an array into a string
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
and now
let's copy the same
code here
and here instead of last i just say
cars dot
to string
now you can use this method
to convert the array into a string so
let's save this
and let's execute it
all right
now here the same output is shown
which means that the type has only been
changed to string type
all right moving on
the next method is pop now pop basically
removes the last element from the array
so let me show you how that works let's
go back to our vs code and here
we have to save
the pop element into a variable right so
let's create a variable say last
okay and oh since last is already used
let me call it last one
[Music]
last one of cars dot pop
now you can use the pop method to pop
the element
and now you can just
copy the same code
to display this onto our web page
and here
i just say
last one
now
since we've popped the last element the
array has only two elements right that
is bmw and volvo so if you want to
display the last element it should
display volvo right so what we can do is
we can just create another variable say
last two
and just
use the same logic here
okay
and now let's just
display it on your console and let's say
last two all right so now let's save it
now the popped element has been saved in
last one which is displayed on the web
page
and the last element of the array after
the pop function has to be displayed on
our console so let's go ahead and
execute the file
alright so honda has been displayed that
is the element that has been removed
from the array
and now once we check our console
here you go here you can see volvo
which means that is the last element in
the array
moving on
the next method is the push method now
as the name suggests it is used to add a
new element to the array and remember to
the end of the array so let's go back to
our vs code
and here let me say cars
dot push
push is the method that we're using
inside of which we'll say
audi all right
and now let's just display the same
things so let me copy this
and here let me say
cars
okay so let me save it
and once i execute it
it says bmw volvo and audi so we've
successfully added another element to
the end of the array
so the next method is the shift method
now basically shift is used to remove
the first element from the array now
this method shifts all the elements
reducing the indexes of every element by
one all right let me show you how this
works
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just say cars
dot shift
it's as simple as that
and let's just display this
let me copy the same thing
let's save it
and when we execute it
here you can see it just displays volvo
and od so now cars has array elements
volvo and audi
with array indices 0 and 1.
all right so moving on the next method
is unshift
all right so to add an element into the
beginning of an array we use the unshift
method
therefore this method increases the
array index by one
right so let's go back to our vs code
and use the same function
unshift
let's say
dot unshift
and here we go let's
save it and here we have to specify what
we're adding right let me say
hyundai okay
let's save this
and when we execute it
you can see hyundai volvo and audi
as simple as that
all right moving on the next method is
the concat method now this is basically
used to merge two different areas
right so let's go back to our vs code
and here
let's create another array first
and let's just call the array
bikes
okay
and let's create say
yamaha
and
let's say suzuki
[Music]
and then we'll say royal enfield
okay
and now
let's save this
and say let
vehicles this is another array
which is basically the after
concatenation
the entire array is saved into this
array all right so let's say
dot concat
[Music]
or bikes we just concat bikes and cars
together
okay and then let's just
display this over the web page so
let me change this to vehicles
all right
let me save this
so let's go ahead and execute it
there you go now both the areas have
been merged together into a single array
so the next array method is the sort
method
now basically sort is used to sort the
entire array into ascending order
all right so let's go back to our editor
and here
let's just use the
sort method on the
array vehicles all right
vehicles dot sort
okay
and
let's just
display this on our web page
so
again
let's go back and
execute it and here you can see it has
been sorted
the next method
is the reverse method so the reverse
method is again used to reverse the
elements in an array so it's logic right
so sort was used to sort it in ascending
order now when you reverse it it just
sorts it in this ascending order
so let's go back here
i'm going to copy the same thing
all right and here instead of sort
let me just say reverse
so let's save this
and execute it
there we go
it has displayed the entire array in the
reverse order
all right
with that we finish the area methods
next up we have map reduce and filter
first up we have array.map
now the map method is used for creating
a new array from an existing one by
applying a function to each and every
one of the elements in the first array
and it does not change the original
array all right so to make you
understand this better let's go back to
our
visual studio code
and now here let's first create another
area
okay so let me call this num1
and let's have
integers let's say 2 3 4 5
6 and 7
okay
and now let's have another array
num2
so let's go ahead and say num1
dot
map
of let me define a function
say multiply
okay
so multiply is the function that is that
i'm going to define here
so let's say function
multiply
of value
okay
and inside this let me say return
value
into 2
okay
so what this basically does
is that it multiplies each and every
element of the array num1 by 2 and saves
the new elements into the array num2
okay
now after this
let's go ahead and
display the content so let me copy this
and let's display the content
in the array num2
right so let me save it
let's go back here
execute it
so there you go
every element has been multiplied by 2
and then displayed again
i hope this was clear for you
now the next method is the filter method
so the filter method takes each element
in an array and applies a conditional
statement against it
and if this condition returns true the
element gets pushed onto the output
array but if it returns false the
element does not get pushed
all right so let me show it to you
now
let's
go ahead and create another
variable
say num3
and here i say num1
dot
filter
of say comp
now comp is a function
let me define the function
here let me say function
comp
of value
takes a value as a parameter
within which i am going to check
if the value is greater than 4
now it only appends the element into the
array num3 if the value is greater than
all right
so now let me just
go ahead and change this to num3
all right
let's save this
and when we go back and execute
here we go
now the values so let's go back here let
me check
now num1 had the values 2 3 4 5 6 and 7
right so according to this it has to
only display 5 6 and 7. do not get
confused with num2 here
we've passed num1 here so it checks put
this array
right
so according to the logic it should
display 5 6 and 7
and it has done so here
okay
moving on
the next method
is the reduce method
now the reduce method reduces an array
of values down to just one single value
now to get the output value it runs a
reducer function to each element of that
array
okay now this method does not reduce the
original array again
so let's go back to our vs code
now let me create
another
variables in num4
and say num1 dot reduce
and let me call it sum
so what we're basically doing is that
we're adding all the digits 2 3 4 5 6
and 7 in num1 to a single value right
that is the sum and then we're going to
be displaying that
so what we're going to do is let's
define the function here function sum
basically is total comma value
right
and then here let's say return
total plus
the value
okay
and after this
i'm going to
display the content so let's say
num 4
okay
let's
save it
go back and execute
here we go it displaces some of the
entire values in the array we're
learning all about javascript loops
if you're new to javascript i suggest
you go through our previous videos on
this topic
so without further ado let's begin and
look at what's in store for you
so we're going to be covering topics
like for loop
while loop which also includes the do
while loop and then we're going to learn
about breaking out of a loop and then
we'll see how to skip a loop cycle
now before jumping into the for loop
let's first understand what exactly a
loop is
right so a loop is basically a
programming construct that executes a
piece of code as long as a certain
condition is met
all right and there are two different
types of loops we have entry control
loops and exit control loops
now what exactly are entry control loops
now these are the loops where the test
condition is checked before executing
the piece of code for example you have
the for loop and the while loop so in
their case before entering the loop the
condition is checked and only if the
condition is met it enters the loop and
executes the code
all right when it comes to exit control
loops the test condition is checked
after the loop has been executed
all right so in this case the loop at
least gets executed i mean the code in
the loop gets executed at least once
so the example for this is the two while
loop
all right with this basic knowledge
let's go ahead and learn about the
different loops
so the first loop is the for loop
all right
so what exactly is a for loop this is
the basic logic and the flowchart in
front of you so what exactly happens is
that say for example you want to print
the word looping
say 10 times right so what you can do is
you can start and you can have a for
loop which goes from 0 to 9
and then you increase the number by 1
every time you print the loop
once it's equal to 10 or even greater
than 10 it ends the loop
right
so let me help you understand this
better with an example so let's go to
our editor that is vs code
here i've created a folder called demo
underscore loops within which i've
created a file called for loops
all right so now let's just write down
our initial
code for html that is
html
and then i have a head tag
[Music]
within which i say javascript
loops
all right
now i have a body
[Music]
tag within which i give a heading for
clearer understanding let me have a
heading say
javascript
[Music]
for loops
all right
let me just call it for loop
now let's have the script tag
[Music]
within which
i'll have
a variable say x
and now we have the for loop so we say
for
x equals
x less than
x plus plus
within which i say console.log
of x
so basically
what happens is
now you have
the first variable which is called the
counter variable now this keeps track of
how many times the code is being
executed
right and next
i less than 5 is the condition now
the loop keeps executing as long as the
condition is met
and lastly the counter variable is
incremented and usually it's incremented
by one
right so here we've done the same thing
and
inside the loop we print the value of x
all right so let me save the file
and then execute it
all right it's printed javascript loops
here let me just go back
okay my bad i missed out on the title
tag
so this has to be enclosed within the
title tag
so let me just
change it here
now let's save this
let's go back and just refresh the page
and that is it so whatever is in the
title tag basically appears here all
right so now since we're printing the
value of x on our console we have to
inspect our element so let's go here
and here let's check on console
and here you can see all the values have
been printed from 0 to 4.
all right now this is a simple for loop
so next up is a while loop
now the logic is similar to that of a
for loop
first the condition is checked and if
the condition holds true then the code
is executed and if it is false it
terminates
all right so moving on let's understand
the general syntax
so here first you have the variable
whose value keeps changing
and then you have the ending condition
which is basically the maximum value a
variable can reach all right so let's go
back to our vs code
and here for better understanding let me
just change this to
javascript while loop
all right let's just
delete this and here
let's initialize the value of x to 1.
and now i say while
x
less than or equal to 5
within braces i
say console.log
x
and then i increment the value of x
all right so let me save this
and let's execute the file
all right so it says javascript while
loop and let's inspect
and here in our console it displays
the values of x
all right so according to the logic
x is initially initialized to 1
and the value
gets executed once it enters the while
loop
all right it's incremented and then
checked every time
until the value reaches
6 right and then it breaks from the loop
since the value does not hold true and
then it terminates
so this is a logic behind the while loop
next up is the two while loop
now here
as you can see
first the code is executed and then the
condition is checked if the condition is
true then the code execution continues
and if it falls it's terminated
all right so this is an exit control
loop
also in an exit control loop
the code is executed at least once
so let's go back to our vs code
and here
let me just delete this
now let's initialize x to say
15 all right
and now i use the do keyword
within which i write the code
so first i am going to print the value
of x
console
dot log of x
and then i increase my value
and here i mentioned my test condition
which is while
x
less than say 10.
all right so according to the logic
initially the value is x and once it
enters the loop
here
it should print the value of x which is
15 all right and then it increments the
value but once it comes out of the loop
it checks for the condition
here the condition says less than 10 but
since x is not less than 10 it prints
the value x that is 15 and then
terminates
all right so let's save this
and execute it
let me execute this
and here
let's check
the console
so there we go it prints 15. so what it
does is that it prints the value 15
first and then checks the condition
now
let's go ahead and change the value of x
to say
all right
so now it enters a loop
and then it prints the value of x and
then increments it
and when it comes out of the loop and
checks the condition
as long as the value of x remains less
than 10 it prints it
okay
so let's save this
go back here
and let's refresh the page
and here you can see the values 5 to 9
are printed
so this is how the do while loop works
moving on to the next concept
breaking out of a loop
now as the name suggests break is the
keyword that is used to break out of a
loop
now here is a simple code for you
so according to the logic it prints the
values
between 1 to 10
and say at the value 5 you want to break
out of the loop you can simply use the
keyword break
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just
make it simple
and save
or
x equals 1
x less than or equal to 10
let's increment it
and within the loop
let's
display the value x
on the console and then
we're going to check for the condition
if x equals 5
all right
so if x equals 5
we break out of the loop
so let's save the file and execute it
and there you go it's displayed the
values from 1 to 5.
so basically the code inside the for
loop is executed and once the value of x
reaches 5 it breaks from the loop
simple right
all right so let's move on
next up we have skipping a loop cycle
all right
so here
what exactly we do is we make use of a
keyword continue to skip a particular
loop cycle
say in this case we have a for loop
which displays the values of i
ranging from 1 to 10
however we want to skip the cycle when
it reaches the value 3. so what we do is
we make use of the keyword continue here
so basically it displays 1 and 2 and
skips the third cycle and then directly
displays 4
all right so let me show you in our
vs code editor
here
let me just remove this and save
if
x equals
i'm going to continue
all right
after which
i'm going to say console
dot log of x
so let me save this
and then execute it
so here
let me refresh the page
and there we go
as you can see it displays one two three
and four and the fifth cycle
is kept
all right and the rest of the digits are
displayed so that is how you can skip a
loop
i highly suggest you also practice all
of this and then play around with loops
to get a better understanding
so taking a step forward we're going to
learn about javascript objects so
without further ado let's begin and look
at what's in store for us
first we'll start by understanding what
a javascript object is
then we learn how to create a javascript
object and also get to know about the
properties of these objects
after that we'll get familiar with using
javascript methods lastly we'll
understand what javascript accessors are
so what is a javascript object
javascript is an object-oriented
programming language so everything in
java is an object
a javascript object is like a real-world
entity having state and behavior for
example a car
now we can take a car as an object it
will have its state like color and model
it will also have behaviors like
accelerate and break
javascript is template based and we can
create objects without having the need
to create a class
generally object is accompanied by a
class that defines an object's
blueprints but javascript doesn't
require any class to be defined for
objects
moving on to the next concept
to create a javascript object
now basically there are three different
ways of creating a javascript object all
right so we look at them one by one
the first one is to use a literal to
create and define a javascript object
so let's go to our vs code editor
now if you have any doubts regarding the
initial setup then i suggest you go
through the previous video that is
javascript arrays
to get you started with it so here i
have created a folder called demo
objects
and now i'm going to create a file
called
create
underscore objects
dot html
all right
so we'll begin by writing the initial
code
that is the head and the body so i say
html
[Music]
but in this i
create the head tag
[Music]
and then i create a title tag
and let's say
javascript
objects
then after the head tag i'm going to
create a body tag
and
let's create a heading and say
creating javascript
objects
okay
and now we create
an id
all of this is explained in the previous
video i really suggest you go through
the video before hand so that you get a
clear picture
and then i say id equals
say demo
and then i'm gonna close it
now the first method that we're going to
use to create an object is by using
object literals
right
so what we can do is say script
within which i declare a variable
say where student
now within the object we're going to
create three different properties now
this is basically like a dictionary it
has a property a key and then a value
okay so i say name
property
and let's say
chris
and then another property say age and
say 21
and another property
studies
and say maybe computer science
okay
so this is the syntax used to
create an object using an object
literally
now after this what we're going to do is
we're going to display this right now we
want to display the message saying chris
of age 21 studies computer science
so what we can do is say document dot
get element by id
and the id that we're going to pass is
demo
and we say
in
html
equals
student dot name
which is chris
after which we display the message
of the age
and then the age that is student dot age
studies
student
dot
studies
okay let's save this
and when we
execute the file it says chris of the
age 21 studies computer science
all right this is one of the ways in
which you can define an object
all right so moving on to the next way
of creating a javascript object it is to
use the new keyword now this is the most
traditional way of creating an object
right so let's go back to our vs code
let's create another script
within which we say
where student
equals new
object
i'm sure everybody has learned the same
way the same syntax
so
this is one of the ways
after which we can say student top name
equals
chris
again student dot age
equals 21
[Music]
and then
student dot
studies
[Music]
equals computer science
all right
now after this we again
display the message so let me just copy
this
[Music]
all right
so let's save this
and run our code again
and there we go it displays the message
chris of the age 21 studies computer
science
all right this was the second method
used to create an object
all right so then moving on to the third
method
it is to use an object constructor to
create and define a javascript object
so let's go back to our code editor
and here
we define a function so we say function
say start
with three parameters
that is name
age
and say
studies
okay
and now
within the function we use the keyword
this
so we say this dot name
equals name
[Music]
all right
we say this dot h
equals h
we say this dot
studies
[Music]
equals studies
now what we do is that we can
create a variable and pass parameters to
the function so we say where
student
equals
stud and within braces we say
chris
comma 21
comma computer science
[Music]
all right so we've done passing the
parameters
after this
we're going to copy the same
print message
here
[Music]
all right so let's
save this and execute our file
so let's refresh the web page
and there we go it still displays the
message chris of the age 21 studies
computer science so this was the third
method that can be used to create
objects
moving on to the next topic
object properties
now a javascript object is basically a
collection of unordered properties right
values associated with the javascript
object are called its properties
and properties can usually be added
updated or deleted excluding read-only
properties
so now let's have a look at the demo to
help you understand this better
so let me go back to my
vs code so this is where we left off
and this is how we created objects right
so now let me create another file
and let me call it
[Music]
objects underscore properties
html
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to copy the first piece of code
here
all right let me just copy this
into my
new file
and here as you can see student is the
object that we've created and name agent
studies are the three properties
now say we want to update the age all
right so what we can do is here we can
just say student
dot h
equals
let me change it to 24 all right
and let me save this
and when we execute the file that was
object underscore properties
you can see chris of the age 24 so 21 is
updated to 24.
so this is one of the ways you can do it
or there's another method
you can just assign the property to a
variable and then display the variable
instead so what we can do
is we can just assign student.h
to a property say x
and here instead of displaying
student.age we can just say
x
all right so let's save this
and when we run it
it says 21 because we haven't updated
21 to 24 anywhere all right
so 21 remains the same
so another method we can use
is we can just say
x equals h
so we're directly assigning the property
to the variable
and here
when i'm displaying it i say student
of x
all right
so let me
save this
and when you look at the web page
it still displays the same thing these
are different ways of accessing the
properties you can update them delete
them unless they're read-only
all right so let's move on to the next
concept object methods
now basically a javascript method is an
action that can be performed on the
objects
so you'll understand better with the
help of the demo
so let's go back to rbs code and here
i've created another html file called
objects underscore methods all right so
let's let me just copy the initial
code
paste it here and let's have the
enclosing tags as well
and html all right now here i declare
another tag that is the button tag so
we're going to be making this a button
here so i say button
id equals click me so that is the action
that i'm going to
be performing
and the message that is going to be
displayed on the button will be
click
all right
so we're going to see the usage of it a
little later
now let's go ahead and create an object
so i say script
[Music]
within which i create
the user object
[Music]
so we're creating using a object little
here
and i declare the property name
as chris again
and age
say 24
okay
so let's close this
all right so the next thing i'm going to
do is i'm going to create a new function
that we will use as an object method
all right so i say function
and let's give the name say hi
okay
within the function we declare
we basically display a message
so we're going to say
and hello
all right so this is going to be
displayed in a separate dialog box
so now once the declaration is done
what we're going to do
is we're going to use
create another property basically say
user dot
let's say message
and assign
say hi to it
so basically what we're doing
is we're adding the previously created
method
to a new property that is user dot
message the message property all right
so now i say
document dot get element by id
and say demo
[Music]
and the message that i want is just
hi
plus the username
all right
[Music]
so what we're going to do is we're going
to display the message hello
all right when the user clicks on the
button
so for that let's say
let's just copy this
[Music]
and here
instead of demo
right we're going to be passing the id
click me
as per this and the event is going to be
on click event so here i say on click
after which
i'm going to simply pass
user dot
message
let me just delete this
all right so here i noticed that i've
given an equal to sign i'm sorry it's a
colon
all right
so let's save the file
and let's go ahead and execute it
all right so here you can see hi chris
being displayed and once we click on the
button
you can see
an alert which says hello
all right
so now let's move on to the next concept
that is java object accessors
now getters and setters allow defining
an object accessor all right to get the
value of a property in a javascript
object we use a getter and to set the
value of a property of a javascript
object we use a setup so let's go back
to our demo
and now let me create another file
and let's call it
object
accessors
and now again let me just
copy the first initial part
[Music]
all right so now
let's go ahead and create a new
object so let me say script
within which i say where
and let's call it car
all right
so let me define the properties say
model
and
the model is say bmw
320d
and
another property say color
and let's say it's navy blue
and the last property say fuel type
and let's say it's
diesel
[Music]
now what we can do is we can you make
use of the keyword get
to access the properties so i say get
and say fuel
within which i return
this dot
fuel
type
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's display it
document dot
get element by id
demo
dot inner html equals we say car
dot
fuel
all right so now let's save it
and execute our file
here you go it retrieves diesel for us
now this is one of the ways of accessing
the properties
now to help you understand setter
let's go ahead and create another
object
all right say where car again
now let's say the model
is
audi a4
[Music]
color would be bright
red
[Music]
and if you will type
let's keep it blank
all right
now to set the value we use the set
keyword we say set fuel
the parameter is fuel
within which we say this
dot fuel type
[Music]
equals fuel
right
now let's set the value for the fuel
say car dot
fuel
equals
petrol
all right
now let's display the same
let me copy this
and what we want to display is the fuel
type right so here we say fuel type
so let's save this
and let's go ahead and
execute the file
and there we go it retrieves petrol
so what it does is basically it assigns
the value petrol to the property fuel
type and then we display the same on our
web page
so this is how you make use of getters
and setters
we're going to be learning all about
javascript this keyword
so without further delay let's jump
right in
so you must have heard about this
keyword several times so in javascript
this keyword basically refers to an
object which is executing the current
piece of code well in simple terms this
keyword basically just references the
object that is executing the current
function
now if the function that is being
referenced is a regular function
then this keyword references the global
object
all right i'm sure it must be a little
tricky at the moment but please hold on
and if the function that is being
referenced is a method in an object
then this keyword references the object
itself
so to help you understand the concept
better and to clarify all your doubts
let's look at a simple demo
so here in vs code i've created a file
called this.html
all right you can give it a name of your
choice now here
let me first
define a variable
and let's call the variable
say
value
and let's set it to say 50
all right
now let's go ahead and create a simple
function
so let me say function
[Music]
my function
all right
and within this
let me define the value
for value
let me set the value for
the variable value as hundred
okay
and now let me just alert it all right
so let me say alert
value
[Music]
okay plus value
and then let me have another alert
message
which is going to display this dot value
so let me just say this value
[Music]
and
instead of just saying value i say this
dot value
all right now after this let's go ahead
and call the function
my function
so let me just save this and execute it
so here it says value equals hundred
and then when you see this dot value it
says 50. so now here you can come back
to the code and see
now when i just say value it takes the
value 100 all right which is taken
locally but when i say this dot value
since it is a normal function its
references to the global variable which
is here
this value
i hope this makes sense to you now
now moving on let's look at the behavior
of this keyword within an object method
so let me create an object here
but before that let me just
comment this out
let's say script
and now let's create an object so
let's say const
and then i give the name of my object as
random
and within this let me say name and
let's call it
john
and then i create a method called info
okay and within this i display a console
message
that says hi
my name is
and now i make use of this keyword i say
this
dot name
all right
and now let me just go ahead and call
this method
so i say random
dot info
all right so let's save this and execute
it
so let me check my console
and there you go it says hi my name is
john
so if you clearly observe here
when we say this dot name since it is
being used within a method that is
defined inside an object
it references to this
property here
all right unlike this case where it
reference to the global variable that
was mentioned outside
so i hope this helped you understand the
difference between the two
now let's look at another simple example
so now let me just change the value of
name here
to say tutorial
and now let's define another property
which is basically an array so let me
just call the property video
within which i have an add a let's say
javascript
another value
say this
and then let's say keyword
and in my info method i'm going to just
display these video tags
so
let me just
say
this okay let me just delete this first
and let's say this
dot video
now since it's an array we can make use
of for each
and now for each in turn takes a
callback function
and then i say
i'm going to call it
a tag
the parameter that's being passed
within which i just console log it
and say
tag
all right so let me save it
and then execute
this now here you can see that the
values in the video property are
displayed that is javascript this and
keyword
now let's suppose
that you want to display the name along
with every
string here right so
naturally you would go ahead and just
say
this
dot
name
right it makes perfect sense
so let me just
save and execute this
now if you see just the values of the
property video are displayed here
now the main reason for this is
if you closely observe that this
function here is mentioned within the
callback function
right so when it is referencing it is
referencing to the global object
which is unclear which is undefined in
this case so to overcome this what we
can do is that
the for each method takes in two
properties one is the function the other
one is the object
so here we just pass this
all right so what happens is it's going
to reference the current object that is
random so let me save this and then
execute it
and there you go
you can see that tutorial that is the
name has been displayed
all right i hope you understood the
concept of this keyword it could be a
little tricky but as you work on it
you'll get the hang of it
we're going to learn all about
javascript functions in our previous
videos we've covered topics like
javascript arrays and loops
if you're new to this topic i suggest
you go through these topics before
all right so before jumping in let's go
ahead and look at what's in store for us
first we're going to learn what exactly
javascript functions are
then we'll look at javascript function
expressions then the function
constructor
self-invoking functions functions as
values functions as objects arrow
functions generator function and the
predefined functions
also don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to our first topic
what are javascript functions
so basically a function is a group of
reusable code which can be called from
anywhere in your program right
when you have a piece of code that you
want to execute repeatedly in your
entire program it makes more sense to
define it once and call it over and over
right it makes the code more efficient
and readable this also helps programmers
write modular codes
so this is the syntax you make use of
the function keyword followed by which
you mentioned the name of the function
the name of the function is completely
your choice
next you mentioned the parameter list
and within curly braces you can define
the function now the function body is
basically the code that is executed
every time the function is called
so let's go to our vs code editor
and here i created a folder called demo
functions within which i've created an
html file called functions.html
all right and now i've just typed in the
initial code
now let's create a function
so let me say script
within which i use the keyword that is
function keyword
and now i give
the name for my function i say my
underscore
function
and the function takes
a parameter say value now this function
basically returns the square of the
digit all right
so within which
i say
document.getelementbyid
the id is demo
and now it just displays value
into value
all right so the function basically
displays the square of the number
now outside the function let me call the
function
does
my function
let me pass the value 5
all right now let's save this
and execute it
so let me go back to my file
and here we go it displays the value 25
so this was a simple function which took
a value
a digit as a parameter and then returned
the square
moving on to the next concept
function expression
now what we learned previously was
function declaration
but a function can also be defined as an
expression
now this is what the syntax looks like
now here the function is created and
assigned to the variable explicitly like
any other value
the meaning remains the same that is you
create the function and store the value
that it returns into a variable and in
our case it's x right so let's go to our
vs code and let me help you understand
this better
so now
i create another function
and here i say
let
x equals let's use a simpler function so
i just mentioned
function
and within curly braces i display an
alert message
and i display a message saying hello
all right
now
after that to display the message what
we can do is let me just copy this
output
code
and replace it here
and here what we're going to be
displaying is the value x right now
since it consists of a function you'll
have to type the curly braces now this
is crucial for its execution all right
so let me save this
and then execute
let me execute this
and here you go it says the site says
hello so we've successfully executed the
piece of code
we can also assign this variable x to
another variable and then call that
variable instead right we can say let
y equals x
and instead of calling x here
we can simply call y
let me save it and then let me refresh
the page
and there we go it still displays the
message hello
all right so this is one of the ways of
defining a function that is as an
expression
moving on to our next concept function
constructor
now javascript functions are defined
using the keyword function right now
functions can also be defined using a
javascript built-in function
now this is the basic syntax so here
we've created a function called my
function and we've used the keyword new
after which we've used the constructor
function
and inside we provide the parameter list
after that the return value
next you can call the function here
right so let me just go back to my vs
code
and now
let me just make changes to the same
piece of code here
i create a function say
my underscore function
okay
all right let me just change the name
to my function all right
and then here i use the keyword new
and the function constructor that is
function
[Music]
within which i'm passing all the
parameters
so i have
a
b
and i'm going to return the sum of the
digits
all right
and now while calling the function
let me just store the value in a
variable say x
and let's call the function that is my
function
with the parameters
2 and 3.
all right
and now let me
display it
so i'm just going to copy this
and i want to display the value of x
right
all right so let me save this
and execute it
if you refresh the page it displays the
sum that is 5.
to make it more readable let me just
display another message here
let me just say
the sum is
x all right
let me save it and then refresh the page
it says the sum is 5.
all right now this is how you make use
of the function constructor
next up we learn about self-invoking
functions
now as the name suggests these functions
are invoked automatically without being
called
now previously when we learnt about
function expressions we saw that
parentheses were crucial
so you have to add parentheses around
the function to indicate that it is a
function expression
so here is a syntax value so what we've
done is we've made sure we've enclosed
the entire function within parentheses
so let me help you with that let's go
back to our vs code
and let me create another script
and here
let me create the function within the
parentheses
and say function
it's not taking any parameters
instead it is going to
alert a message so let me say
hello
welcome
all right
after which
we're going to call the function so
again we have to mention the parentheses
let's save this
and execute
so when we
refresh the page
it says hello welcome
so we never called the function
rather it got invoked by itself so these
are self-invoking functions
now let's go ahead and look at functions
as values
now in javascript a function is
basically a value so we can deal with it
as a value now here is a simple syntax
now if you closely look at the syntax
you might think that this is same as
function expressions well no in this
case what we do is we first define the
function and then we assign it to a
particular variable but in the case of
expressions the function definition was
defined during the initialization of the
variable right and also we have to
specify the parenthesis in order to call
the function
so to help you understand this better
let me go back to our vs code
and here
let me just erase this
and let's define a function
that returns the product of two digits
so let me just call it product
which takes two parameters let me say a
and b
within which we return the value
a into b
all right now after this let's create
another variable say y
equals
function oh i'm sorry the name of the
function is product
so product
of 2 and 5
all right so this basically returns us
10 right so let me just
copy this to display this on our web
page
and here i change the message to the
product
and here let me change it to y
so let's save this and execute it
so let me refresh the page and here you
go you can see the message the product
is 10.
now what we can do is we can make
alterations to this
now say i want to multiply the value
with 5 again
right so basically this returns 10 and
that value is multiplied by 5. so let me
save this
and
refresh our page and there we go it
returns
and there we go it displays 50. so this
is how you can make use of functions as
values
moving on to the next topic functions as
objects
now javascript functions are a special
type of objects called function objects
now a function includes a string which
holds the actual code that is the
function body of the function
the code is literally just a string
although not recommended you can also
create a function with the help of the
function constructor i will show that
you a little later on but for now let's
look at the syntax
now here we have a variable called body
which basically consists of the function
body it's enclosed in double quotes and
that's a mistake please ignore it
all right so next we have variable
function name here we create a function
using the keyword new and then we pass a
parameter list
and the body basically tells us what the
function returns
all right
next we have an alert message to call
the function
so let me just show how this is executed
back in our vs code let me create
another
function
and let's say the function returns the
area of a circle right so let me just
create
a body variable
which returns
so the area of a circle is pi r square
so we make use of math
dot pi
into radius
right
so it's basically pi r square
after which let's see
where circle
[Music]
and here let's create a function using
the new keyword
function
and then here we pass
the value that is the radius
and then the body
right so basically
this is the definition of our function
so let's use alert
to display the area so we say alert of
circle
or five
all right let me save this
and execute it
so when you refresh the page
it displays the area of the circle
so this is how you can use functions as
objects
moving on to our next concept arrow
functions
now functions can be written more
compactly and more precisely with the
help of arrow functions all right now
arrow function expressions are
ill-suited as methods and they cannot be
used as constructors
now also while using arrow functions
using const is a safer option because a
function expression is always a constant
value
so this is the syntax now you can only
omit the return keyword
within the curly braces if the function
is a single statement
so this is the syntax first you provide
the name of the function
with an equal to sign
followed by the argument list
and later you make use of this arrow
icon and define the expression
so this is basically nothing
but this
so let's go back to our vs code and
check for ourselves
so let's create another function
and here let me say
const
my funk
equals now say we want to display the
product of three digits so let me just
pass a b c of my parameters
and make use of this icon which
indicates that this is an arrow function
within which i say return
a
into b into c
all right
now let me just
assign this to a variable
okay let me say
product
because we've used x here
and then let me call my function that is
my func
and pass the value 2 3 and say 4.
all right so let's display
the product so let me just copy this
code
and here let me say the product
of the three
digits is
and let me say product here because that
is what is being used here right
all right so let me save this and
execute it
all right first it displays the area of
the circle
all right and then we say okay
and there we go it displays the message
the product of the three digits is 24.
so let me do one thing let me just
comment this out
okay
let me save it and then execute it again
it just displays this
all right so this is how we can make use
of arrow functions
moving on let's look at the generator
function
now regular functions typically return
only one value right or a single value
or sometimes even nothing but a
generator function can return multiple
values
and the speciality is that it can do it
so on demand all right now to create a
generator function we make use of an
asterisk
so an asterisk indicates that the
function is a generator function
so here you can see that we have a
function followed by asterisks and we've
created a function called generator
sequence
so here you can see we have the asterisk
after the keyword function followed by
the name of the function right
but the main method of a generator
function is the next method
when this method is called it basically
runs the execution until the nearest
yield value
all right all the nearest yield
statement
then the function execution pauses and
the yielded value is returned to the
outer code
all right so the result of the next
method is always an object with two
properties it has a value property which
is basically the yielded value
and then it has a done property which
displays true if the function code is
finished or false if it's otherwise
so let me show it execution for a
clearer understanding so let's go back
to our vs code
and here let's create the generator
function
let's say function
asterisk
[Music]
generate
function all right
now within which
i make use of the keyword yield
and i say yield 1 first
followed by yield
and finally i make use of return which
indicates the termination so i say
return 3
all right
now we make use of
a variable say generator
and assign it to the generator function
that is generate
func
and now i create another variable say 1
which will basically
return the value when i call the next
function so here i say generator
dot
next
okay
so whatever generator dot next returns
it's stored in one
so to display the message i say alert
and now i'm going to make use of a
method called json.stringify
[Music]
all right so basically this method
converts a javascript object or a value
to a json string
all right so within which i'm going to
say
that is this
all right
so now let me save this
and execute it
let me refresh the page and there you go
here it returns
two properties that is value and done it
says value is one and done is false
right it is false because we haven't
reached the return statement yet
so what we can do is to display the rest
let me just copy these
and display it one by one
so there let's see this
and here let me say 2
and this is 3
let me copy
[Music]
this okay here i say
and then i say 3.
all right so let me save this and then
execute it
so when i refresh the page
it says one and false
after which again it says two and false
[Music]
and finally when it displays three it
returns true for the done property that
means we've reached the end of the
function definition
so this is how you make use of a
generator function
now let's move on to our last topic that
is predefined functions
now javascript has many built-in
functions all right now here are a few
of them we have eval parse end pass
float escape and unescape now let's go
through one by one
all right first up is eval now this
basically evaluates a string and returns
a value
all right so to help you understand this
better let me go back to our vs code
and now let me just create another file
and let me call it
predefined
functions.html all right
and i've just copied the initial code
all right so for eval
the syntax is eval
within which
i say
expression
all right now this is the general syntax
so what this eval does is that it
evaluates the expression
and if the result is not a string the
result is just returned and if the
result is a string it is taken to be a
javascript program and evaluated
so let me show you how it's done
so first let's create three
all right let's call them
x
and initialize it to five
then y
with six
and then let z
be seven all right
now let's just displace the result on
the console so let's say console.log
eval
of let me say
x plus y
all right
after which i again say console.log
of eval
of z
here since the expression is a string
this gets evaluated
and here since it's not a string it just
returns the value z
and here since it is not a string it
just returns the value of z
so let me save this
and then execute it
all right so let me just
check
our console
there you go it evaluated the expression
and added the two values that is x and y
and returned 11
while z is returned as it is
all right this is what eval does
next up is parseint now as the name
suggests it passes a string argument and
returns an integer of the specified
radix or base
and the syntax basically includes the
keyword parse
and the string within paranthesis
pars float on the other hand passes a
string argument and returns a floating
point number
again the syntax has the keyword parse
float along with the string within
parenthesis
next up is escape now this returns a
hexadecimal encoding of an argument
and on the other hand unescape returns
the ascii string for the specified value
we're going to learn all about
javascript form validation
so what exactly is form validation
now i'm sure you must have filled
several online forms right a simple
example would be a new registration for
a website
now every time you miss out on giving a
particular detail or end up giving
faulty information the website alerts
you
so this process of ensuring that the
information provided is legit is called
form validation
now this generally happens on the server
side however javascript facilitates form
validation on the client computer before
sending it over to the server now there
are two functions performed
one is the basic validation which
ensures that all the mandatory fields
are filled now this is implemented with
the help of a simple loop
and the other is a data format
validation now this checks the data for
its correctness
so to help you understand form
validation better let's look at a simple
demo
all right so back in my visual studio
code i've created a file called forms
alright it's an html file and i've typed
down the initial code
now the simple use case that i'm going
to show will include the validation of
the email and the password fields in a
form
all right so for that let's go ahead and
first create a simple form
so here html allows the form tag so i
say form
within which i'm going to provide
our fields so i say
input and then the name i'm going to be
providing is email
[Music]
all right and then i'll provide a
placeholder and call it
email
and then the type of the input is going
to be text
all right and then let me just give a
break tag here
so now let me just copy the same thing
for my password as well
so here we go i say
password here
and then the placeholder again will be
password
and then i'm going to keep the type as
text
and finally i'm going to have a button a
submit button right so let me say button
type
is basically submit
all right
and let me just play submit on my button
okay
so with the help of this we've created a
simple
form so let me show you how this looks
so here we go we have successfully
created an email field a password field
and a submit button and every time i
click on the submit button you can see
that my page is getting refreshed
now once the user provides the correct
email id and password we want to display
a message all right so for that i've
created another file called message.html
and this is a simple file where i'm
displaying the message hello there
welcome
all right
so this is a simple message that i want
to display
so for that i have to
add it in my form tag
now once the form gets submitted
an action has to be performed and the
action is to navigate to the
message.html file right so let me just
say action
[Music]
equals
message.html
now you can also provide a name to your
form so let me call it
my form
all right
so let me just save
this all right so moving on we have to
now validate the information that is
provided for that i'm going to create a
function here
so let me call the function
validate all right
so here i'm going to check for my fields
right
now if the email field is empty then i'm
going to alert the user saying please
enter the email
and if the password field is empty i'm
going to again alert the user to provide
the password
so for that we're going to make use of
this simple if else logic
so let me say if
document
dot my form
[Music]
dot email
dot value
is null
so i'm going to check if the value
provided on my email field in my form
is null all right
what i'm gonna do is i'm going to say
alert
please
provide
your
email id
okay
and then
i'm going to say
document.myform.email.focus
now what exactly focus does
is that it makes sure that the cursor
remains at the email field that is it is
focused at the same field
all right
so let me just copy the same thing for
my password field
so let me say else if
let me just copy this
instead of email
i say password
[Music]
within which i'm going to alert the user
to provide the password
[Music]
i'll say please provide
your password all right
so basically it first checks for the
email field and then for the password
field so let me just say finally else
do nothing
all right
okay so now what we're going to do is
every time we click on the submit button
the form gets submitted correct now we
can control when the form is getting
submitted
so basically the form gets submitted
when this function is executed
so for that we can use another property
here
called on submit
and here i'm going to call my function
that is validate so let me say validate
here
all right so let me save this and let's
check the output
so here as you can see
let me just try submitting it without
providing the email field all right so
here we go it alerts us all right and
once i click on ok
it still displays the message hello
there welcome
now that is not what we want right so
once the email field is empty it should
remain in the same page
and the form shouldn't get submitted but
here in our case it is getting submitted
so for that we're going to have to make
use of return values so what happens is
if my email field is empty then i'm
going to return a false
so here i say return false
and here as well
and finally when both my email and my
password fields are filled i'm going to
return true
all right
and same goes here
let me just say return validate instead
of just validate
right
so
here we go
let me save this
and now let's check the output so here
let's first submit the form without
providing any information
all right so it says please provide your
email id when i click on ok observe that
the cursor remains at the email field
so here let me just give some random
value
and then let's try submitting it again
without providing the password
and then it says please provide your
password
all right
okay now if you observe that the cursor
is remains at the email field so let me
just check my code once
here we go i haven't mentioned password
here
so let me change email to password
so let me just provide some random value
at my email field
and say submit
and then i get a message saying please
provide your password
and now you can see that the cursor is
at the password field right so let me
just give random information there
and then i say submit
and here we go
the message hello there welcome is
displayed
so this was a simple demo on form
validation
so i really suggest you pause the video
here and then go through the code once
we're going to learn all about
javascript regular expressions
so now without further delay let's begin
so what exactly are regular expressions
now a regular expression is basically a
sequence of characters now these
characters could be digits or the
letters of the alphabet and this
expression usually searches for a
particular pattern
now the user can basically define what
has to be searched in a text all right
and these expressions could be alphabet
or digits as i explained before
also one of the main reasons that we use
regular expressions is for text search
and text replacement operations
so this is a general syntax you have a
pattern that needs to be checked and you
have a flag associated with it so
further on in the video i'll explain to
you what flags and patterns are but
before that let me give you a small
example of what a regular expression is
so i have made use of this website
called regexar.com i'll link it down in
the description box below
so this is the website now here let me
just show you a simple regular
expression now say we have a text that
says
apple
all right and now we have to search for
the letter a so what i do here now this
is going to be my expression so i first
provide a pattern right so i just say
capital a
so when i say capital a you can see that
the letter a has been matched
in my text all right so it's as simple
as that now one thing to remember is
that here it is case sensitive
all right so if i say a regular small a
it does not get matched
all right so if i want to match ap i can
just say ap and it gets highlighted here
all right so this is a simple regular
expression that matches with the text
so moving on
let's see what exactly these flags
patterns and quantifiers are
so what exactly is a flag so we
previously saw that the syntax consists
of a pattern and then a flag right so
these flags basically specify to alter
the behavior of a regular expression now
these flags are generally appended after
the red x literal and can be specified
as a second argument in your expression
right so let's see the different flags
that are supported by javascript
now you have these five flags here you
have g which is the global flag
now this finds all matches instead of
stopping after the first
all right then you have i which is
ignore case which makes the entire
expression case insensitive and then you
have m which is multi-line
so the carrot and the dollar match the
beginning and the end of each line
respectively
then you have unicode and if this flag
is not supported you must match specific
unicode characters and then finally you
have y which finds all the consecutive
or adjacent matches
so moving on we have
patterns now these patterns are
basically brackets and are used to find
the range of characters
now again we have these patterns we have
a to z which finds all the characters
from a to z in lower cases only then we
have 0 to 9 which finds all the digits
between 0 to 9 and finally we have the
letters of the alphabet and the digits
separated by a pipe all right so this
basically finds any character be it an
alphabet or a digit
i hope this was clear to you so moving
on we have quantifiers now these
quantifiers define the number of
occurrences of a particular string
now consider n to be a string so we have
three quantifiers here we have the plus
we have the asterisk and we have the
question mark so plus indicates one or
more occurrence of the character n
all right and the asterisk indicates
zero or more occurrences of the
character end while a question mark
indicates zero or one occurrence of the
character n
so now that you know flags patterns and
quantifiers let me help you understand
them better with the help of a demo
alright so here i have a simple text
which says welcome to this tutorial on
javascript this video teaches regular
expressions
now here
when i search for a particular word see
let me search for the word this okay
so i say this
now ideally even this has to be
highlighted
right however it does not that is
because as mentioned earlier it is
extremely case sensitive right so what
we can do is here we have flags
so here i say case insensitive so once i
click on that both these words get
highlighted
all right so this is how you make use of
the i flag
now moving on let me help you understand
patterns
now as mentioned you can have a range of
characters
now just in case here
say i just make it case sensitive again
and here
i would like to select all the letters
of the alphabet
from a to z
all right so when i do that you can
observe all the letters are highlighted
except the ones that are in the upper
case
correct because that is not mentioned
here
so here when i make it insensitive you
can see all of them get highlighted
so this is how you can make use of a
pattern
now to understand quantifiers
let me use a separate text all right
let's have a couple of a's and a few b's
now here when i say a
you can see all the characters a are
being highlighted right which is correct
but when i use the asterix
symbol here what happens is you can
observe
all the four a's are considered to be a
single unit what aztecs does is that you
can see here it says match is 0 or more
of the preceding token now the preceding
token is a and matches 0 or more
occurrences of the character a
now same if i say b next to it
you can see all the characters b are
matched
right
however you can check
the characters a in this particular text
are not highlighted
i'm sure you can understand why because
the expression that i'm looking for is
any occurrences of a followed by the
character b
in this text here there are no
characters a and b together correct so
here you can see that a is not
highlighted
but once i give an asterisk again
what happens is that the character a
gets highlighted
what happens is that b can have zero or
more occurrences so here there is a zero
occurrence of b so a gets highlighted so
this is how
gas does quantifier works
now one of the most important concepts
of using regular expressions
are the special characters
so here you're gonna indicate the
special characters with the backslash
so we have backslash w for example
now what w does is that it matches any
word character right so all the
characters here get matched
now it also has a counter character
which is the capital w all right so what
this does is that it does not match any
word so it matches everything that is
not a word including the periods
now let's see if you want to match
all the white spaces you can make use of
the character
s here
all right and when you have the
uppercase s
it matches any character that is not a
white space
now let's say you want to match
a digit you can just have backslash d
so let me just type in a few digits
and here you go all of them get matched
now let's say you want to have a range
of values that get matched right now
let's say i want to match just
three digits
so i can make use of curly braces and
within which i can mention three now
here you can see that it matches three
of the preceding token correct so the
preceding token is basically a digit so
it groups them in threes
so let me just add two other digits and
there we go
same goes with the matching of words so
here let me say w
so when i say three all the characters
are grouped in threes all right
now let's say i want to group the words
that are three or four in number so here
i can just say
comma four
all right now it gets matched
all right so now it gets grouped in
force
so this is a simple example to show you
how special characters work in a regular
expression
moving on let's see how you can use
regular expressions to search for phone
numbers
now here in my phone number
i'm going to have an area code
so let's say
080 followed by a neat digit number all
right so let me give a random number
[Music]
all right so it's eight digits so some
people write a phone number like this
while others could write it something
like this you could have a hyphen in
between and then
an eight digit number all right now how
are you going to look for this text
so what we're going to do is we're going
to make use of the special character
that is for a digit
we'll make use of hyphen d
and first we're going to look for
the area code that is a three digit
number right so let me just say
three here
and next we're going to have an optional
hyphen so for that now since we learnt a
pattern can be enclosed within square
brackets so let me just
say hyphen here
and let me say a question mark now a
question mark indicates zero or one
occurrence of the preceding character
right so we're going to have a hyphen
for a question mark
and then finally we're going to have a
digit again
and here the number of digits is 8. so
let me just specify that
all right so when this happens you can
see both my numbers are getting
highlighted
although the text remains the same it
could be specified with different
formats right so just like this you can
create expressions that match various
formats so this was just a simple video
to acquaint you with regular expressions
react.js is a widely used front-end
development library let's go ahead and
begin with what is react react is a
javascript library used to build fast
and interactive user interfaces for both
web and mobile applications now one
thing that makes react extremely
powerful is the fact that it's open
source any user can access its source
code modify it and enhance it in a
typical model view controller
architecture react defines the view part
of the application it is also
responsible for how the app looks and
feels fun fact react was built by jordan
walkey an engineer at facebook now let's
go ahead and see how react works in real
time consider a typical web application
say instagram the entire ui of the web
page is divided into several components
we have the search component a profile
description component stories component
and a post-list component these
components make the code easier to debug
and always remain discrete components
also make development and maintenance of
web applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and one
way data binding we'll learn about these
topics a little later in the video react
uses reusable components now this helps
decrease the development time react
involves unidirectional flow of data
react also has a small learning curve
compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual dom with the virtual dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
dom as discussed earlier virtual dog
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
javascript and a familiarity with html
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the it industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the united states is a whopping 91 000
us dollars the average salary for a
react developer in india is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by google trends
react has had a better growth scale
compared to other frameworks like
angular and vue statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
forgoing other available options if you
are skilled and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally we have
facebook instagram netflix dropbox
whatsapp among others
in this video we'll be learning all
about react installation on windows to
set up the react development environment
we need two things installed node and a
text editor of your choice so let's
begin by installing node.js we can head
to the official node.js website save
download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so i'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system i'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
i'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder
i'm creating it on my desktop while you
can create it in any of your drives
let's call it
first
react now open your command prompt now
you can type in the path for the folder
that you just created so say
cd
[Music]
users
first yeah now go ahead and type in the
command npm
install
hyphen g create
react
app okay so this command installs all
the necessary react.js modules now to
check if the version is correctly
installed you can type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create
react app
and you can give a name to your
application so i say my app
now this should take a couple of minutes
okay once you've successfully created an
application
they say to begin by typing the
following commands so let's do that save
cd
my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go
all right you can also open your
application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file
open folder go to your desktop or the
drive that you've saved your folder in
first react
my app and i say select folder so as you
can see all your modules have been
imported you can click on app.js and
start editing in this video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js called
components so we'll be touching on
topics like what are components types of
components nesting components higher
order in pure components and a brief
description about component life cycle
all right to begin with what exactly are
components components are the building
blocks of a react application wherein
each component represents a part of the
user interface now to make it more
understandable consider the facebook
home page the entire ui can be broken
down into several elements say we have
the credentials component the signup
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks alright reusability is one of
the salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application and this
improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working hands-on so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical javascript functions that return
html now they can be contained in a dot
js or a dot jsx file coming to class
components these are regular es6 classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
html they can also be contained in dot
jx or jsx file okay then let's go ahead
and build our first react application
using components alright so i've opened
my text editor that is vs code to build
my application also i suggest you watch
the react installation on windows video
to help you get started the video
briefly explains how to install node and
how to start building your first react
application in my case i've opened a
folder called react component tutorial
and here in my source folder i have
app.js now app.js is the main component
that gets rendered to the dom let me
show you that here in index.js you pass
app.js which is a component that gets
rendered to the react dom so app.js
consists of several other components
that can be nested so as you can see
app.js is a functional component and
before moving on let me get rid of all
the unnecessary code so let me delete
all of this
and return
an h1 tag that says hello welcome to
sibling let me save it and if you look
at the browser you'll have hello welcome
to simply learn now let's go ahead and
display another message say h1
this
video is about
components let me save it and let me
check the browser it gives you an error
so jsx uses a conventional rule which
states that all html tags have to be
enclosed within a div tag so for example
i say div and i enclose it so let me
save and check my browser again here you
go so multiple html tags have to be
enclosed within the div tag moving on
let's create a first functional
component to do that i'll first create a
folder in my source folder say
components within that i'll create a
file say functional component dot js all
right so the first thing we have to do
is import react so i say import react
from
yeah the general syntax for a functional
component involves the keyword function
and say
functional
component now you say return an h1 tag
or i've already used h1 tags so i'll say
paragraph and i say
this is
a functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general syntax for a class
component so i create another file say
class component dot js i again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class react.component
so going ahead i say class class
component extends react dot
component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so i say render
within braces i say return a paragraph
tag saying this is
the class component all right so moving
on let's see how these components can be
nested into the main component that is
app.js components can be nested into the
main component using import and export
keywords so as the name suggests export
features used to export a particular
file or a module and import is used to
import a particular file or module into
the current existing module so we have
two different types of exports you have
default export and just export or named
export so a default export is used to
export just one object be it a function
a class a variable from the file and
there can only be one default export
profile and when you're importing it you
can specify the address and use the word
import before it so let me show you how
it works let's go back to our editor and
then functional component and here i say
export default and the name of the
functional component that is
functional com so let me save this and
going back to my app.js i say import
name of the functional component that is
functional com from and i pass the path
this components slash functional
component also let me get rid of these
unnecessary
files here now let's define functional
component in our app.js component so
here i say functional com let's compile
it and check our browser here it says
this is a functional component moving on
to my class component it's the same
syntax here as well i say export default
name of my component and in my app.js i
import it
import class comp from
the path and again i'll have to define
it in my return method i say so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that i can
rename the file while i'm importing it
so for example i can rename it as say
fc and while i'm defining it i'll have
to make sure i use the same naming
conventions so i say fc again and when i
check it it says this is the functional
component there is literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so i'll
just copy paste this
let me give it another name say class
com1 and the message that i want to
display is hey i'm another class all
right so when i'm exporting it i don't
want default so let me take it off and
say export here all right in my app.js
while importing it i want to import both
the classes so i'll include them within
curly braces here i say class com comma
class comp one and then again i define
it here class comp one let's compile it
and run it and here we go here you can
see hey i'm another class so we've
successfully exported both the classes
from the class component and imported it
back in our app.js component one
advantage of using named export is the
fact that i can choose to import the
classes that i want to now say for
example i do not want to import class
component here so let me take it off and
here let me
comment this now let's compile and see
hey am another class the second class
got imported while the first class that
was defined earlier is not imported here
all right so next up we have higher
order and pure competence now i won't
get into the nativities of it because
they're advanced topics but to give you
a brief insight higher order components
are basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click
dot js all right so here we define a
class i use this benefit rce here we go
we get the entire format using the small
snippet rce and here i'm going to make
use of a button now say i use the tag
button and i'll say
clicked
one time every time the user clicks on
the button the value gets incremented so
for this i'm going to use a variable say
count and i'm going to use the concept
of states so let's go ahead and define
our variable count and initialize it to
0. so for that i'm going to use another
snippet called r const and here this dot
state equals my variable count
initializing it to zero so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
i say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click equals this
dot
update click
now update click is going to be another
method that we have to define now so
every time the button gets clicked this
method is called so let's go ahead and
define the function so it is update
click equals it's going to be an arrow
function and i say
this dot set state is nothing but count
this dot
state dot account plus one okay and here
we save
count times all right so once this is
done let's import our component in
app.js so here again
i say import click from components click
and let's define it here so let's check
our browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that i say
counter dot js i'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag i
define a button and say incremented
to for now i say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event say button
on
mouse
enter
i'm going to call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and define the
increment count method i'm going to copy
the same code that i've mentioned in my
click.js so i say copy this all right so
one change is that i change the name of
the method and
call it increment count again let's
define the count in our render method so
i say const count equals
this dot
state and here i change x to
com now let's go ahead and import it in
our app.js
so i say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time i
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you i'm not clicking i'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our hoc
let's call it
higher order dot js okay so i say import
react
from via after that i say const updated
component equals
original component
that's going to be an arrow function
again and within curly braces i define
my class that is class say new component
extends
react
dot component inside let's define a
render method
that returns the original component with
a modification that is i want to type
the user i want to append the user
before the actual message is displayed
all right so let's go ahead and close
the tag and return new component and
let's export this say export
default updated component
now we import higherorder.js in our
counter.js and click.js and pass these
components as parameters so let's do
that let's go to our counter.js and here
i say import
updated component
from
dot slash higher order component and
here while exporting i say updated comp
and pass this as my parameter let's do
the same to click.js here i import
data.com from higher order component and
here i pass this as a parameter now here
in a higher order component we've
defined a property name and initialized
it to the user so we'll have to include
this in our other components that's
counter and click so let's do that and
here right before incremented 2 i say
this dot
props dot name let me save it let me do
the same thing here and say
this dot props dot name so if you go
back to our browser here you can see it
says the user clicked zero times and the
user incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react a
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you'll learn about
this method a little later in the video
now this method enables re-rendering of
components to the dom but a pure
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component now using
this example i'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a
purecomponent.js file i say purecom
dot js so here i'm going to use a
snippet rpce that is going to create a
pure component class let me get rid of
this export and here in my div tag i'll
display the text say i'm
the pure component all right now let's
go ahead and create a regular component
let me call it
regular component.js and here i'm going
to use the snippet rce and the message
that i want to display is
i'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pure component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here i'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here i
display the message i am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
constructor so let's use the snippet our
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and i say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead i'm going to make use of the
method and say component
did mount and here i say set interval
the first argument is going to be an
arrow function and the second will be
the time interval and i'm going to be
setting it to 3 seconds now within the
arrow function i'll make use of the set
state function to set the state of my
property however i do not change the
name i keep it simply done itself moving
on let's import pure component and the
regular component into our parent
component and then pass name as a
property so to do that first import
pure comp
from your component and then i say
import
regular comp from regular com.js and
here let's say regular comp name equals
this dot state dot
name and i say pure component name
equals this
dot state dot me now let's include the
property name in both our regular and
pure components so to do that let's just
say this dot
drop dot name and here i again say this
dot drop dot name and finally let's
import parent component into our app.js
component so here i say import parent
com from okay and here let me define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have i'm the parent and regular
component simply learn and i'm the pure
component simply done we've got the
result as expected now to check if the
pure component is actually read entering
or not let's include simple console.log
statements so here i say clg snippet and
here i say
pure component
render and in my regular component i do
the same thing i say console.log regular
component
render now let's do the same in our
parent component as well here
parent
component render all right so let's go
back to our browser and inspect it in
our console first the parent component
gets rendered then the regular component
and then the pure component after that
for every three seconds only the parent
component and the regular component is
rendered for the same state and prop the
pure component is not re-rendered so in
conclusion pure components optimize
react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
comprehend life cycle explains the
stages the component goes through the
entire life cycle of a component can be
divided into three parts we have
mounting updation and unmounting so the
first thing that gets invoked in the
life cycle is component will mount it is
invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once the component
is inserted into the dom component did
mount gets invoked coming to the next
phase we have updation when a complaint
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked set state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component state
should trigger a re-render or not to do
that should component update method is
called component will update is invoked
right before re-rendering after
re-rendering component did update is
called that makes updates to the dom and
the last phase is unmounted component
will unmount method does all the
necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and cycles moving ahead
let's learn about another striking
feature of react.js called props props
short for properties allow the user to
pass arguments or data to components a
pairing component can pass additional
information to its children using props
properties help make components more
dynamic props are passed to components
in the way similar to that of html track
attributes now we'll look at this a
little later in the video props in a
component are read only and cannot be
changed one thing to remember is that
props are sent by the parent to the
children components hence the children
components cannot make any changes to
these props now that we've learnt about
props in brief let's go ahead and create
our application using props if you're
new to this tutorial i suggest you go to
the react installation and react
components video on our channel so back
in my code editor that is vs code i've
opened a folder called react props
and now i'm going to create a component
a class component and i'll call it class
props dot js so let's create the class
component i give rce the snippet
and here i display a message saying an
h1 tag basically
[Music]
all right
now let me get rid of export here and
import it in my app.js main component
here i say import
class props
all right now we define the class
component in our render method
let's say
all right
now if we go back to the browser you see
hello learners welcome to simply
learning now let's say we want to
individually welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props now let's see how to do that now
we pass the name as a property from the
main component that is app.js to the
child component and render this onto the
browser so let's do that so here
while i'm defining my child component i
say name
i save it and here in my child component
instead of learners
i say i use the keyword this
dot props
dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner one
welcome to simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner two and
learner three so i again say class props
name
equals
learner two
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want to
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome learner1 from
place x so i can here
define another property say place
[Music]
and say place
similarly i can do it for the rest too
say place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component and here say hello
one
from
this dot props
dot
place
let me save it and if you look at the
browser now we have hello learner one
from place x place y and place z we can
also display whatever we want between
the opening and closing tags when
invoking a component now this is
facilitated using props dot children
reserved keyword now let me explain to
you how it's done with an example here
let's split the self and closing tag
into
an opening and a closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag let me say
and in my
child component
after my h1 tag
let me use a paragraph tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
props dot children
[Music]
so let's save it
and now if you look at the browser you
can here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialog that represent generic boxes
so let's go ahead and create a button
tag and check again
so here
i'll split it and add a button tag
and say click
and let's check our browser
here we go
we get the output as expected all right
we saw the usage of props for class
components similarly we can use it for
functional components so let's go ahead
and create a functional component let me
call it
i say import
react from
react
and then i say function
function props
and here i return
an h3 tag
i'll say this is
functional component
and i'll return another hc tag saying
hello learner
so let me save this
and let's export it
export
default
function
props
and import it
in our app.js again
import
function prop from
function prop
and here in our render method
let's define it
let me call
function prop
name
let me give learner 4
and
place
place say a
let me close it
and back in a functional component
instead of learner
i say
props dot
name
let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says props is not defined
so let's go back to our code editor and
pass props here
to our functional component also let me
define hello props dot name
from
props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go we get the output as
expected let's begin and learn what
exactly is a state in react typically a
state is an object that stores the
values of properties belonging to a
component now these values can change
over a period of time either via user
interactions or network changes and the
state helps facilitate this
functionality every time the state
changes react re-renders the component
to the browser the state is initialized
in the constructor a state can also
store multiple properties a method
called set state is used to update the
value of the state object now this
function performs a shallow merge on the
new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learnt about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props in a component are
used to pass data and event handlers to
its children while state on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the web page props are
immutable once set by the parent they
cannot be changed state holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learned all about state let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of state all right so in my
code editor that is vs code i've created
my application say state and here in my
source folder i have my app.js file now
here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that i'm not going to
be using also i suggest you go through
the react installation on windows video
to help you get started with creating
your first application so let's create
our class component say class app
extends react dot component and inside i
have a render method that returns an
html tag let's display a message welcome
let's follow the jsx conventions and
enclose all the html tags within the div
tag so i say
div
class name equals app we also have to
import the app.css file import
app dot css
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome now let's
beautify our code to do that let's add
some styling so here in my app.js class
component i say styles
equals
and i say font
style and i set it to say bold and i say
color
say teal and here in my h1 tag i say
style equals
this
dot
styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold now let's go ahead
and create a class component to
understand state so first i create a
folder and i call it components and
inside this folder i create a class
component and i call it new comp dot js
and i use the snippet rce to create the
class component to give you an insight
into what we're doing today we'll
display a message asking the user to
subscribe to simply learn once the user
clicks on the subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we are
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state object in a constructor so let's
use the snippet r const to create a
constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this
dot
state
dot message let's save it and now let's
import it in our app.js component so
i'll get rid of export here and here i
say
import new com from components and new
comp and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says subscribe to simply
learn all right again to make our code
look more presentable let's add in
styles so i'll just copy the same styles
that i've added here and i'll paste them
here and instead of bold i make it
italic
and i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag i define
style
and initialize it to distort styles so
let me save it and now if you look at
the browser it's in italic and it's in
purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe and once the
user clicks on it the button should read
subscribed and the message displayed
above should instruct the user to click
on the bell icon to do that let's first
create a button the message that i want
the button to read is subscribe however
this message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here i
create a prop i say sub
and i say subscribe here and back in my
render method i say this dot state dot
sub so let's save it and if you look at
the browser now you have a button which
displays a message subscribe now once
the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call another method
and let's call the method button change
okay so this method should update the
state and change the message and sub
values to do that we make use of a set
state method now a state can be updated
in response to event handlers server
responses or prop changes now all the
updation can be done using the set state
method now this is the general syntax
used by the method we'll have a look at
this further in the demo now the set
state method conventionally enqueues all
the updates made to the component state
and instructs react to re-render the
component and its children with the
updated state now let's go back to our
code editor and look at the working of
this method now here i defined the arrow
function button change if you are not
familiar with arrow functions i suggest
you read up on them and this is the
general syntax and here i say this dot
set state and inside i change my message
to hit the bell icon
to never
miss an update and my sub value changes
to subscribed
let's save this and now if you look at
the browser when we click on the
subscribe button the message changes to
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update so moving ahead let's use a bell
icon so that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen so for that i have two
images i have bell a and bell b so i
drag and drop both the images in my
components folder all right
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file
here i say import bell a
from
bell a dot png
and again i say import bell b
from
bell b
dot png all right let me save it to
display the image on the screen we make
use of the image tag now this tag has
two attributes one is the source
attribute that specifies the url and the
other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image so here in my component i say i
make use of a paragraph tag that will
help display the image in the next line
and then i use the image tag now since
my image changes once it's clicked i
have to define a property and pass the
event handler click that will update the
image so here
before specifying the source let's go
back to our state and define another
property
that is image url and let's set it to
bell a since that is the image that i
want to display first let me save it and
here in my image tag i say source equals
this dot state
dot image url and then we have the alt
tag and i do not want to display any
message so i leave it as it is now let's
save it and if you look at the browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell so back
in my vs code i define style with width
say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this and now if you look at the
browser we have a smaller icon so once
the user clicks on this image the emit
changes and the message displayed here
gets updated to do that we'll have to
define an event so let's go back to our
vs code and here in my image tag let's
say on click i define a method say this
dot
image change and now we define this
method here i see image change i make
use of an arrow function again
and again i use the set state method i
update the image so i say image url is
now set to bell
b and the message
is updated to thank you
happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser we see the image and once
clicked on it the image gets updated and
the message changes so finally let me
refresh the browser once and show the
full execution let me refresh following
the instructions let's click on the
subscribe button and now it says hit the
bell icon and once i do that the image
updates and the message changes in this
session we're going to cover the topic
of what is angular
i am sure all of you use mobile and web
applications be it from social media to
health care e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe now the main
reason we use these apps is that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface
but how are they developed to provide
such reliability one of the frameworks
that is widely used to build such robust
apps is angular so let's dive into the
session now
so here is a list of topics that we're
going to be covering
first up we'll see why angular was
introduced
then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture
advantages and limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we look at some of the companies
that deploy angular so without further
delay let's begin
why angular now javascript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into html
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such things
with respect to front-end development
angular and javascript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications
and also provide scalability and
maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework written completely in
typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for developers it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing
we have the document object model type
script data binding and testing now
let's look at them one by one now the
document object model treats an xml or
an html document as a tree structure
now here every node in the tree
structure defines an object representing
a part of your document
angular uses the regular dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single html page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding dom or the tree structure
needs to be updated
now angular updates the entire tree
structure of html tags
moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
javascript which helps you write
javascript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic javascript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not mandatory for developing an
angular application but it is highly
recommended the main reason is highly
recommended is that it offers better
syntactic structure while making the
code base easier to understand and
maintain now typescript can be installed
as an npm package now to do that you
just have to run the command npm install
hyphen g type script on your command
prompt next up is data binding now data
binding is a process that allows you to
manipulate web page elements using the
web browser now it mainly employs
dynamic html and does not require
complex scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials games etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes needing the ui element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state
are reflected onto the ui state
this allows the framework to connect the
dom to the model data via the controller
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses jasmine to run its various
tests the jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases
karma is a task runner for the tests
that use a configuration file to set the
startup reporters and testing framework
so with that we've covered the features
of angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates the real dom mvc short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic
view on the other hand is used for ui
logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components that can pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data from
your javascript code to the view and
react to user events without having to
write any code yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the same don't worry
if you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind
you can literally test every part of
your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out-of-the-box
solutions for server communication
routing and more
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross platform
and browser compatible
an angular application can typically run
on all browsers beat chrome firefox
safari and platforms like windows mac os
and linux now many versions of angular
have been released ever since its
inception all of these versions have
added to the efficient working of the
framework now here are two different
versions released first up was angular
1. it was built on javascript and
completely based on controllers next
release was angular 2. now this
incorporated the component based
approach wherein the entire ui was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic
next was angular 4 it included router
updation angular cli or command line
interface 1.0 was introduced however not
deployed in this release the angular cli
was optimized and commands like ng
update and ng add were added
in the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced which provided tips in cli
about the functions being used
in angular 8 iv renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the iv renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learnt about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
first up is a sleep learning curve now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
learners to begin with
you need to be acquainted with simple
topics and then move on to more advanced
topics to become proficient in this
language
next up is limited seo options
now angular offers limited seo options
and poor accessibility to search engine
crawlers
it's verbose and complex now a common
issue faced by the angular community is
the verbosity of the framework
it also poses to be complex compared to
other front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult to port legacy
code to angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
backward compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular some of them are directives
modules decorators
components services dependency injection
pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js
however the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut
in the beginning it could be a little
intimidating but once you start using
the tool it becomes way more easier to
comprehend and understand what is going
on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like nike forbes
google hbo sony upwork among others
readily deploy angular so moving on
let's look at the prerequisites for
angular
first up we have nodejs angular uses
nodejs as its base for a large part of
its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have nodejs
installed on your environment so head to
your official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system
next up is the angular cli now this
command line interface is a tool that
makes it easier to bootstrap and develop
your angular applications now to install
the latest version run the command npm
install hyphen g
at angular
front cli you got to run this command on
your command prompt
and finally to confirm installation
check for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an ide or a text editor to type your
code now there are several ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites i think you're ready to
create your first angular application so
let's head to our vs code and begin here
i've created a folder called angular on
my desktop and opened it on my visual
studio code so to create your app you
need to open the terminal just go here
and
select new terminal
and now type in the command
ng
new
and provide the name for your app so i'm
just going to say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
hello world in our case
and it includes a bunch of files and
installs all the necessary dependencies
for the angular application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say cd
hello world
and now use the command ng serve
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200
and once you do that you can see your ui
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser
and it says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but i'll rush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts
now this is the part of the
bootstrapping piece all right so the
index.html file is responsible for
deciding which files are to be loaded
correct the main.ts file on the other
hand identifies which angular module is
to be loaded when the application starts
so this is just a brief explanation as
to what they are doing
next we have the app folder
now here we have the
app.module.ts file
now this application module file can be
thought of as the code configuration of
your application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts
these are all typescript files hence the
extension ts now this file basically is
a root component of your application
and then we have the html file for the
same which defines the appearance of
what you can see on your browser so let
me just change the message that is being
displayed
so i'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this
and when we go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first
we'll get acquainted to what exactly
angular components are
then i'll help you create an angular
component by showing a quick demo and
lastly we'll learn about component
decorator metadata but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our channel if
you love watching new and interesting
technology videos also hit the bell icon
to never miss an update so what exactly
are angular components
now i'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application
so in this case here we have the logo
component then you have a sign in
component an image component and then a
create account component now all of
these components generally don't affect
the working of each other but however
when embedded they define the ui of your
application
so i hope you understood what components
are
so to go ahead let's discuss some of its
common features now firstly they are the
building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
detectives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template
now components are typically custom html
elements and each of these elements can
instantiate only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when i show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator now the decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the ng module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks
so this was just a brief introduction to
what angular components are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when i show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a visual studio code
now here back in my vs code i've created
a folder called angulardemo within which
i've created an angular application
called demo components once executed the
browser looks something like this
so if you haven't watched our previous
video on getting started with angular
that is angular hello world i highly
suggest you go through that video first
it helps you create your first angular
application so um
now let's go ahead and create our first
component
now the command used to create our
component is ng gc and your component
name
once executed it creates four different
files now let's just see how this works
on rvs code now what you can do is head
to your terminal and type in the command
ng
[Music]
g
c
and provide a name for your component
for example i'm gonna just call my
component text component
all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts indicating that
this new component has been created
so here in your source folder
within which there's an app folder
and again here you can see that your
four different files have been created
first is the html file where you can
define all the code that you want for
your component next you have the css
file for your styling
then you have the dot ts file which
includes the component decorator and
finally you have spec.ts which is
basically a unit test file all right and
then in your app.module.ts
you can observe that the component that
you've created that is text component
has been imported that is what the
message conveys here all right now let's
go back to our app.component.org
now this basically has all the code for
your application so let me just get rid
of it
and i'm just gonna
display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome
all right so let me save it
and if you go ahead and look at your
browser
hello welcome message is displayed now
let's go back to our component
dot html file
and here
let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
and let me display a message
saying welcome to this tutorial
on angular components
all right
now in your text component dot ts file
which is your typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component now go ahead and
copy this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom html tag
with the selector that you just copied
now this indicates that the component
that you just created that is the text
component is being incorporated in the
final render so what happens is that
whatever is defined in the
component.html file is also being
rendered in your final output so when i
save this
let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed so this was a
simple creation of a component now for
this let's give it some styling
so here go to your dot css file and
provide some styling say for example
here i just say
text line
and let me say center and also in my
app.component.cs i'm going to give the
same thing and say each one
text align
is center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and define the tags in the
app component
now the components are executed
sequentially
so now let's create another component
just to give you a brief insight into it
let's say nggc
image component
now here i'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so i'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here i've added the
logo
so what i can do is back in my html file
i can go ahead and create an image tag
so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
[Music]
and then
let me say
image
source
equals
so the source is basically assets
slash
logo
dot png
and class
equals
center
all right so you can also head to your
css file and provide any sort of styling
that you need
so let me just say
text
align
to be center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here i mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this
and from the dot cs file
let's copy the selector
and create a custom html tag in our
final component.html file
so there we go
let's save this and check the output
and there we go first the hello welcome
message is displayed
next you have the message displayed from
the first component and then you have
the second component so this is how you
can create
your own components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final html file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as mentioned
earlier the at component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object first up is the
selector now basically the selector is a
css selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the html tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own html tag however the
same has to be included in the parent
component so to help you understand that
better let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here
the selector says text component
correct for the time being let's change
it to say n component
[Music]
all right now when you save it and look
at the browser
the message is not displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector
and then include this
here
and now you can see
that the same component has been
rendered onto your output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template
now a template is an inline defined
template for the view now the template
can be used to provide some particular
markup the markup could typically
include some headings or paragraphs that
are displayed on the ui
next up we have template url now it is
the url for the external file containing
the template for the view
so here you can see this is basically
the external file that contains the
template for the view
next up you have styles now these are
also inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view so any
code that you provide in the dot css
file can also be included here
next you have the style urls now this is
a list of urls to your style sheets that
are applied on your components view
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern and
finally i'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this i'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components the entire ui of the
application is divided into several
components
now what if all of these components
perform similar tasks be it accessing
the database rendering images etc now
instead of writing the same piece of
code for every component you could write
the code once and then perhaps inject
the same code into every component
now this is supported by dependency
injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes a and b
now let's assume that a uses the objects
of class b
and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of class b is
created so that a can access its objects
with using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the code more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own and lastly di benefits
directives pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider class postal details
that is dependent on the number and the
address class
in the postal details class the
constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class the constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code let's assume that
the number and address class
constructors now accept parameters
when we change the numbers class the
postal details class gets broken
now to overcome this what we need to do
is we need to pass parameter to the
number constructor so this applies to
address as well
the first drawback of using this
traditional method is that the code is
not very flexible
anytime the dependencies change the
postal details class needs to be changed
as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependencies from an external source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the constructor to the
constructor's parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules components all
of these are benefactors of dependency
injection so in the demo i'm going to be
showing how dependency injection can be
used with the help of services and
injecting these services into classes
so the main
thought behind this is
normally components are used to ensure
just a good user experience
these components do not generally
execute tasks so to
execute these tasks we make use of
services so a component can delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
any network related issues etc to a
particular service and these services
can be made available to components
with the same thought what i'm going to
be doing is i'll be creating a service
that performs the task of displaying an
employee list
later we're going to inject this service
into the class using dependency
injection
so let's head to our visual studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed i'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then i have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee id email id etc
so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
nggc
and the name of the component i'm
providing is amp
info
all right so as you can see here in my
app folder i have the component
with four different files
all right so the next thing we have to
do is we have to create a service so to
create that we make use of the command
ng g
s
you can either give s or service and the
service name i'm providing is records
so let me just say
records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spec.ts file and the
dot ts file
all right so now the service contains
all the employee data that needs to be
displayed right so let's go ahead and
write the data so first we're going to
make use of three arrays i'm going to be
displaying employee records for three
employees so i'll have to create three
arrays and provide certain information
so let's go ahead and do that
all right so the area i'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and i'm going to be
passing
information like name employee id and
the email id so the arrays of type
string
and within which let me just mention the
details i'm giving random information
i'm just saying adam taylor
and some random
employee id
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so i'm going to be creating
three records so i'll just copy the same
thing and paste for the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and
let me change the name of the area as
well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
i'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot in four one
all right i'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
i'm just going to return different
arrays here
all right and lastly info 3 all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays that will receive this data let's
go back to our component dot ts file
here and then type in the following code
so i've created three arrays again or
info received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct
now as
i mentioned services are implemented
with the help of dependency injection so
what we need to do is we'll have to
first import the service into the
file
the key reason behind doing this is that
when angular creates this component an
instance of the service class is also
made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so i'll say import
[Music]
records
services
i'm sorry service
from
and let's say records dot service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the providers
area of the component
all right
so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class
right however to access this instance an
object is also created
so this object will in turn access the
methods and variables of the service
class
so for that we have to create another
object so let's do that here in our
constructor method
let's say constructor
private
and the object i'm creating is called
our service you can give a name
of your choice
and then i'm going to just say records
service all right now this
object will help me retrieve data from
the service so let's go ahead and use
this in order to get the employee
details
all right i've created three different
methods here get info from service class
2 1 and 3 and these methods will
retrieve the data and add it to our
array here that is info received all
right
and lastly
we'll have to create an unordered list
in our html file here we haven't added
anything so let me get rid of this
so now i have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the ui
right
so as you can see i've created buttons
for three different employees
and then i've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info
and then i've
interpolated
info which displays the contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot ts
file we have to bind them with the
button
so since it is bound with the click
event every time you click on the button
the information is
displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom html tag
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that
let me copy
this here
and then in my
appcomponent.html let me get rid of this
and then let me just create this
i've just created the custom html tag
for my component
and now just to beautify the code i'll
write a heading
and let's say
employee
details
and then i'll also add the simply learn
logo
say image source
[Music]
i've added the image here so let me just
say logo
dot png
i've also added some styling to it
all right so now let me just save this
and have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when i click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the id and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
we'll understand what angular forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control and group
control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now i'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application
you need forms to update your profile or
to enter sensitive information or also
to perform any sort of data related
tasks so now let's look at the different
types of form building supported by
angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one
so talking about template driven
approach in this method the conventional
form tag is used to create forms
so angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object with the help of
the directives
now controls can be added to the form
using the ng model tag
now multiple controls can be grouped
using the ng control group module so it
basically uses several module classes to
provide controls
now if you don't get this don't worry
you'll understand better when i am
showing you the demo
next up is json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic html validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to reactive approach now
this approach is the programming
paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the anti
pattern of updating the data model via
two-way data binding
so it does not use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location now a
form control is basically a class that
enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
now these instances help check the
values of the field and see if they're
either touched untouched dirty pristine
valid invalid and so on so this allows
you to check every field for the value
it makes it easier to understand which
field's value is invalid or which field
has not been entered etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls
a form can have multiple group controls
the form group returns true if all the
controls are valid and provides
validation errors if there are any so i
hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features i'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo
so for that let's head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
i've created a component called form
component
and
i've also included the simply learn logo
just to beautify the appearance so once
you execute the code
this is what you're going to see on your
browser
so you just have the logo at the moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to
import the forms module all right
so oh uh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is so we're going
to be creating a user registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last name email
id and a password
all right so now let me show you how to
import the forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file
you will have to import forms module
from angular forms
all right and then in your imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that let's
go ahead and
start our form creation
so here in my component.html
let's enclose the entire form within a
div tag so here
let me say div
class
is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user
registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now i'm going to create a div class for
every field
so
say div
class
equals form group
i'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tab will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right so this we have to do for all
the other fields
so let me just copy this
and
paste it like four times
i'll also add the tag pre
for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type submit
and let's just say submit on the button
so now uh let's go ahead and change
these values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have password so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our uh
user registration form ready
but i would like to
align it to the center so let me just do
that
so here in my css file
i'm just going to uh
align all the div tags to the center and
the label tag to the left so let me save
this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have a registration
form with a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
ng model
now this directive when added into the
input tag
will
provide form controls to every input
field
all right so here let's just go ahead
and say ng
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this
and back in my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like ng untouched ng pristine
ng ballot are added
right so this indicates that angular has
recognized the form tag and it has added
these clauses to the form as well as all
the fields so this is achieved when you
add the ng model directive in your input
tag now back in my vs code now every
form has an output property attached to
it called ng submit all right so this
property can be bound within a method
that method called the subbit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just save
form
ng submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right
so now we have to define the submit
method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file and let
me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
called subnet
and then here let me just
console.log
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when i click on submit it says form
submitted
all right so the next crucial step is to
generate javascript representation now
we'll have to make use of another
directive called ng form
that is assigned to a template variable
okay so this javascript representation
helps with validating all the fields so
i'll help you understand that better
so back in our html file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right
and say ng
form
okay
now the mgform object includes the
javascript representation so now while
you're calling the submit method you're
going to pass login as a parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file
again let's just say login
and along with it
i want login to be displayed so
i say login again
so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's click on submit
and now here you can see the javascript
representation
so
within form
i can
check
for
email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it
untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now um let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty and the form only accepts names
with the minimum length of 2 and the
maximum length of 7
all right so here in my input tag
i just mentioned required meaning this
field cannot be empty
and min length
to
and
max length
to say 7
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when i submit it
and i look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name
you can see that
an error is shown here it says
required equals true
that means that there is one error
now you can make use of these form
control objects
you can leverage form control objects to
ensure field validation and display a
message whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid
or touched all of these properties or
objects need to be accessed for that
we'll have to create a template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable
let me call it
name
and
let's say
ng
model
all right here the variable name
receives the control
object
so here back in my browser when i submit
again without
the first name
you can see that the invalid
property
is set to true
correct so this helps us use this
property to alert the user with the help
of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code
let me create another
div tag
within which i mentioned ngf
within which i'm going to use a simple
if logic
so let's say mgf
name which is
our
template variable
name
dot touched
and
name dot invalid
is true
right then i'm going to alert
so i'm gonna
make use of an alert
here let's say
alert
danger
all right
so in my css file i'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're going to have the background
color red
for
danger all right
and here i'm going to display the
message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement
say suppose the length of the first name
is too short then you can alert the user
with a different message or
suppose they have missed out on filling
a form field then you can again alert
the user so you can basically make use
of the nested if condition right now
just to help you understand that better
let me just show it to you
now back in my html
file instead of invalid let me have
another
tag a paragraph tag
within which i make use of ng if again
now ng if
name dot errors
dot required
is true
then i display the message
first
name
required
all right
and
if
the length of the first name is
not two
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then i'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot min length
if this is true then i'm going to say
sorry
short
first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when i proceed without providing the
name it says first name required
but when i type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if i type in
another character it accepts so i hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now i highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects uh trust me it's really
fun
so i hope this tutorial helped you out
i'm sure you all know that an angular
app is divided into several components
for example you have the logo component
you have the sign in component an image
component and say a create account
component
now these components are standalone
and each of them represents a part of
the user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
accessing the database
or rendering images on the view
tasks like those
now instead of having to write the code
for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
they're injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it
now the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it components make sure
that whatever is being rendered onto the
screen is right and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so now let's talk about a few features
of angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells angular that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the back end
now for example if you want to make ajax
calls you can have methods to those
calls in the service and then use it as
a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module
i'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo
so in the next section we're going to
look at a demo but before that let me
tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee id and
their email id
will create a database of say three
employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employee's details
so without delay let's head to our vs
code and start learning angular services
hands-on so here first i've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
within which i've created a file called
hello world
so this was previously used for a
tutorial so the name is just hello world
so don't get confused
however when you look at the browser
i've written
an initial code here which is angular
services and i have the simply learn
logo
so back in my browser this is what the
ui looks like
so uh to
so to understand the concept of angular
services
first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here i'm going to say ng
g c
e info
i'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app
file we have the e info
component which has these four files
so if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then i highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so i'm just typing in the command ng
g
service
here g stands for generate
and we're generating a service and the
name of the service that i'm providing
is data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be
a dot ts file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service
all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file i'm going to
create an array
that displays the employee information
in our case i'm creating uh three
different employee records so for that
i'll have three different arrays
so let me just call the arrays info
received
one indicating this is the information
of
first employee
and this is going to be of type string
and i'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and i'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of that is all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
i'll have to create a method again i'm
creating three methods for uh the three
different employee records
so i'm going to call the array get
info
from service
1 indicating it's again for employee 1
and
i'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
i'll tell you how the information is
being received
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records
so let me just
copy paste and here
i'm just going to change
the name of the methods
all right
so this is the initial code for
retrieving information
however we'll have to create the
employee record in our service
so back here in my
data.ts file
what i'm going to do is
i'll create
three different records
for the employees
so let me say info 1
which is going to be of type string
all right
and
let me just give a random names say for
example i say john
matthew
all right
and
employee id say
e
and let me just give a random
email id and say jm at abc.net
all right so i'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh records
so let me just create another one and
call it info two
and the name of providing is say rob
listen
with a different employee
id say 673
and i'm just gonna make it
rw at abc.net
and another record
for employee number three
and
i'm just gonna say rose adams
with
some employee id
and
an email id all right
so now we've created the employee
records
so what i have to do is i have to create
a method
that returns these employee records
correct
so for that i'm just going to create
another method called get info 1
which is of type string
and it just returns
this dot info 1
all right
similarly for the rest of the two
records i'm just going to retrieve them
[Music]
let's say in 4 2
and get info
2. and again
i'm just going to make it get in for 3
and this is going to
return
in 4 3
all right so i'm sure you've got an idea
as to what i'm doing here so basically
this information is going to be
retrieved in our employee component
correct so for that i'll have to make
use of dependency injection so here i'll
have to import the service that i've
created so let's go ahead and say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data dot service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular
that when the component is created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks and for that we'll also
have to include this in our providers
area
so here
let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so this property basically allows us to
access all the methods that are defined
in the service class
all right
so here in my constructor method i'm
just going to say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here i'm just giving the
name d service
all right
and which is of type
data service
all right
so now with the help of this property i
can retrieve information from the
service
class so here i'm just going to save
this
dot
info receipt
equals this dot
d service
dot
get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service which returns the
information of the first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next
two methods i'm just going to use the
same
piece of code
let me just change it here
and
same for the third one
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the ui for it
here in my html file
i'm going to create
an unordered list
and now i'm going to make use of
the
ng
for director
to uh basically loop over the record and
display everything
so for that i have to make use of a
particular variable so i'll just say
let info
[Music]
of
info received
so
you can check here in our ts file the
array is info received correct so i'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first in
employee record i'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a class
a bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
info
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here as well let me create
a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right i hope this was clear to you
so basically here
the information is being retrieved with
the help of this method right that is
get info from service one so in order to
call this method we'll have to bind it
with a button all right so that's what
we're going to do
let's just
copy this and here i'm going to create a
button
all right
and the type
is button
[Music]
with name
button again
all right so i'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when i click on
it
this particular method gets called
all right i'm just pasting the method
here
and finally let's just provide the name
employee 1
for the button
all right
so similarly we'll have to do the same
for
the other two records as well
let me just make this look better all
right
so what i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna
paste the same
twice
and here i'm gonna just change
the names i'll say 2 here
and this is again for employee 2
and i'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employee i'm sorry it's
going to be in 4 received 2 this is
going to be in 4 received 3
and finally employee 3
all right
and lastly we'll have to include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main
component
or html so here
let me just
create a custom tag all right and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that three different
buttons have been created
for employee one two and three and when
you click on it
it retrieves the information that is
the name the employee id and their email
ids so we've successfully created an
angular service and injected it into our
component to retrieve information all
right so now the last part of the use
case that we discussed
was uh to add another detail that is the
employee detail in the record
all right so for that we'll have to take
uh input from the user and in our case
we're taking the location
now we're also adding the same location
for all three employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can tweak the code a little bit
and you can change the entire uh view of
your application you can add information
you can delete you can retrieve you can
alter etc
all right so for that what we're going
to do is back in the html file we'll
create a form
that basically takes the input
so i'm just going to say um
[Music]
form
all right
within which i'm going to be defining a
div class
div tag
inside of which i'll have
the input tag
of
type
text
and
the name i'm going to be providing it
will be location
all right
and we'll have a value and i'll just
leave it blank and finally i'll have ng
model so if you're confused as to what
i'm doing here then i suggest you watch
the angular forms
video
it basically teaches you uh how to work
around with angular forms
all right and now
after this we're gonna have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
and i'm gonna just say add
info okay
all right so now when i'm creating the
form i'll also have to create a
template variable to access all the
values within my form
so if i have to access the location then
i need a variable to access it so here
let me just go ahead and create a
template variable
let me call it
frm and i'm going to make use of the ng
form directive
so this tells angular
that
this variable can be used
to
access all the values within the form
and since i'm using form here
i'll have to import it in my
module
file
so here
i just go ahead
and say
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
i'll just say forms
module
okay so i've imported the forms module
so now uh back in my html file
what i'm going to do is that i'll have
to make use of this template variable
to update my information correct so i'll
have to create another method that will
update information into the records
so here in my component.ts file i'll
have to create another
method
and i'm going to call this method update
info method
all right
and
this basically takes in the template
variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do
is that it updates
the record correct so i'm going to say
this
dot
d service
add info now you must be wondering what
ad info is
i'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that i'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've uh
provided as an input which is nothing
but form
dot value dot location
all right so now
what happens is that i'll have to again
specify what ad info is and this method
is going to be defined in the service
file correct
so here
i'm going to create another
method that's add
info
and i'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays
so since i'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info one in photo and
info three i'm just going to say this
dot info one dot push
off info
[Music]
all right and uh the same for
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right
so what exactly i'm doing is that i have
i have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also i
have to return it so i'll say return
this dot info
one
all right
and i'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls uh the
add info method in our service
and passes the value to it and in my
html file
also note that the button type here is
submit
and not button
so what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
passed on to the method that is update
enforce so here
i'll say ng submit
and
i'm going to call the method update
info
and i'm going to pass
frm
as
the argument
and now let's save this
and
execute so all right here you can see
that we have an input field and a button
saying add info
so now i can just go ahead and see type
usa
and when i say add info
and when i check on my
employee 1 details usa has been added to
the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so i hope this a simple demo on angular
services helped you understand the
concept better i highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of html css and
javascript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
pages it is a free and open source
project based on github and originally
created by twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of handy reusable bits
of code written in html css and
javascript
it's also a front-end development
framework that enables developers and
beginners to design quick and responsive
websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid
you don't have to spend time working on
your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page these
components could be navigation bars drop
downs progress bars thumbnails etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive
user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application
so let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it
first up is by using the bootstrap cdn
or the content delivery network
now this enables users to load css
javascript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jquery and other packages and
frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that i am going to be
showing you i have embedded bootstrap
using npm all right so i'm sure you only
understand the concept better when you
look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what i'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post
so uh let me show you what we're going
to be doing
so here i've created a simple
blog
for simply learn and i've added the
simply learn logo i've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer i've also mentioned their tag
line and when you scroll down you can
see that i've mentioned the different
courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course
so this is for lean six sigma the same
for full stack web development
as well
and uh the same for the last one that is
cyber security
and finally i've added a simple video
here to just make it more uh beautiful
so i've added a simple video
and lastly i've also
linked our youtube channel so when you
click on the youtube icon
it will navigate to the
youtube channel
to our youtube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating
using angular bootstrap so i'm
hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in
so first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that i'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog template
and i'm just going to click on the first
link that i get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like
so i'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that
you can then click on live preview
and once you do that
you can just
say view frame source
so here you can see that the html code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags and then you have the title
and then you also have the css file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the
ui there's code for navigation bar and
then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that
and lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
html file
so that is the best practice that
angular uses so we're going to make use
of components
and you can also see that
when you scroll down you can see that
it has certain dependencies so here it
has the bootstrap dependency and then
you have jquery so we'll have to
download them
so we'll have to install them
and as mentioned earlier we're going to
be installing them with the help of npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code i've created a
folder called angulardemo
and then i've also created a file called
demo components
and here
i'm just going to say cd
demo components
within which i'll say npm
install
jquery
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jquery go
ahead and type npm install
bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jquery and bootstrap
so now we need to add the references to
these javascript files to do that
go to your
angular.json file
and here we have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so in our
scripts array we define the relative
path to these javascript files
so these files are generally uh stored
in your
node modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and
then in your dist file
and then click on js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well i'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my json file in my scripts
i'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to uh
make it a path by providing by providing
forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for jquery so here there's
jquery and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min
so again let me just
copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here
in the beginning they've also included
the css file so we'll have to embed that
as well so
here back
in
bootstrap
let me just add the css file as well
that's
bootstrap.min.css i'm just going to copy
the relative path
and just provide it here
[Music]
let me just change these
to forward slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to copy this
and just paste it in our
[Music]
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so i think we've added all the
dependencies
and the custom style sheet and
everything so now let me just
close all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and
take the code from the
source here so i'm just going to copy
the body tag
all right
so
i'm going to copy this till the footer
and then i'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier i will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the ui in these
components
so
let me just see if i've got everything
here
okay
so i'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be
to display the courses that we're
providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components i've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so i just have to
type in the command
ng gc
first we'll create
the
component for the top navigation bar so
i'm just saying ngc so i'm just gonna
say components
slash navbar
[Music]
all right so
the component has been created so what
i'm going to do is i'll just
copy this
and paste it
[Music]
here all right and the next component
i'm going to be creating is for
the introduction right so i'll say ng
g
c
[Music]
components slash
intro
all right so
so i will have to take
this code here i'm also going to be
including the call to action part so
i'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
so let me do that and then i'm going to
have the main course content
component so for that i'll say nggc
components slash courses
and we're going to copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until
till the footer
[Music]
let me just add it here
and finally we're going to create the
component for the footer so
i'll say ng gc
[Music]
components slash
footer
and the last part of the code i'm just
going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
html tags for these components and then
place it in our html file right so first
one that we created was the navigation
bar so here
head over to the ts file
just copied the selector
and then your
and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags
similarly for intro
i'm just going to copy the selector
and then for courses
so
yeah app hyphen courses
that as well
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
paste it here
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything
is displayed intact
so here let me just say ng
serve so when you execute the command
you can see that the template is being
displayed so you have the navigation bar
you have the
intro component
and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component right okay so now
that we have the template ready we can
go ahead and customize it according to
our needs so now i'm going to be making
a few changes to the code we're going to
add the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tag line here we're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that i'm going to be
doing
is changing the message here i'm gonna
display simply learn for that
in our navbar component
let's go to the html code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
all right
so when you save it and when you look at
the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that i want to do is
i want to add the image right i simply
learn logo
so what i've done here is i've already
added
the logo
dot png file in my assets folder
so i'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this
so that's going to be in our intro files
so here
image source
is going to be
assets
slash
logo.png
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change
this part of the ui so the information
that i want to display is this
i'm going to be displaying
walls number one online boot camp and
other information so what i'm going to
do is back in my vs code
i'm just going to delete
this
and instead of that i'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online bootcamp
and then within the paragraph tag i'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that i
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message i'm going to display a
explore programs message so let's go
back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then
lastly
instead of this message here
i want to display the message get
certified get ahead with our programs so
back in our vs code
i'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
so when you
have a look at the browser
let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message get
certified get ahead and all of that
uh well now what i'm going to do is i'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so i'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here i'm just going to mention style
and then say font size
and i'm going to make it xx large
all right so let's see
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so i think i'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in our vs code
we'll have to go to the courses
component
so here i'm going to just uh type in the
code for the different courses so i
already have it here
so the first thing is this message that
i want to display let me just copy that
and for our first tag i'm just gonna say
post graduate program ending six sigma
and the next information i'm gonna be
providing is the duration
so here let me just get rid of this
paste that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the
code
and then
and here for our reference link i
already have the link here
so i'm just going to paste that so once
you click on the
more info button it will automatically
navigate to this page
all right
so let me see this
next up i'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says postgraduate program in full
stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also
provide a blind break
and then
link i have it here so
i'm just gonna paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card
i have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core and
paste this instead
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
[Music]
all right
so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that
the information has been added you can
see it displays postgraduate program in
lean six sigma full stack development
and cyber security so once i click on
more info it leads you to that
page
that shows the overview all right so now
the next thing on the agenda was to uh
display a short video and then the link
to our youtube channel so let's go ahead
and add that in our
courses component
uh so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to get the code to add a video
from google and then i'm going to
provide the source
which is going to be the video that i
want to display
so i've received the code i'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on google so
go ahead and just paste that
also for the source i have a video in my
assets folder which i have provided here
so when i save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
[Music]
and once clicked it starts playing
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for youtube and then
the link to navigate to the youtube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again i've pasted the code for
the youtube logo so here you can see
that i've added the image that is
youtube.png in my assets folder and i've
provided the source
and accordingly i've also added
the styling i've provided a white
background and i've also aligned the
text to the
center of the page
all right and i've also displayed the
message saying check out our youtube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then i provided the link to our
channel on youtube
so let me just save this and head back
to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the youtube logo
and we have the message displayed
so once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
channel on youtube
all right so
if you want you can also change the
message here for the footer
so here in
footer.html i can just
remove this and
paste this i say simply on solutions and
all rights reserved and i save it and
look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go so with the help of
bootstrap we have successfully created a
website which is basically a blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you uh
make use of bootstrap and embed it into
your angular
for more responsive and better user
interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now i am sure that you observed that the
url changes every time you click on a
particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create single
page applications
now these applications are loaded just
once and new content is added
dynamically
applications like google facebook
twitter and gmail are a few examples of
single page applications the best part
of using single page applications is
that it provides an excellent user
experience and you don't even have to
wait for new pages to load which by
extension makes single page applications
extremely fast but how is this new
content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now i'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it hands-on
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our visual studio code
so basically the objective of our
application
is to navigate to home
and the login pages
so when i click on the login icon here
it loads the login
page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it some new information
gets added and the url changes
with the slash home appended
all right so this is the main objective
of our application so to create it let's
head back to our vs code all right so
here i've created a folder called demo
and underscore angular and i've created
a file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added
now although this is generally
added when your app is created if it is
not then add a base tag with href
attribute which is set to a forward
slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the url while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your
app.module.ts file and check if the app
routing module has been imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your imports array
with that the initial setup is done
now to create the nav bar the code that
i'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap i highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so the code is already available i'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it
and paste the code in it so let's do
that
let me say
nggc
navbar
[Music]
all right so this component is now
created
now here in my html file
i'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go i've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file
i'll just remove all the
unwanted
code here
and just specify the
custom html tag for my navbar
so
let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when i open the browser
the navigation bar has been created
along with
these different options that's home
about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content
now again i have used bootstrap to
define the user interface for these
files you can easily find the code
online just search for
bootstrap login templates and depending
on your requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create
the components for by two files that is
for the home component
and the login component
so
let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
ngc
i'm just going to call it login
for my login component
all right and then i'm gonna say nggc
home
for the home component
all right
so i'm just going to copy the
code for the login component
so back in my login.html
file
i'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that i've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the photo message
correct so here we're going to just
paste the code for all of these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what i'm going to do is
i'll just
paste it here
so this basically has all the content
one thing i want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this i've just
added all the code in the same component
now i agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom html
tags in your home component
i'm just hoping you're following me
right now
and also here in my assets folder i've
added
a video and the youtube logo that needs
to be displayed
when the home icon is clicked
all right so now that we've created the
home and the login components
the next step is to configure the routes
for the application
all right so here you can see that we
have a file called app routing module.ts
file
so here
we have the routes and the router module
that is imported
and we also have a constant called
routes which is strongly typed to routes
from the router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application now each route is basically
an object with a path
so here in my routes array
i'm just going to go ahead and create
the paths that is we have two different
routes right one is for login and one is
for home
so i'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
i'm sorry within curly braces i say path
and then the path that i'm going to give
is
login
this is basically what will appear
on the url all right
and the component that needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
component as you can see the login
component has been automatically
imported
now same with
the home path so let me just say
path
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the navbar that is the home and the
login button right so we're going to
make use of the nav tag and an anchor
tag for this
you can see that we have a nav tag and
an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives
from the router package called router
link and router link active
now these are specified within the
anchor tag
the router link basically holds the path
to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more css classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just
add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're going to have another
director called
router link active
[Music]
and we're just gonna save
active here
all right
same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and
instead of home
the path we created for this was login
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your ui
now despite of all this
how are we specifying where these
components are to be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router outlet directive now again this
directive is available in the router
package so we have to add that in our
app component.html file
so here just go ahead and type
router
outlet
all right
so with that we've created a simple
navigation bar which has different
options that is home about services and
link and once the user clicks on the
home icon it displays the content that
is in the home component dot html file
and once the user clicks on the login
component it displays the content in the
login.html file
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's go to the browser and see
if it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once i click on the home i can hear
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have
the intro section we have the courses
section and the footer section as
discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our url you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component so
we've successfully created a route here
and for login component when i click on
this icon
you can see that the path changes here
and the login component gets displayed
all right so this is how routing is
achieved in angular today we have a very
interesting topic coming up and that's
called our fronted interview questions
as we know it very well
in today's scenario especially for the
front end we have multiple topics
aligned
and interviewers ask and expect lot many
common questions
to be answered
by the participants
so we have brought some very common
questions which are usually asked in
interviews
in web development front
as we know it very well in our web
development we have a multiple
technologies are involved
especially when it comes to
html
css
javascript angular and many more
so we have brought some really very nice
questions along with the answers to help
you to clear those interview questions
so let's get started so
here
what is there inside for you so we have
one very common topic for the version
control system that is called a git
second we have a called html5
third it's all about css3
then we talk about javascript
then we have a react.js
followed by angular
and generic interview questions
these
six
very important topics
are used
in web development
so
people expect that you are aware about
some very common questions which they
usually ask so let's get started
so we are going to talk about version
control system first what do you
understand with version control system
so as we know it very well today when we
talk about call
a kind of team which work in different
environment different computers so they
want to store
their work in a centralized repository
system
okay so that they can keep track of what
they have done so that they can
understand who have made the updates and
when to roll back
in case if some problem comes up
so you would like to push
all the necessary repositories to the
centralized system that is conversion
control system
so it is telling you
it is a system that keeps track all the
necessary changes
made to a file or a set of data
okay so it ensures that everyone work on
a most recent system
okay
while taking care about your necessary
updates
next what is the difference between a
centralized and distributed version
control system
so as we know it very well
when we talk about call a centralized
system
okay so in central system what happens
like here it uses the centralized server
to store all different version of files
usually we always commit those changes
to our local system but in centralized
system it helps to protect in case of
any failure happens in your local
environment so it can easily protect
okay so developer doesn't need to save
any file local to their system
okay so the main idea is to basically
avoid
single point failover and keep
everything under the single location
now when it comes to the second option
called distributed version control
system so what they're trying to say
that every developer has a copy of all
the versions
while developing a code so it actually
improves the ability to work offline
and does not rely on the single
locations for the backup
okay so there is no even threat for
server crashes
that's the benefit of centralized
version system
now
my next question is like just explain me
the get push and get pull how they're
different
and how they are differentiated from
each other
so we know it very well when we talk
about like a git push
so push is trying to commit
okay some changes whichever are made
into the local file system to the
centralized repository
okay so whichever cloud environment you
will be using it it could be either
github or else you talk about bitbucket
or else you talk about gitlab
so you would like to push
all those necessary changes to that
location and pull on the other hand is
responsible to pull to retrieve all
those version controlling to your local
environment
clear that's the benefit and that's the
difference which comes
okay
now
going ahead
and talk about
the git pull as i said that you try to
fetch
the real data from your local repository
okay towards your local repository
whichever is there available in your
cloud environment
so we say the git pull is a combinations
of two command
git fetch followed by the get merge
okay
so now
next question
give us a few git commands and their
functions
okay so there are few commands which are
there the first command is like in gate
config
so in git config you basically configure
your username and email address that is
really helpful whenever you would like
to push
the repositories in your cloud
environment
get in is to
initializer get repository get add is to
basically add
the files to the staging areas
git diff to view the changes made to
this particular file and we have called
git commit
okay commit means water changes
to the head but not to the reporter or
to the remote repositories
now the other commands are also
available i can get reset which is
designed to undo all the changes
whichever we have made to the git
repository
we also have a git status to know about
the current state of the working
directory and the staging area
we talk about like in get merge
okay so that means that you want to
merge a branch
okay
into a active branch
so get push so this is the command
through which you will be upload the
content from the local repository to the
remote repository git pull is to
basically fetch and download the content
from the remote repositories
now
next thing uh the difference between git
pull and the gate fetch so when we talk
about like in git fetch so get fetch is
only downloads new data from the report
remote repository okay so it does not
integrate any of its new data into your
working files
okay so git command or git fetch can be
done at any point of time to update the
remote tracking branches
clear that is a great fetch on other
side when you talk about called gate
pull so git pull updates the current
head branch with the latest changes from
the remote servers
okay so the git pull downloads the new
data and integrates with the current
working directory files so it actually
tries to
merge the remote changes with your local
ones
so that's the difference between get
get fetch and the git pull
now the next question comes here is what
is the merge conflict in git and how it
can be resolved see the merge conflict
is very very common when you have the
common data is available
between the branches and at that point
of time which one to take which one to
avoid so in such kind of scenario the
conflict automatically comes in
clear now so you actually does what you
go back and manually edit the file and
decide which particular portion you
would like to keep and which of the
portion you would like to discard
so that's how the git merge conflict you
try to utilize it
now when we talk about the git merge
conflict how it can be resolved so we
have a pull request which is available
under the repository name when you click
it there
so in pull request actually
you click to pull the request with a
merge conflict which you would like to
resolve so it need so in the near bottom
of your pull request the click resolve
actually conflicts
so you decide which one to keep which
one to basically
avoid so that something which really
make your life even more simple to avoid
the conflictual or in case in
confliction comes how to basically fix
that up
okay so you can see now
this kind of
messages like in greater than less than
and hyphen equal to sign this would be
shown
at a time of resolve
okay so you basically decide which one
you want to take it so if you have more
than one merge conflict in your file you
just scroll down to the next set of
conflict markers and repeat the steps
okay or four
point five resolve the merge conflict
will be taken care and once
it is resolved it will click as a result
which will be ready to get
update to your existing branch
that's how exactly the merge conflict is
really
made up
now so once you have resolved all the
merge you can see the green color signal
that says like okay there is no
confliction available or no more
conflict in your program so you can
simply
merge the entire base branch into the
head branch okay so to merge your pull
request you click merge pull request
okay
so get much conflict it arises when you
have a multiple branches when they are
trying to merge with each other so there
are some common set of data or files
which will be available in both the side
so at that point of time it needs to be
avoid confliction so that's how it
really works
so
how you can resolve it so you can also
resolve the merge conflict using command
line so you simply open a git bash
and never go
to this particular repository where the
merge conflict is actually occurred
and then
it generates the list of files which are
actually affected by the conflict so in
this particular example you can see
there's a one style guide dot md file
which has a god merge conflict
so you basically shoot up some command
okay so you open it in any editor like
in vs code editor atom so you go to that
location open this particular file
and manipulate and decide which one you
really want
and likewise you'll be in position
to resolve all the conflict and
discard all those changes whichever
you're not interested in
okay so that's how the merge conflict is
already taken care of
okay so what you're doing it right now
you are adding
your files to the stages by saying git
add dot
and after that you're committing it by
using this commit
so now you can merge all the branches
with using push so those changes
okay to your remote repository on your
github and merge your command in a
public host
okay so that was a quick idea about how
you can try to resolve the issue of
get
conflict
okay so the next question comes here
that is called what is git stash
so what is a git stash so imagine we are
a developer and he's working with the
current branch and wants to switch the
branch
okay to the another branch
okay to work on something else
just imagine and after that what happens
but you don't want to commit the changes
to your unfinished work because the
changes are not yet decided so you
really don't want to commit those
changes to your unfinished work okay so
the solution is called what
is git stash
okay so it basically try to takes your
modified tracked files and saves it on
your stack of unfinished changes that
means these are not committed properly
so that you can reapply at any point of
time that is called git stash
so what is the difference between get
merge and get rebase these are a very
common question see suppose it says you
are working on a new
feature of your
project and in a dedicated branch and
another team members updates the master
branch with some new comments
okay
and
what is happening now so to incorporate
the new commits into your feature branch
like you have already initiated one job
and your team members have already
initiated the job in a parallel
branch and you feel okay you want to
merge both the features together
okay so what you will do so you're going
to create a extra merge commit every
time you need to incorporate changes so
to pollute your feature branch histories
so here what is happening now is an
alternative to merging
see as an alternate native to merging
you can rebase the feature branch into
the master
so it incorporates or whatever the
changes you want to incorporate
all the new commits in a master branch
number one and it rewrites the project
history by creating the brand new
commits for each commit in the original
branch
that's the
difference between
a git merge and the git rebase
so
git is as you know it very well it is
designed for the centralized repository
system
and
from the remote repository or from the
local repository you can basically try
to update
or retrieve
whatever number of records you want
okay so to make it possible
about the gate we have some
i would say commands available like
i talk about like in push we talk about
like in pull
so what is the difference see when you
talk about like in push you sends the
commit and ask them to update their
branch
this actually requires that things to be
right on their end
i'll be clear and the pull command on
the other hand it is nothing but a call
retry which is called a kind of fetch
which gets the commit and has
your get update to your report or remote
tracking
and get you there all latest updates
are we clear now so
let's go ahead and talk about how we
gonna be implementing this
okay so first of all i will be going and
creating a new empty repository by
saying get space
in it
so you can see it is initializing the
empty git repository inside this
and now i would like to create the new
file and keep it inside
okay so if i have this file with me
okay
i'll put it under this or any file
whichever i want suppose if i have this
call
this
okay and i put it under my get demo
okay it is there under my git demo now
now what i can do
i can just use this statement like
get
space
status i can see my one file and i'm
saying git space add space start
and once again i'm saying git status all
files are now tracked
and now i talk about
git space commit space hyphen m
are we clear now all changed and now i
would like to push this
to my
remain repository so i have this command
with me called
you know git branch hyphen main as you
can see now
so
just see the commands here which we have
it because i have a repository available
in my remote location so i can say
get space branch
okay space hyphen
m space main that means i want to put it
in our main branch
okay
so now it is done and i'll be talking
about git remote where i want to add it
so this is the remote location
so
i need to make this remote location
available
paste it
okay and i can say get space push
okay hyphen u
space
main
now you can see it is uploading and it's
saying writing object and the records
has been successfully
taken
okay
so this is how you're able to
get all those into your application now
you can see
we have this react case study.docx is
now available to us
now we have an option called pull
request
are we clear so what it is saying now
we're going to pull this request
okay so i can just a new pull request
okay so it is telling you
compare and changes the branches across
you want
okay so let me go back and change first
of all i go back to my code
which is
get the em
and here
whichever the name i have it
i just use
the file which i have it now
i say
git space
pull
okay
and now you can see
it is taking it up
okay now you can see the word is being
taken and that's what the pull is the
pull actually calls the git fetch which
gets
a commits and has your get updates
your remote tracking name and then runs
the second command to update your branch
so the second command can combine the
parallel development so this is how the
difference between
push and the pull
everyone so now we're going to talk
about some of the very very common and
useful commands
provided by the gate and their practical
usage
okay
now the first command which we always
use it with the git okay that is called
git config
we talk about like git
config so this config is basically
provide
the configuration because if you want to
push
or pull the repository so it should know
about on which username and watch email
so we talk about
the set the author name and email
address
okay
with your commits it is very very
essential
okay so
whenever you try to perform a commit it
basically keep all the names and email
associated so we say git config
hyphen global
and you provide user name
and then you provide the username
and in a similar way you provide the
email i just copy
and here you provide what user dot
and now in space you can give the
username and here you provide what email
second command which we know it very
well that is called git space what
init that is for initializing the
repository as you have already seen
next we talk about like a git space
clone
okay which is responsible to obtain the
repository repository from the existing
url the one which you have already taken
it up
then you have recently seen the command
in my previous example that is called
git space add
okay space file name
okay
or you can use asterisk astriq means add
all the files and file name will be the
specific file you want to talk about
you've already seen one command name
called what git space
commit which is to commit the records
into your repository we have also seen
git space what
status to know about the current status
of my repository or my
you know the statement like
in which particular position it is it is
untracked it is dragged it is committed
so those status i want to know that
clear now so
you talk about another command that is
known as call git space reset
what this command does so this git reset
is basically unstage the file
okay and stage means earlier your file
was staged now it is unstaged but
prevents
okay or the preserve the file contains
it doesn't delete those contents but the
reset means what it does reset unstaged
when you say talk about add it's staged
when you say
reset it unstaged but it basically can't
keep all the necessary data within that
are we clear now so these are the
necessary commands are there
comes along with your get point
hello everyone so now we're going to
talk about our next very interesting
area of the gate that is called
what is the merge conflict and how to
basically resolve that
okay see in every situation where the
work can be paralyzed
in every situation where the work can be
paralyzed will work will eventually
overlap
sometimes two developers will change the
same line of code in two different ways
in such cases git can't tell which
version is correct that time you have to
decide
okay so to work with the
merge conflict okay so git gives you the
clue like say like i have got two
updates which one you want to keep it so
that you would like to make it now so to
make this possible we will be using the
system now to make it possible i would
like to create a one simple example of
avoiding the get merge or sorry the git
conflict so first of all i will say
ls hyphen l nothing is there so we are
saying get space
in it it will be initializing the
repository lsi for l it would not be
showing any
you know the
hidden repository which is created but
certainly in my vs code editor i can see
it is created for me that's perfectly
fine
let me go back and create the new file
here
okay and
i just create using
echo
this is new redmi file
okay and the file name will be what
dot md
okay you can see this new file has been
created now
okay so what i'll be doing now
i can go back and change
some
content inside this
okay so
first of all let me check cad space
redmi dot md i can see this is a new
file with me
now i can say get space
add space
redmi dot md
okay
and after that i can say
get space
commit space hyphen m
i can say redmi
at it
okay
we can see now one file changed and then
all done
so we just talk about git space
status it says on branch master it is
the
okay so
that's it it is there now let's go back
and create a new branch now so to create
a new branch what i'll be saying i'll be
saying git space
checkout i'm gonna create a new branch
space hyphen b
okay and i'm gonna give the name called
okay plans to create
conflict
okay so we're saying git space checkout
okay space hyphen b and we're just
giving that name here
okay so we're just saying
so let's check about what is there
okay so we've created
status
conflict
and the branch will be created and it'll
be shifting out there
so you see like we're saying switch to
the new branch branch to conflict
and if i want to check
by saying get space
branch so i can say my current position
is branch to conflict okay and below
this we have this statement to me
now what i can say i can create
uh the changes inside my readme dot file
okay so
what we can do now here in this
readme.md file i can go back and change
by saying
on
the branch
okay this is an edit on the branch
and
what we can do now
we can once again just check
git space
get space status
we can see the file has been modified
now
and i can just use git space
commit
okay space hyphen m
space we can give a value call
on branch
okay
now you can see
this is telling you
to change
okay
so
we're saying one file change to
modifications
modified but yes we haven't
add those to make those changes so we
just need to secure space add space
okay and then
commit it and now you can see one file
change to insertions
not is working because i did not add
those
and once it is done then it will be
switching back
to our master branch so
right now readme.md have those changes
i'll go back to my master branch we say
get
checkout
master
now you can see if i say git checkout
master it is having the older data which
is available to us
okay and now i can just make the changes
once again here i can say this
is
master
okay now i can call getspace
status and i can call
git space at space
readme.md
and we can just say
get space
commit space hyphen
m
updated again in master
okay
and
you can see it's done but now when you
talk about like emerging
that the challenge will come
now if i just talk about git
space
branch
so it is in master branch right now so
if i want to merge
the
master branch with this branch so what
i'll be doing now
i will just use this option like in what
git space
merge
okay and we have a call
branch
okay underscore two
underscore
conflict
you can see now conflict came up
are we clear now it is saying auto
merging it's a conflict content
and you can see immediate it is telling
you they say except correct changes this
is the master and this is an edit
i'll be clear so at this point of time
you have to decide which one you want to
keep and which one you want to avoid so
if you want to keep the which one
that
on edit which is done in a child branch
what you can do
you can basically keep those
okay and let those changes will be done
by your application
okay so now when i say
you can say
okay and that's it so this is how
exactly the merge conflict is taking
place
okay everyone so now you can tell which
of the file you want to make
so that's how the final file which is
available to you and that's the beauty
of what
the conflict changes i hope you're all
clear
okay so the get interview questions are
over now we are heading towards
html interview questions
now here are a few questions like what
is an attribute in html so you can
consider the attribute are the
properties that can be added into the
html tag and that changes the way the
tag behaves or it is displayed
okay so you can see here you have a call
button
okay so attributes are added right after
the name of the html tag so button is an
element for me it's not an attribute
okay
so what is the marquee in html file so
mark is something which keep on rotating
okay they say
for scrolling down the text page or the
text on the web page mark is used
sometimes you might have seen when you
want to display some very important
information
okay which needs to scroll at the bottom
or else the right after specific period
of time you always use marquee it is one
of the very very old
element available under the html page so
it scrolls the image
top left right center automatically
everywhere so you always use marquee
tags for rotating it
so the next is what is the semantic and
html see semantics are htmls are nothing
but a call another coding style
okay so
when we talk about a semantics so they
are basically reinforcing the meaning of
the contents like typically you have
seen we are using div and span tag but a
different span tag really don't make
sense to us as an edge table reviewer
unless i go inside those and get to know
about what they're really doing it so
semantics are nothing
but
these are the standard tags
i'll be clear so you can see like here
like bold tag is not useful for the bold
statement
as well as the italic tag is used for
for what for the italic tag so instead
of we are using
strong
and em tags
are we clear now so this makes more
sense to us
now the next thing is how do you display
a table in an html web page so obviously
we have a got table tag
and under the table tag i can
align the complete layout of my web page
because of table head table body
table row table columns there are
multiple different type of elements
which are available
okay which are the part of table it's
just to basically align the content in a
proper format
what is svg
okay so svg is basically known as a kind
of a graphic which is written in a
typical xml language the svgs are the
high quality graphics which doesn't tear
off when you basically grow
and increase
or zoom so normally what happens gif
image
you talk about
jpeg images
after beyond certain point that pixel
get deteriorated but here in svg it
never happens so you go to any level
when you want to zoom and you're gonna
get accurate contents at any point of
time
okay so these vector graphics
are really typically 2d base diagrams
and give you the x and y coordinates in
a regular
systems next how do you separate a
section of text in html
to
separate the sections of text in html we
always use what either br
or else we use block code or else we use
what a paragraph tag so br means anyways
it separate out a text
and break the current line
paragraph is used to again write a
paragraph of text and the block codes is
used to define the large quotation
sections
okay
next is how do you create the nested web
page in html
so obviously we have a different type of
options that are available like an
iframe okay you need to say page within
a web page
okay so we can create a page within a
web page with using iframe this is a
very very common questions we used to
receive at the time of interview
okay the difference between ordered list
and unordered list
so ordered list will give you the
different
ways to display the data
in roman format in numeric digits or
else you can talk about like an
alphabetical order but the unordered
list is completely unordered you don't
get any options like an order list
okay so the ordered list start with
ol and
unordered list starts with
ul
uh in our html demos i'm gonna start
with very first file that is known as
called table demo
like how we can offer you
the table
related tags inside the html so table as
we know it very well it is designed to
organize
your contents or give you the proper
layout
so it is a very old technique we are
using
to align or to prop define a proper
layout
so this html page
will start working with the very first
tag that is called table
within this table we will be using tr
that is called table row under this
table we'll be using th call table
heading
and inside this table heading we're
gonna give call
name
like this i copy
and here we say
uh employee name i say
fitty
or i can say name city and we can say
department
three parameters i have it now so called
three different headings
and these headings are getting closed
and we're going to start working with
another table row
and here we'll be providing the data
so again another tr again we'll be
having this td in this 3d we can say
admin this will be the first
attribute we're going to use it's called
admin
followed by another properties
we say
admin
mail.com
department i can say hr
or
will try to copy this again
and have
few more rows
i can say
now i can say admin i can say
atul
here we say
okay so
here we can say
finance
so this
is going to give me the data so called
what table data so we're giving td
so here let me see how the outcome will
be
so
in finder
there we go now you can see it's going
to give me
the proper look and feel for how
the table really looks like in
so that's a quick example of table but
yes if you want to organize a table a
little bit more better
are we clear so this you can apply some
of the styles on the top of that like as
you can see here we have a called table
so we can just use
inline style that is called style equal
to
float
colon write
if i do so
i will see some difference you can see
it is on right hand side by default it
will be on left or
there's no center
no nothing it will be either left
float left
okay
so like this you are going to offer
the table so this is a very simple
example of like how the table can be
created within your html
next after this table
we gonna go ahead
uh with some new ideas well if in case
if you want to make this table even more
attractive we have some options with us
by offering some styles this example
will be seeing it in our upcoming demos
in a css so that is the table demo which
we have recently seen
going ahead we'll be talking about like
and how we can offer you the svg scalar
vector graphics that is there a feature
under added under the html 5.0
so how you'll be adding it let's take a
look
let me add a new file called svg
demo
dot html
here let me add a template
and here onwards
we'll be adding this svg so svg itself
is a tag
okay so we're using this svg here
and this svg we have to provide
some
standard
width and height so we say
width equal to
100 and we just say height
equal to
100 that's you're providing with the svg
here if i try to see the outcome
because it would not show right now but
certainly we can add it and see what we
can apply over here so we have a called
svg
let me add the first property called
circle
okay
so
in this circle we'll be offering
the
x and y coordinates so we can say cx
equal to
i can say 50
x
okay and
we also use cy
equal to
once again
and uh followed by our radius equal to
the way you want
so within this i'll be offering the
stroke the surrounding part but let's
see
you can see it automatically came the
best part is like if you
expand or zoom at whatever level it
won't go down and that's the beauty
okay and here we can attach
the
some color strokes whichever you want to
give it here that we can give it so
here
we say stroke
okay
and
this is a circle
so
we would like to offer
the other properties so this will be the
stroke for me
so rather than writing the separate
i can better attach it here
stroke equal to you can just say
black and we can use this option like
any stroke width
stroke hyphen
width equal to you can give three
and followed by you can use fill
color which you would like to make it so
i can just say pink
like this
okay that's it let's check
awesome this looks beautiful
that is one of the basic example of like
how you can use this svg
okay so now we're gonna talk about our
next feature in a same continuation to
the html i'm gonna talk about something
called how you'll be separating it out
the sections
of html page see html page comes with
loads and loads of data now how you'll
be separating it out now how you'll be
arranging it properly to tell like okay
this particular section contains this
related data so in html5 we have a one
beautiful feature comes that is known as
called semantics it is a feature of
html5 that not only helps
the
google that is which we talk about
called search engine optimization that's
called seo but also
to
make the developer's life even more
easier to
understand the contents what is their
benefit so
let's go ahead and talk about our next
feature called how you're going to be
separating it out so this one's called
semantics so we're gonna talk about call
okay semantics.html
here we will start working with the same
html tags with us
so here we will start working with
the data so we always have some
predefined tags called
we will call header
okay i can say this is
header and after this we have a call
footer you can say this is
photo so this is how you can see more
meaningful
we talk about like a nav
you see like it is a nav we can say this
is
menu
nav
okay along with this navigation we can
also offer call section
okay so under the sections you can have
an articles
okay so
we can say
uh
under the sections let's talk about call
article
so article we can say this is
one
okay and
we can say this is article 2
and we can create n number of sections
in my code
okay and
after that we can have
summary
okay
which can defines the
for details elements so like there are a
lot many available are
a lot many are available
so if you can just take a look to the
semantics you really won't find any
difference but yes
it is a separators
okay so used heavily inside the html
based applications
so that's how you are defining the
separators into your code so
it looks more even
easy to understand what is there under
so that's how we define this
layouts
well
coming to the next area of our html
we're gonna talk about something called
how you're gonna be defining
okay a nested html page
so nested html page we have a feature
that means page under page
so
that's
called
iframe
iframe is a feature
okay that helps the user
to define
the page under the page and how do we
use that let's take a look so under the
body section
okay i will be offering iframe
okay so i can just use h3
i say
iframe demo and within this i'll be
using
iframe tag you can say iframe src
equal to i can just give
the name of simply learn so you can just
go ahead
sorry running wrong so you can just see
the simplyland.com that is the website
so i can just copy this
okay and
offer this iframe src equal to
https simplylearn.com
okay and
that's it so we have a call frame border
i really do not want a frame border if
you want you can just add the initial
value
clear and you can talk about call style
in a same level
okay so
you can just say
style in style you can also offer some
other type of details too
okay let's see how we use it
so here we are talking about our style
part so style you can just say height
so height you can define how much height
you want so i can just say
300 pixels
okay and also we can offer the width so
width i can say again
300 pixels
so these are the properties are there
let's check
how it really looks like in so here in
our
nested
now you can see we have got this uh
simply run refuse to connect because of
some you know
connection issues so it works but you
can see like how
it is showing you
uh in your application
to have a quick look
okay so that's an idea like how the
iframes are used
inside your code okay so you can
also offer some other type of tools like
you can say
here
uh
if i say google.com
see it gonna show you like this
okay because of security issues it is
not
if i you just go to the inspect area
you can say console they say cross
origin
same origin so this issues normally
comes
okay but anyways that is how i told you
to use this frame into your code
well going to the next area
of this html that's called defining the
list
now this is once again very interesting
area of
html
okay where it you're gonna get the
different set of
uh display if you want to display the
data in the form of list so if you have
a form of array you want to display this
in a form of list you can certainly get
it so html has got inbuilt tags
available for the list two different
type of tags that are available one is
called ordered list or taking for
unordered list
ordered list always starts with over
yeah it always starts with oil called
ordered list under this will be using li
that stand for list items you can give
the items like i'm talking about like in
soap
okay
and another one i can just take scall
next we are talking about
machines
so that is called
ordered list so this
ordered list
gonna give you
the idea of like how the
data really looks like and you can see
now
okay and this also you can change
look okay while using this
type equal to options are there like you
want to have a numbering which is a by
default option if you want to use
alphabetical
you can see it is showing the
alphabetical roman numbers that is
called ordered list the other hand we
have this option like it you will call
unadded list and in this unordered list
you won't get any kind of sequences but
yes the data would be available to us
but there'll be no sequence
captain so here
this is called ul
yeah
unordered list let's check
now you can see it's only disks are
coming up
but there's no exactly
on the types
okay so that is the quick difference
between the ordered list and unordered
list provided by html tools
okay so we have already seen the
difference between order list and
unordered list now it's time to talk
about our another type of type of
interview questions which is regards to
your css
now
in css interview the first question they
always ask you like
how do you add css styling in html
so we have different ways to include
number one
we have a call inline css where we use
the element and within that we try to
add the css content that is called
inline css second is called external
style sheet
okay where you can just
use as a secondary or the
you know external css file and just
include it into your existing html page
okay that is the additional file which
you write it in a css and you include it
in html and third is called which is the
internal style sheet which you write it
within your html but the only difference
happens when you talk about external it
is reusable across multiple web pages
now the different type of css selectors
which are available so we have a
different selectors like a universal
selector which is available where you
use the asterisk sign and select all the
elements and offer the common style
second we talk about element type
selector where you have the specific
element name into your mind and you
offer that particular type of selector
id selector is responsible to
select the particular element without
having the proper id
class selector which starts with the dot
class
okay and having the class name
we talk about descendant selector so in
description you basically try to select
all the elements which are the part of
that
okay so you are selecting this container
and under that all the child elements of
the box
okay so we are talking about like in
what
of your
descendants director we talk about
called child combinator so in this case
you are basically trying to select all
those which is the child of this
container so you are using this
greater than symbol of container dot box
okay so selecting all those which is
having the child name called box
available then you're talking about a
general sibling selectors
with this tinder sign and finally we
talk about like an attribute selector
where you have a proper attribute
available to you
okay so these are known as called a
general css selectors
followed by we have a next question like
in what is sas less than stylus
friends these are the advanced level of
theses
used in the industry so we talk about
like it what is the sas which we talk
about like in systematically awesome
style sheet so we also have a similar
type of option like in less and many
more
okay so it says about the sas
saying that it is a systatically
awesome style sheet it is
basically taking the complete css to the
next level
so that is a third-party website but
once again it is very
awesome
css which can
offer you the mathematical functions
as well as the reusability
you talk about less
okay so we talk about linear style sheet
where you can see all statements which
starts with at the rate sign
there in sas every single variable start
with a dollar sign
then you talk about stylus it is also
flexible css so it doesn't use add the
rate or dollar for any defining
variables we can just directly use this
with the name
okay and use it at any point of time so
these are the three very popular
new or next generation css
so explain box sizing property like how
you can offer
the property for the box sizing
so here so
box sizing property actually defines how
to basically define
height and the width of the box which
are calculated
so you talk about the term name called
content box you talk about padding box
and you talk about border box typically
we use three different type of box
content padding and border box
in a content box these are the default
width and the height which can apply to
the elements
content which are there under the
content box
okay
padding box are here you talk about the
dimensions which are added to the
box elements of the content padding
third which is available called border
box so here the dimensions added to the
content padding and the border
now what are the different way to hide
the element in a css
so we have a different way either we can
use display none
that means whatever is there inside a
dom it won't be visible to you
second option is visibility hidden that
is another property through which you
can
the visibility but the thing is like it
is not visible to the user but this
element is added to the dom and takes up
the space
but in display none it doesn't load in a
dom so somewhere to
when you want to talk about performance
display none is anytime better
and second call position absolute so
this can be made to appear
outside the screen so three different
options are available
next option
what does that important css mean so the
important keyword actually indicates to
the highest precedence and it overrides
the cascade properties
okay so like as you can see here we have
a call paragraph where we have a color
call
important and there's someone id name
called think color called green so when
we talk about pid equal to what thing
so it automatically tried to override
the highest precedence
okay
now
what are the css sprites css sprites is
a technique where you can basically take
a
larger image
okay
download in a single shot and try to cut
down to the pieces and utilize the way
you always want
okay so if you're using this small small
images
separately
okay so to load those images
independently you would be making
multiple http calls which can be an
overhead
so it is good to basically download this
uh lengthy image in a single shot
clear and utilize them as per your
convenience within your application
so it is used to minimize the loading
time of your web page by combining
multiple smaller picture into the single
image
okay that's what the css sprites are
so which properties used to underline
and strikethrough and the overline text
so we have this option
text style
text type text decoration
text transform
okay so the text declaration so the text
decoration is the one which will be
helping you to achieve this
so i would like to demonstrate some of
the css related features the very first
feature is
like how many ways are there to add css
inside your code so
here i'll be creating the new file name
called index
html
okay how many ways are there to add
a css into your code
so there are
three different ways are there okay the
number one which is known is called
external css internal css and inline css
external css means you have some css
features externally used and that you
want to make it available locally okay
let's take a look
here i'm going to create the new file
under the css demo that is known as call
style start
3ss and here we can write some normal
styles like you can talk about body
in this body we can just say background
color
equal to let's say pink
okay and i want to include this inside
my local environment so here in my head
section
i would like to use
link
okay so you can see we have an options
available name called
link real equal to style sheet hrf equal
to style but my class name is styles
let's say styles.css and check how it
works
so
here
you can see now the background color is
changed to what to
pink that is called external css the
best part of the external css is to give
you the reusability factor so if any
other html file want to use the same
style it can be easily used
second is called internal style sheet
internal style sheet means you will be
having or some some of them say it is a
kind of embedded style sheet where you
have the styles available locally
and that starts with
style tag here you define suppose h1
and in this h1 suppose if i say
color
i'm saying
suppose
blue
and here we're defining the h1
okay i'm saying
welcome to
heading
and if i just try
you can see now this internal style
sheet is utilized here that is known as
call
internal or embedded style sheet and the
third which is known as call
inline style sheet where
you offer the style
okay to the element itself which is
uh
i say try to avoid uh it is not
recommended to use because it you know
you lose out the meaning of elements
completely so we just use this statement
like in what text
suppose we talk about text so with this
we will be using this is style tag equal
to
text align and if i just use center
so you will see here
so all three styles are applicable in
the same page that is called internal
style sheet that is called inline style
sheet and this is known as an external
style sheet
so i'm sure we got the idea about how
the three style sheets are utilized
together
well going ahead and taking you towards
another very interesting area of our
css called different type of css
selectors
see ultimate goal of css is what
to apply the style on your target
elements
okay
so in css we have called multiple type
of ways
to select your elements
in css it is called css selectors
okay so css selectors are used to select
the content where you want the style to
be applied
okay so there are multiple type of
selectors are available first type of
selector you've already seen that is
called element selector
that is called what element selector
another type of option which is
available that is known as call id
selector
that means if i have a one h3
content with me and i can say this
is
heading three
and if i want to utilize here call
s3 and i say what
class equal to
give the name i can just say
s3
demo
just a name you can give any name here
if i just use with dot keyword i say h3
demo
and here if i want to apply the style i
can say color
echo that means it will be applicable
only on those particular classes which
color equal to what echo let's take a
look
there you go
okay so you got to know this is called
what
c is a selector
another option which is available called
id selector that means similar elements
can be now accessed for help of ids like
if i remove this class and if i use id
equal to s3 demo so you don't use
dot you rather use what hash
okay and give the color the way you want
suppose if i want to talk about like an
blue violate so now
you will see it looks like this
okay so
that's called id selector so element
selector we have seen class selector we
have seen
id selector we have seen now we talk
about universal selector universal
selector means what that means all
elements will be selected like it starts
with asterisk and i say
align
text align
center if i see that means all the
elements will be aligned to the center
as you can see now all our elements are
aligned to the center that means
whichever element we declare it even if
i declare paragraph tag here i say
this is
para it will equally applicable to this
paragraph too you can see now it is also
coming into the center that is called
universal selectors
last which is called group selector
where you can have
elements which can be grouped together
like i guess i can see h1 and if you
want to apply the similar style for
h1
as well as for the h4 so you can just
use what h1
h4
okay they'll be sharing the same feature
now
so if i just use this
h4
this is
heading 4
now
well
now you can see
both headings are now sharing the common
feature this concept is known as call
group selectors where you can select the
group of elements together which you
want so we have told you about
element selector where you target the
specific element id selector with the id
attribute class means you always use
with the id class
id we'll talk about universally talk
about asterisk you talk about group
selector that you're trying to tell
the group of elements which you want to
utilize it together so these are the
quick benefits and the ways how we
define it
okay thank you
okay so now we will be talking about our
next feature okay in the css that is
known as call what is the difference
between or how many ways are there to
hide the elements
okay how many ways are there to hide
elements so that two options are
available in css
to hide the elements number one is
called display none and second is called
visibility hidden
okay
now
let me try to show you this examples so
as of now i'm removing this
all records whichever is there under the
style
and removing it all okay now let's make
it very simple so it is called like
hiding the elements
we have two options either we can use
display none or else we can use
visibility hidden so display none
removes the element from the normal flow
of the page
are we clear and
visibility hidden
leaves the element in the normal flow
are we clear but occupies a space in a
dom
that means it would not be showing the
elements in your browser but behind the
scene it will take the space
so it will be quite heavy so display
none is a better option compared to the
visibility hidden
both options are designed to hide the
elements let me show you very simple
example here
so first statement what i'm trying to do
is
here
i'm defining this
ex1 and this ex1 we are using this
a
space href
equal to
hash
okay and we're using
style
okay in style we are saying
display colon
none so i won't be displaying it
okay and
here after that i close this
and i say
unseen
okay
after this i am breaking it
here
fine and copy the same
and pasting it below
you say like ex2
well
ex1 is saying what display none
and style here we are not using this
rather if we saying
which option we are using
this visibility and this visibility will
be checking
visibility hidden
in such case when i try to run the
example
you see like both the options are not
visible but when i say inspect
you can see here
it is saying display none visibility
hidden so you can see here in this
example both options are not showing
okay so the answer is very clear to us
none of the hyperlinks are showing to us
because that's where
the conditions are
okay so we understood about the
way
how to basically hide the elements
from the browser
there is another feature friends coming
up
in
the css front and that is called a
feature called property called important
so important is again a type of property
it is a rule in css to add more
importance
to a particular property than like a
normal value
so important will try to override all
the previous stylings
and give
the next available value to your element
now let me show you how it really works
so just imagine i have got
this
body tag and in this body type we ever
got
h1
we can say this is
heading one
okay like this i can copy
and paste
okay so this is heading one heading one
three times i'm playing it now
now in this case uh i may have multiple
classes are also available this is a
like normal i can say
equal to
i can use
head one
okay and here also i'm saying
rather than using class
okay i can use what id
equal to
head to you can change the name as you
want
and here what i can do is in my style i
can use this first option
for id that is called
head to
okay
i can use one more that is called
head one
so two properties i have it head one and
head two
and we can also use h1
as like a normal property
head two we can give this
for id i can say
background color
i say
pink
head one
i can just use background color
red
and here what i can do i can override
the properties
so what i can do here in my application
i can zip h1
here i say background
okay color
and here we can just use as a what
as i call brown so if i say brown in
that case and if i make it as an
important
like i say
important by saying accelerometer mark
important so what would happen just take
a look here
you will see it basically replacing all
the colors with what
with
brown because i'm making it as a what
other
important and i say it overrides or
overrule all the previous property if i
remove it
okay so it will be changing it
to the different color and here
i just use what dot
and here i use what
hash
head to
is the id so i can just use hash here
and here it is what
dot now
you see they will be having their own
dedicated colors
okay i say like this but if i just make
it as a what
important
and i use it as i call what
green yellow so you can see
it'll apply the green yellow to
everywhere
okay so that is an important problem
let's override all the previous rules
that's how the css is
okay everyone so our next example
is towards
focus on javascript interview questions
now here we have free questions are
available like what are the various data
types in javascript
so javascript contains different type of
javascript data types like if you think
about
all different types which are there
generally
byte short int long
float double character boolean these are
all different type of data types are
supported inside a javascript
okay
now
going ahead what is the callback in
javascript so the callback means is a
function
okay that is passed with another
function as an argument on a parameter
okay so what is the callback callback
means don't call me i will call you
clear so the idea is like you are
passing
the function itself is a parameter to
the another function because the
javascript is known to be called
non-blocking which never wait for the
code to finish it continues to move on
and due to some reason if your
function it's taking some time
to
you know
execute so javascript won't wait for
that particular function to finish so
you use callback to prevent such
behavior
okay that's called a javascript callback
now what is the difference between
function declaration and function
expression see this is called
function declaration
and you talk about a function expression
function declaration is just to declare
a
separate statement within a main
javascript code and
you can be called before the function is
defined
okay it gives you the better readability
where the function expression are always
created inside the expression
okay and
it is created when the execution point
reaches it
are we clear and it is used when there
is a need of for a conditional
declaration of a particular function
now what do you understand about the
cookies in a javascript so it is one of
the very very common question cookies
are the one which is created by the
server stored in a client side which is
responsible to store all the necessary
client activities so that the browser or
the application give the better
recommendation to the user
okay so it is just a
small
text file
which is stored in a browser itself
okay if you want
to record something about a user
activity you always put it like that
and you can also define
the expiry time for the cookies okay as
per your convenience to decide how long
the cookie wants to be there inside your
browser if you do not offer any time
span by default you will get lost
immediately the moment the browser
closed
next what are the clauses in javascript
so closures are the javascript is a
feature where the inner function has an
access to outer functions variables
and the properties
okay so you can consider a closure has a
three scope change number one it has an
access to its own scope
that is defined within its curly braces
second it has an access to the variable
of the outer function and also has an
access to the global
variables now the closure is a
javascript features as i told you like
which has hana has an access to the
outer functions variable simple example
i can give it to you is
a function which is known as called
inner function
and there's a function defined on the
top is an outer function so it is having
all the functionalities access of the
outer function inside it
now
what are the imports and exporting
javascript so import and exports in
javascript is a very very common way how
in java you use the term name called
import a package
but in javascript it is little different
unless you export something you can't
import it
okay so if you want to access any of
your files properties or methods outside
of your file you always use the
statement of import
and export so here you can see you have
got
one property like an sqrt which you are
exporting it and you have one function
which is called square there is another
function called
you can say diag which you are exporting
it and importing it just the way you
always want so that is how
it is importing and exporting
what is the difference between undefined
undeclared and null in a javascript
see undefined means a variable that is
declared but the value has not been
assigned yet that is called undefined
undeclared means
like it is a null
first of all we talk about null null
means it is an assignment value that we
can assign to any variable that is meant
to contain no value and undeclared means
the variables are not declared and do
not exist in the program
okay that is called what un declared
how to remove the duplication from the
javascript array so you basically needs
to use the standard filter methods
okay this is basically responsible to
help you to analyze whether we have some
duplicates available or not
so we'll be using using filter methods
okay so these are basically what's
called array and the current element and
the index of current element
and by using the for loop it is an empty
array is used for the storing all the
repeated elements
okay so these are known as call a
typical javascript discussion which we
have taken place
multiple questions are there which we
have already answered
it's time to basically talk about
javascript so i'm going to create a new
folder now the name called jsdemos
and in this js demo we would like to
explain you
the different concepts the first let me
go and create
index
dot html and i will be creating another
file here called
demo.js well my first concept towards
this javascript is like working with
callbacks like what are the callbacks
are see the ideally as we know callbacks
are the function which you pass it
okay to the another function as an
parameter so we'll be seeing how this
callbacks really works with showing you
one very small demonstration let me have
this
html5 here and
here
we would like to use script
src equal to
demo.js
and in my demo.js i'd like to create
const
okay
get blocks
okay equal to
now
this function call
get
blogs
let me have this arrow sign here so now
here i would like to provide one
function called set timeout
this set timeout as you know there's the
javascript function which delays the
response time i'm dealing it for
2000 millisecond and here in set timeout
we are saying return
and here we will provide
property called title
colon
welcome to
js
so this get blocks is a function having
one
it is returning on an object of having
property called title and saying welcome
to js delaying for 2000
here i am saying
const
bp is just a variable equal to
get blocks
okay and here we'll be using
console.log
and here we'll be providing the property
like and what bp
dot
title so that's the property for me
now
ideally if i just check if i try to run
my code i want to see what outcome i'm
going to receive while i try to running
this
i'll go back to my browser and
just check
what works
not nothing is displaying but when i go
to the inspect
i'll see it is saying like cannot read
property title got undefined
yeah now white it happens because
javascript is non-blocking it doesn't
wait
for the function or
the
i would say the block of code to get
over if it is delaying for 2000
millisecond then title property will be
available only after the 2000
milliseconds are lapsed but here the
output is displaying title immediately
due to that it is saying like hey title
is not available because it is delaying
for 2000 millisecond
now this is the concept where the
closure sorry this callback comes where
you're passing the function itself as in
parameter to another function which will
wait till the time the job get over
so here what i'll be doing i'll be
removing this i'll be using this as a
function called cb
sorry
cb and
this
enclosed it here now we have one
function name called cb
okay which is having property called
title and i'm passing this cb as a what
as in parameter here
now this is called callback your passing
function itself is in what is in
parameter to another function
and here in get blocks what i'll be
doing it
i'll be using
get blocks here we are passing
bp as in parameter
and now
let me take this
to back to my code bp.title and let me
see
how it works
okay so
that's where
the concept really comes in so now after
two second melee two thousand
milliseconds are over respond is
available response is available let me
refresh
2 second mean 2 milliseconds sorry 2000
milliseconds the response is available
that's the concept of callback where you
are passing the function itself as a
parameter with another function
okay everyone so after this we're gonna
start working with our next area of
discussion
that is called what is the difference
between a function expression and
function declaration
okay see ideally if you check
they're actually
really similar
okay how you call them is exactly the
same
the difference is how the browser loads
them into the execution context
again i'm telling you
the
concept of let me try to create a new
file and give the name call
declaration versus
expression
so what i'm trying to tell you is
they are actually really simple or
similar
how you call them is exactly the same
the only difference lies here is how the
browser load them into the execution
context
so function declaration loads before any
code is executed
again i'm repeating function declaration
loads before any code is executed where
the function expression load only when
the interpreter reaches at the end of
the
code okay
so as i said the function expression
loads only when the interpreter reaches
that line of code
okay so once again i repeat the
difference function declaration loads
before any code is executed however the
function expression loads only when the
interpreter reaches that line of code
if you try to call function expression
before it is loaded you will get an
error for sure
if you call a function declaration
instead it will work because no code can
be called until all declarations are
loaded like again i'm telling you this
example if i say
alert
demo
i'm using this
okay and i'm coming down
okay and i'm using this var
demo
equal to
function
which says
return
hello
are we clear
so you see it is an error
white is an error you can see the error
carefully they say
whatever the reason is
okay suppose even if i put semicolon
here so there will be no difference here
because they're telling you very clearly
like this example
is an error because the demo function
was not found it is the example of
function expression
function declaration however what would
happen
in the other side
okay
it will run
i'll be clear it will run without having
any issue the way you call it's gonna
work
without having any issue
okay that is the alert demo
okay here we have a call
object which is returning here and
that's it
this is called function expression and
if i just show you about
another way around so we're just going
to say
alert
demo 2
here
suppose when we are saying this alert
demo 2 here let me
try to close this
okay it is an actually error here in our
alert demo when i say the same example
alert demo two
okay and i'm using it here by saying
function
okay and i'm using this call
demo2
okay and here
we're just saying return
is it gonna work for you
okay this is gonna work for you
that's the difference between function
expression
and function declaration so this is a
function expression and this is a
function
declaration hope you're all clear about
this
well another example which i'm trying to
show to you that is called working with
the closures
so i'm going to create a new file here
called
now what are the closure see the idea
behind the closure is very important
because it is a core concept of
javascript
the idea behind of closure means that
the inner function
okay you have a outer function you call
inner function inner function always
have an access to the variables and the
parameter of its outer function
even after the outer function has
returned
okay
now let's see
how we gonna declare this
in this example if i define one function
okay this function is called
outer okay and here defining one
variable called
oe
okay equal to 100
there's a variable declaration and after
that we are declaring the nested
function inside this by saying
function
inner
okay
and now inside this i'm gonna declare
a simple alert
sorry
a simple alert where we are displaying
the outer variable the one which is
defined
okay after this a function we are just
saying what
return
enough see inner function has already
written
and
after this what i'll be doing i'm just
going to create the object of our
inner function
equal to
outer the object we are creating it now
okay and after that we are calling
inner
function
and ideally it should work because that
is what i said the
implementation is very simple the inner
function will have the access of what
come on outer function variable even it
has been returned and that's what we are
doing it now and if i just check
how it is so here
i have a call closuredemo.js let me
invoke the closure demo
now
you can see it is working
that's the beauty of
the closure
okay so we understand like closure
example is very simple
where it is giving you the access of
external
variables
can be accessed by the inner variables
okay very easily
now i'm going to tell you about the
difference between
okay the difference between
the null
undefined and undeclared
again i'm repeating my word three
options
undefined
null and undeclared what is the
difference so here
i'm going to define a new file called
in this default.js
undefined means what undefined means a
variable that has been declared but not
has
assigned a value okay like if i just say
var a
i'm defining this log
okay let me say a so that is called
undefined
let's call undefined you're using it the
value hasn't been defined
are we clear that means the value is
undefined null means it can be assigned
to a variable to a
represent no value again null means what
it can be assigned to a variable to a
represent no value like
you think about a situation
var b equal to what
null
are we clear and if i say log
okay and i'm defining the beak
this will be null
it can be assigned to a variable
to represent no value that is called
null and undeclared means what
undeclared means if a variable is not
declared and the browser throws an error
here at least you define declare a
variable but you haven't defined the
value
and here i'll be showing what
log
and here if i just say
demo
so this is certainly a what
come on undeclared this is called what
your application will be throwing the
error saying like hey what you are
trying to access it doesn't even exist
so here the type is undefined
okay that's the differences
okay so we are clear about what you mean
by
undefined undeclared versus the null
values
now the next thing is how to basically
try
to eliminate
the
arrays duplicate values from the arrays
so if you are planning to remove
the duplicate values from where from the
array you have options with you
what options very simple
to remove the duplicate elements in an
array let me declare one simple
let
data equal to here let's define a value
like an a
like in b
okay
like on c
and once again we are defining what a so
a is a duplicate it should not be
repeated while displaying so we can just
use what let
let unique equal to we're using what
data it contains one function called
what
filter
inside this filter we are passing two
properties here
number one is just a character like in c
and second we are passing what
index
okay
and here
here we are defining return
okay the property called what
data okay dot
index of
okay here we are passing the first
character like in what c
index
that's it
that's how we are defining and let's
close this
and use
log what
the unique
okay and this demo.js we are including
in our index.js
okay and let's check this out
now you can see it is having abc
it doesn't have any duplicate elements
which we have defined now let me add
another one that is called b
again but here
you see it's really having what
the same value so this is how the way
you remove
the duplicate element from there
from
the area very simple and straightforward
utilization of the filter function
okay thank you
well let's go ahead with the next area
that is called working with react.js
interview questions
now as we know it react.js is as
important as like in other
tools which you've already seen
so what is the jsx here jsx called
javascript syntax extension
okay
so this syntax extension to the
javascript in react.js isn't the way
how you express
to bind js and html together to result a
jsx
content
so by using jsx you can write the html
structure in the same file that contains
the javascript code that is something
more innovative way because of that
react js is creating
more buzz in a market
so
jsx actually helps the making code more
easy to understand and debug and avoids
a lot of boilerplate code okay inside
the dom structure
now the next thing is what is the
virtual dom so the virtual dom is
representing a dom in a memory
okay that is called virtual dom so
manipulating the real dom is much more
slower and costly affair
okay because you need to repaint the dom
over and over the period of time
when the user changes few things
so
when the state change virtual dom
changes and only the objects which are
in real dom
okay
update instead of updating the entire
object so that makes your page to be
load far more faster okay so in virtual
dom what happens this is the real dom
this is a virtual dom so the orange
color portion which you're seeing that
is basically the changes which has been
made
okay these are called changed object
okay so virtual
dom is basically compare it to the
previous state and understand
which area it needs to send for the
updates and avoid the other areas
okay that's what this
virtual dom really works
so what are react extension react
extensions are many like you talk about
like in flux it is a third-party tool
which is responsible to attach
the state management feature you talk
about react native which is responsible
to develop the hybrid mobile
applications
in javascript so these are two very
popular and there are many more which
are available
okay so
like you talk about
architectural support you talk about
server side rendering okay so redux and
there are lot many other tools are also
available
so what is an event in react and how
you're going to create that so react is
basically offering
the ideas of handling the event
very fairly easy so that you talk about
clicking anything
you talk about taking your mouse
somewhere so these kind of options
generate an event so for that we
typically say
alert and you click on this render you
click on this button in a curly braces
you call the function to trigger
to event
now what are the components in react
so friends react components are nothing
but a call view
okay like a complex view can be divided
into the smaller portions
a complex ui can be
distributed further to create more
better and reusable views
clear so
it splits the user interface into the
independent pieces of code which can be
developed and joins
later on okay so that's how you define
the component in and react so in angular
and react in both the areas the word
component is
very much used so the component meaning
is very simple you talk about a view
so what does the state in a react so
state is react is nothing but
is the one which identify
what was and what is now
okay which stores the value for the
specific period of time which changes
and react is basically detecting those
so it is changing because of some
actions either taken by the users or by
the applications
okay so it keep tracking about all those
states what it was there like in i'm
talking about an incrementing an
encounter
so that is also the state available
there okay so the state object is always
initializing the constructor so it can
contain the multiple properties so this
dot set state is used to change
the value of the state object and set
state is responsible
to perform the shallow merge between the
new state and the previous state
now the state holds the data that a
component renders to the web page
certainly because every time the state
changes so it needs to be stored
somewhere
so this is how the state is accessed as
you can see this example here
in the constructor we are defining the
super props and the states being
initialized and you're rendering the
states there are three different steps
are involved initialize the state render
the state and update the states
what is the higher order component and
pure component react higher components
are the component which are typically a
function okay that takes a component and
return a new component to you by
manipulating few things
they're basically designed for the
reusing
okay so the higher the components are
typically a function that takes a
component and return a new component
okay so to in order to perform some
reusability
a pure components
are the components okay is a
variation of react component that
doesn't
that does a shallow comparison of props
and state
okay shallow comparison basically checks
what the equality
are we clear now so that's what the main
job
going ahead what do you implement and
how do you implement react routing so
the implemented react routing react
routing
also comes with inbuilt
uh react
modules and that particular module need
to import it
so
here we define the react modules by
offering the route path
where you have a call left hand side is
the name and the right hand side is a
component which you would like to
deliver it now
okay that's how you define it so we'll
be discussing about some of the
important aspects of react
so the very first question is what is
the component in
react see we know it very well the react
is known to be called component centric
library where the word component playing
a very important role especially when it
comes to the representation part
so in a nutshell i will say whatever you
see
in your
browser in a modern days applications
they are nothing but a called what
they are so called typically a
component and how to use those
components let's take a look at my code
so in a very complex applications
the view can be distributed to the
smaller portions and every single
portion will be treated as a what is a
component so how to create a component
in react let's take a look
so to create a component what i will be
doing it i'll just go back and create a
new folder called
components you can give any name
and inside these components i'm going to
create a new file with the name called
main
app dot js
so here i have to import one package
called import
react
from
react and here i'll be giving
component
in a curly braces now here let's go and
create a component by saying export
default
class
main app
extends
component and the moment you do so
immediately you have to
create one function called render
which
have a return
and
this return will return you the jsx
and here i write a very simple message
under the dev tag
and say
welcome to
let's put it under the paragraph tag
okay that's it the component is ready
let me include it under the app.js which
is already created component provided by
your react
and here
let's include it
and
start it by saying npm space start
and it will launch in port number 3000
it is saying like
srthintext.js is not found
okay so there are some
previous components are written
so you haven't used it
oh you can see the message called
welcome to main app
so you can see this is a very simple
example of how the components are
created
in your application
that's the one thing
now the next thing is like how to
basically go and create an event how to
launch or trigger an event in react
application
see your friends triggering an event in
react is very very simple
what i will do is here i'm gonna write
one very simple function called
call
app let me put it under
here
call up
and here we can say alert
app is called and to trigger the event
i'll be creating one very simple button
and i say
call
let me have an even call
on click
equal to
and here in curly braces
i'll be calling this
method which is called call up
okay and once it is ready let's go and
there we go you see how easy it is for
you
in react to create an event and launch
an event
okay everyone so our next example in the
same continuation
is like what do you mean by higher order
components
okay
so you need to understand like uh when
we talk about higher order components
they are the just like in javascript
function
are used for adding additional
functionalities to the existing
component
it is basically designed for reusability
okay so the design for adding the
additional functionality to the existing
components
these
functions are pure this which means like
they are receiving the data and
receiving value according to the data
okay so if the data changes higher order
function rerun with a different input
okay so
the idea is like higher order function
is wrapped around the normal components
and provide additional data of it
and that's how this works let me try to
give you a very simple example of how
the react
react offers a higher order function for
you so let me go back and create a new
file
and get the name call
hoc
okay so as usual i'll be importing the
same
in hoc i'll copy and paste the same
and
give the name call
extends component i'll remove this call
up and
render return whatever we have it i'll
just remove these two also
so this turns to be very very normal
function
for the normal component
now what i do is in a very first step in
my application
i'll remove all those i really don't
need those first
i'll say const
info
okay equal to props
it is the stateless function component
okay now here i am defining a div tag
okay within this div tag i'm saying h1
or h2
and within this i'm saying message call
info
after this i'm starting with another tag
called paragraph tag
and we'll say
the info is
something whatever it is but what data i
really don't know but i can just use
something here
now
here if i just say suppose props
dot info so you might be thinking like
what exactly the info is so don't worry
i'll help you how to achieve this
i'm gonna create one more called const
with
admin warning
okay equal to
now here we're going to create
a very simple
okay now here i'm just going to give the
name called wrap component
wrapped
it's just the name wrapped component
okay
here we are saying return
with prop
okay and here
within this props i will use again
another div tag here
within this div tag i can use the
paragraph
and i will say
this is private info
message we have written
and what i'll be doing
within this application i'll create
what red component
and within this
i'm saying
no
okay so we are basically printing what
drops
once it is over
that's it so you can say const
admin
info
const admin info equal to
i'm just gonna give the name call what
with
admin warning and passing what
the another component inside this that
is an info
that's it
so that is what we wanted
okay and i'll be saying what
export
default
which option admin info
and that's the example of typical
higher order component so you can see
this higher order components are the
components which are taking the input in
the form of component and return you
what the another component which changed
value
and that's how we're returning another
component
with
and passing what a component inside this
so this info is passed choose another
component to the wrap
with admin warning and returning this so
this is a typical example of like how
your higher auto components are actually
used
our next example is all about state
management
how to define and display the states
inside a react as we know it very well
react takes care about the state pretty
well
and that is one of the beauty of react
so let's see how we can use this state
management inside your application
so to maintain the state what i'll be
doing it
here i'll just try to create one
function called
inc
increment
okay or
whichever you want to make it so i
better use inc
for increment okay
i remove this alert
so to define the state inside your
component you always use one line
that is known as call
constructor
inside this you define props
and here you use
super
number one and after that you initialize
the state the way you want so to
initialize the state you always say this
dot
state because the state is in an object
you define this state with the value
called count
colon 0. so count is just a variable
which are initializing the initial state
with the value 0
and it will be displaying this value
right over here and say
counter
and here
to display this we'll be using this
start
state dot count
initial value is actually 0 so let me
check
here you can see the value is so zero
now i want
to
increment it value so how are you going
to be incrementing it now so to
increment this what i'll be doing is
i'll be calling this
okay this and calling the set state
function by saying this dot
that state
okay
and in the set state i would like to
check what are my previous values and
what is my current values accordingly
i'll try to make it so here i will say
this starts that state
here i will take one parameter call
ps that is called previous state and
here
i would like to say return
and here i will say count
colon
ps dot
count
plus 1. ps means previous state is just
a variable to confirm what was the
previous state of my application whether
it was 0 1 2 or whatever
and we have to call this inc function
right over here
that's it let's check
there we go okay very simple that is
called state management very simple
example you initialize the state
and after that you render the state and
after that when the state changes while
calling this inc function
this set state function will render the
updated state to the dom due to that
you're able to see this value
now our next step is like how you're
going to be performing this navigation
inside the react application
so friends when you talk about like a
navigation we have a very
straightforward demonstrations
here first of all in case if you want to
perform the navigation
you need to have the new dependencies to
be get added by saying npm space i space
react hyphen
router hyphen dawn
that's the first dependency you need to
have it
okay
and
once the dependency is ready
uh you have to go back and start
importing
some of the
portions of your code like suppose if i
create another component here
give the name call
uh
login dot js
okay that's my component name
and i'm gonna create one more component
here called
landing page
dot js
okay
so
once these two components are ready so
you'll be creating a routes
so in our main app.js or
the previous component what we have
created
okay i would like to go back and create
some data right over here
support class constructor super i am
removing it all
render return
i'll remove everything give the name
call
landing page
okay extends component and everything
and what i'll be doing is to provide the
routing on navigation
here in my applications i will try to
say
how to provide so i will say const
okay
routes
equal to
now here
i would like to make one dependency call
browser router there's some dependency i
would like to use
so here i'll say import
oh
you can see react router down this
dependency came and now i'd like to
bring the first dependency here that is
known as call browser router
that is the
location from where your navigation will
pick up
and within this i'm using this div tag
within this dev tag i'm using
route okay i'm saying path
equal to
if i say
login
okay so which component should load so
i'm saying component
equal to
which component i have it here i
recently created call login
but i didn't write anything there
so here
so let me go back and create it
remove this all
okay and writing
welcome to login and here in my landing
page when i go
i say component
i say
login
okay that means when i will be clicking
on this
i'll be getting what the login
so that is the path i've given
okay and this particular routes i'll be
putting it right over here
so that's it and this is my landing page
and i will be making it landing page
available under my main app
or if you want to make it app.js you can
make it
okay say say ng space
sorry npm space start
now the navigation is taking place
now nothing is coming up because landing
page is blank but yes i know one thing
if i try to click on login something
will come
there we go welcome to login that's a
very simple and straightforward behavior
of like how
the navigation takes place in react
applications
okay everyone so we will go ahead with
the next set of interviews which is
related to your angular
so angular is as popular like in react
okay so there are some questions which
are usually asked like what is the data
binding
okay so the data binding is actually the
process which allows
the
application
okay to have some data associated with
your
html page
from your typescript classes or the vice
versa
okay
so the data binding is the one through
which you bind the data okay so you can
see here it says like angular uses two
data binding when the changes happens in
a model it will be affected in a view
and whether changes happens in review it
will affect the
model also so it is used
to typically keep the model and view in
sync with each other to have the data
interchange
what is the typescript typescript is a
typical
i would say
a language which is used
by angular
okay to develop angular component
services pipes decorators and multiple
things it is a superset of javascript
and it supports
javascript libraries and apis it is a
pure object oriented in nature uses
object-oriented principles better
development time fast to load and
additional features to the javascript
for sure
ok
what is an aot compilation how it is
different from jit aot stands for ahead
of time compiler which is converting all
angular and html and typescript code
into the javascript code during the
build phase before the browser downloads
and run the code
okay so aot
is far more faster and light weighted in
the size just in time compiler is a by
default compiler
okay so
it is a process where the compiling
computer go to the machine code during
the execution of runtime
so this ensures the faster rendering the
browser it also known as called dynamic
compilation
are we clear so when you want to develop
this aot compiler you always use hyphen
hyphen
aot
okay so here you always use
jit compiler because that is a by
default compiler used when you say
ng build
next what are the pipes in angular so
pipes means that they are the decorators
they
never change their default value but
just for the representation purpose they
change the values
okay
to look more better the way they always
want
okay
so pipes are ready made or else it can
be customized created angular also comes
with lot many predefined pipes
okay like it comes with the pipe symbol
here
okay so you can chain the pipes together
it can be provided with some arguments
at the run time with the colon sign
okay
now you pass the input
you put the pipe and get some result
with some decorated outcome now you can
see the pure pipes uses the pure
functions
clear so this pipe doesn't use any
internal state and the output remains
the same as long as the parameters
passed to stay the same angle calls the
pipe only when it detects the changes in
the parameters being passed
a single instance of the pure pipe is
used throughout the all
components
okay so this is how
you see how the pipes are being used so
we have defined the pipe
okay which is the value called truen
falls for the pure and giving the class
by implementing pipe transform
so
you can see here the impure pipes
for the say for every change detection
actually happens in an angular an impure
is called
are we clear with regards to the changes
in the input fields
okay they will be calling every time so
multiple pipe instances are created for
the same for these pipes and push pass
to these pipes can be mutable by default
all pipes are pure only if you want to
make it impure you always say like pure
colon true
or
pure colon false
now what are the promising observables
in angular see
promises it is a typical javascript
object okay it it emits a single values
at a time they execute immediately after
the creation and not cancelable
their push error to the child promises
okay where the observables are only
executable when subscribed to them
they won't call unless you subscribe to
them using subscribe methods so they
help perform operations like it for each
filter and retrieve everything when you
unsubscribe this they won't get called
and won't listen anymore
what are the form control center form
groups see the form controls and form
groups these are two predefined objects
comes with your
angular
so these all text boxes
from you take the input it may be radio
buttons it may be the drop down it may
be the check boxes are called form
controls
okay so form controls is a class that
enables the validation for every single
input class
whichever you are creating it now so
they check
the values which are touched untouched
or the dirty
clear
now we talk about call form group they
are basically forming a group which
under which you have a call relevant
fields joined together or called what a
form group
okay so form group class represents a
group of controls like you talk about
address contain city state and pin code
these all three can be together called
as a form group
okay so the form group class basically
return true if all controls are
basically what
the valid
okay and they are
designed to provide all the necessary
validation errors
what is the eager and what is a lazy
loading
okay
so eager loading means what it is a
default module loading strategy followed
in an angular
eagle loadings are used before the
application starts
these are typically useful for the small
scale applications
lazy loading however is designed
for dynamic loads of features
only on demand
this makes your application far more
faster so in a bigger application we
really don't make easy eager loading
because it hamper the performance and
you want only when the client asks you
want to use lazy loading
what is the string interpolation in
angular
see string interpolation is written
under the double curly braces it is
typically one way binding where you get
the data from the typescript classes and
display directly over your browser it
denotes with the curly braces and it
always
display the data comes from the
component to the view in angular we have
two very important areas to discuss like
number one
what do you mean by
string interpolation say string
interpolation is very very simple
statement like you are
talking about a one-way binding
string interpolation is a one-way
binding technique which is used to
output the data from a typescript code
which is a ts file
so whatever data you keep it on your
typescript we want to make it available
to the browser for the representation
purpose you always use
double curly braces
as you can see right now we have one
property called company name and we have
a call
my company and if i go back to the html
i can say this company name right now so
this company name is written in double
curly braces and here
it contains that value
now if i just give one more option here
call
my city
okay equal to if i say pune
and if i go here if i want to display
the city
so i can use
my
city
okay so if i go to the browser you can
see it is showing me this
so that option is known as call what in
string interpolation you can basically
perform
some other activities to like in case if
you want to perform some calculations
that also you can do like you can see
here we have got
num
one
okay equal to
and you say
num2 equal to 20 so if you want to do
that here you can say
and that you can put it
numplus to num2
and you can see now it is giving the
calculation
so that is something which is known as
called string interpolation
that means whatever you would like to
make it you want to display over your
browser from the ts file
the next activity which comes in an
angular that is known as caller how
you're going to be deal with and how you
will be dealing with another concept
here called
pipes
see the pipes are basically designed for
the formatting purpose so whenever you
would like to perform the formatting you
always use pipes without changing the
core values
okay so in case if i'm planning to
display some records or some data
okay without compromising the original
value i'll always talk about what
pipes
so pipes are always designed to give you
some more meaningful messages like you
can see
predefined pipes different type of pipes
are available here we talk about
predefined pipes which start with this
pipe symbol
and you put
uppercase if you put an uppercase you
can see
all letters
mean
okay
here let me terminate the server and the
other properties are also two
like in component if i go and put
okay and we talk about
rating
okay we say
doj
equal to
date and if you put it in
like this if you put it
and those well if i want to format it as
usual
they'll be showing in a normal format
so formatting can really change the way
they should look
like just imagine here
i'm writing it as an uppercase
in a similar one i can display
some other details too like i copy this
and i'm using
one more property here called income
and this i put it in a number
or currency
which will be showing me the values
where in a currency
again
i talk about
this rating
okay i can
change it to number
and also i can perform what
some basic
customized calculations like suppose
rating is
six 4.9867 i want to
trim the post decimal values to two so i
can say two dot two minus two
it'll be going like that so we can talk
about date of joining so if i just go
here
we say doj and i put what
date it is a predefined pipe it really
make a difference
in your existing applications
let's check
here
let me refresh my browser
you can see now how the codes are
looking like it
so they are basically different set of
pipes which are provided by the
angular to make a difference in your
application hope you are clear
and some generic interview questions
like you can see about what are the
advantages of typescript over the
javascript so certainly we know that
typescript is a superset and give you
the better benefits over the javascript
it is fast super loaded features better
understanding code looks like in typical
c plus and java and offer lot many
features like interface generics and
many more
how a web developer different from a web
designer certainly the web developer
build a web application using html
css and javascript web designer
basically use all the other tools like
an adobe photoshop and other tools
so frequently you use javascript
framework for developing a web-based
application which may be client-side and
server-side you really require good
coding skills and you have to keep
yourself updated with your latest
frameworks which can create a better
effects into your code where in a web
designer is focused only on talking
about trends color patterns and all
so webbed is a developer having much
more better hand over the web designer
so what is the back-end developers
back-end developments you talk about
developing a server-side applications
like in java jsp php
you're writing and developing the apis
where the front-end application can
communicate with and it ensures the data
integrity and consistency and involve
writing lot of scripting where you can
communicate with your backend
application and the databases
okay
what is the coffee script it is once
again a type of
scripting available
okay which is not used further but yes
it is a type of
a language
okay where you can write the javascript
code into so it attempts to demonstrate
the positive points of javascript in
very very straightforward manner
so you can write a consistent javascript
code
and getting much more better advantage
over the traditional coding
how would you ensure that a web designer
is a web designer is a user friendly
there are certain parameters are there
you talk about
a front-end developer should work
closely with the user experience team so
it gives the same design what the user
is actually expect
they should test the application
regularly while taking the inputs
so the application developed
should be compatible with the different
platforms and the different screen sizes
would you recommend a web designer role
or a web developer role certainly we
talk about call web developer role
but it really a matter of preferences
okay if you are
more inclined towards creating the end
user experience
i would suggest to go with the web or ux
designer role if you focus on writing
everything together
okay towards more into the coding you
will certainly step into
web developer
how you would increase the page
performance there are certain parameters
you need to consider html document
should clean up
external http request could be minimized
sprites compressed images and the
smaller image would be included at the
bottom of the page you should put
javascript rather than on a head tag
optimize css javascript and html
caching on cdn
okay
and so with that we come to this
complete full course tutorial on
front-end development
i hope you found this helpful if you
have any doubts or queries regarding any
of the topics covered please let us know
in the comment section below
thank you so much for being here keep
learning and stay tuned to simply learn
you